[Music]
do
with temperatures simmering outside the
eyes of the chess world have turned to
madrid spain
the best players in the world have made
their way inside the palace of santonia
to begin three weeks of intense
competition
the winner takes home the lion's share
of the half million dollar prize pool
and the right to challenge for the world
title
it's day one of the 2022 feed a
candidate's tournament
chess.com exclusive coverage starts now
madrid
civilization here
is almost as old as the game of chess
some claim the queen was given her
powers to honor queen isabella
that my friends is a chess legacy
passion for chess continues to thrive in
madrid
for the first time in 30 years spain's
capital plays host to the candidates
the most important tournament in chess
at the palace of santona the stakes are
high
eight of the world's best players
competing for the right to challenge for
the most coveted title in chess
the world chess championship
the candidates is grueling
the winner requires mental endurance and
unbreakable focus
there are those familiar with the
biggest stages in chess
yet still chasing unfinished business
and others from the next wave of stars
with little patience for yielding to
those before them
[Music]
miss amigos
the next challenger to the world
champion of chess must come through
madrid like queen isabella before them
the candidates is all about leaving a
legacy
[Music]
we are outside the palace of santona
we are about to go
inside the palacio desentonia for the
2022 feed a candidate's tournament
coverage on chess.com begins right now
and boy are we excited as the live
audience
already starts to fill in the players
getting set to fill in
we have so much ahead so much in store
there you can see our official spanish
broadcast with a few early birds already
sitting in the seats speaking of early
birds we have been here all week we were
here early and we are getting ready to
party now because it is game time it's
go time i am joined by the amazing grand
master young love big hammer
international master elmira kripchenko
this is the candidates and it starts
right now hammer how excited are you to
be here i'm i'm really happy uh i i'm
really thrilled to to be able to come in
and i'm actually a substitute for robert
hess i believe
you brought it up uh yeah
almir and i were going to say this looks
a little different than robert than what
we're used to seeing well it's not easy
to fill in rubber shoes i guess it is
not easy to fill in a guy who you can't
spell chess without honestly yeah
honestly i'm surprised you didn't just
cancel the whole event when robert
couldn't make it but i'm happy to be
here and and fill in
z was canceling the entire candidates
because robert has came down with covid
again our best wishes to robert he will
likely be joining us later in the week
uh let's let's continue
you're also very excited to be here you
this is not your first candidate it's
for me and hammer this is our first time
you're the pro you've commentated on the
candidates before but how excited are
you to be here in madrid well i guess
this time it will be less dangerous than
the last time you know i i did the
commentary for the second lack of the
last candidates you know that was the
longest candidates in the history of
chess
and actually still i'm so excited the
kid inside of me screaming like i'm here
i'm here because you know i grew up in
the soviet union watching carp of
kasparov matches uh like hearing the
stories about the candidates so we are
witnessing history today we absolutely
are witnessing history and last night
you and i witnessed something that at
least for me it was the first time going
to an opening ceremony for an event as
prestigious as the candidates and so we
put together a little bit of a highlight
reel for those who maybe weren't there
and missed it speaking of one person
over there who slept instead of joining
us
but here you go we're gonna we're gonna
take a little bit of sneak peek to what
went down last night at the four seasons
in madrid
[Music]
good afternoon
ladies and gentlemen
and welcome to the opening ceremony of
the world chess championship candidates
tournament
this was the opening ceremony there were
many boards just like that getting
signed by the top players uh so many so
many amazing and important people in the
chess world in attendance and lots of
smiles to go around elmira what was your
what was the highlight of the night for
you
well the for me it was certainly the
flamenco performance it was a very nice
surprise at the end of the ceremony and
i really hope that the players would be
on fire you know today because the
flamenco had so much passion the dancers
the guitar
i was mesmerized my wife told me
something i should consider doing well
here is seeing a flamenco performance so
i kind of got to you know two birds with
one stone last night it was it was an
amazing thing to see hammer i know we i
know we teased you for not being there
but you were getting well deserved rest
we're so appreciative that you came at
the last minute but looking at the video
how jealous are you that you didn't get
to attend it does seem like i missed out
on a good time uh so uh next time when
i'm not
kind of just rushed from
getting to madrid very last minute
to replace uh robert then maybe next
time i'll be able to attend
well it was uh it was amazing uh hygge
also performed a brand new song
poisonous pawn uh anna rudolph was
streaming it live to her twitch channel
so many so many fun and exciting things
where we're going down and
we have so much fun and exciting things
in store this is our first show i know
we're all very excited little kids right
now a little bit nervous to get this
thing going imagine how the players are
feeling uh and of course we need to
remind the fans of what the next three
weeks are going to be about what is the
format of the candidates and why are we
here
well eight players from around the world
have been brought in eight of the best
chess players worked super hard to get
here we're gonna talk about their roads
in a minute they're gonna compete in a
double round robin which means you get
both colors so each each person you will
play twice and the winner will challenge
the world champion and for the first
time on a format card we have this sort
of third box stipulation clarifying well
what if the world champion doesn't want
to play it's funny because i guess that
was always an option uh but because of
some statements made by magnus himself
and as well as the fact that no one will
stop talking about this storyline we're
going to be unpacking this a lot today
and talking about what what exactly that
looks like and what would happen if two
finishers were competing for a world
championship so hammer in fact why don't
we just start with that you cover magnus
carlson in norway maybe more than
anybody your thoughts on this the
statement that he made and what it what
it does to set the tone here in madrid
well i i think the players have to go
from the assumption that magnus is going
to play they have to buy for that uh
first place finish because otherwise if
they start thinking hmm second place
might be good enough that will mess with
their heads and so they should just go
for the first place finish and see what
happens we're going to continue to
unpack that but your quick thoughts on
the psychological points of magnus's
comments well actually i well everyone
knows that magnus is a very good poker
player so i would definitely call his
bluff but on a more serious note of
course i i can understand how difficult
it might be to find motivation for
another match so and how difficult it is
psychologically and physically to go
through those matches so yeah but i
really hope that magnus will play
because uh if i can drive a historical
parallel it's like if monarch would
abdicate you know like it's it would be
such a tragedy
i think all eight players want to face
magnus carlsen that's why they competed
and worked so hard to get here and on
that note let's let's remind everybody
of what each individual player's path
was to arrive here in madrid at the 2022
candidates
defeated candidates is the most
important tournament in chess
taking place every two years the
candidates qualifies the victor to
challenge the reigning world champion
and a world chess championship title
match
the 2022 candidates will feature eight
of the world's best chess players
they've all earned their spots through
two years of fierce competition they now
head to madrid spain where everything
will be settled over the board
one of those eight spots is always
reserved for the previous world chess
championship challenger jan napomnishi
would love nothing more than a second
chance at the throne but he has to get
through seven other great players in
madrid first
two spots went to the top finishers of
the most prestigious open chess
tournament in the world the feedahs.com
grand swiss ali reza faruga won the
grand swiss turned the heads of everyone
in doing so and has become the youngest
player in history to cross the 2800 evo
rating barrier he would become the
youngest world chess champion of all
time should he win the candidates and
ultimately the world chess championship
match
fabiano caruana joined him taking the
other spot from the grand swiss the u.s
number one and third highest rated
player in the history of our game is
also the only person to never lose a
classical chess game to magnus carlsen
in a world chess championship match
two of the spots were claimed by the
winners of the dramatic 2022 fide grand
prix cycle
grand master hikara nakamura is a former
world number two a blitz and bullet
chess legend and the most popular chess
streamer in the world
he was joined by gm richard report the
hungarian number one is one of the most
creative and dangerous minds in the game
today and nobody is looking forward to
facing him in madrid
fide awarded one of the eight spots to
the wild card invite grandmaster taymor
rijaba
raja missed the 2021 candidate cycle in
consideration of covet concerns but as
the oldest most experienced player in
the field he's looking to use that
knowledge and punch his ticket to the
world chess championship title match
[Music]
and finally
two spots go to the top two finishers of
the world's largest knockout tournament
the absolutely grueling feed a world cup
young christophe duda the polish number
one punched his ticket by ousting none
other than world champion magnus carlson
in the semi-finals of that event
judith would ultimately defeat karjakin
in the final to win the world cup
however karjakin due to suspension from
play by fidei sees his spot go to
china's number one grand master dingley
rent
dingley rin takes the spot due to being
the highest rated eligible player
according to the may 2022 feed a rating
list
so that's how each of our eight
competitors earn their bids to madrid
inside the palace of santona it's about
who can sustain the mental endurance to
secure the coveted slot as challenger
for the world title
but we're not sure who that will be just
yet we do know this
we'll enjoy watching every minute of the
candidates with the chess.com community
as we see how the most important
tournament in chess plays out together
what a wild ride these guys had to get
here it has been such an amazing year
and now we see the participants and
their beautiful faces jan christophe
duda dingley wren fabiano carwana
jabhoff ali reza faruja hikaru nakamura
yondapamnishi and richard rapport uh
hammer i got to start with you your
favorite your player to watch of all the
faces we see before us
um for me it's got to be karana i think
he has the the best top level he is the
highest rated player uh
the player have achieved the highest
rating after magnus and kasparov at his
best he is
the best player in this field and he
also has some really extensive openings
and and clever ideas so i'm looking
forward to catching his games okay i
think many many would agree with hammer
that fabi fabi likely the favor will
unpack what that means for the other
competitors as we go but elmira your
your thoughts on on the player to watch
well then you will tell me it's an easy
peek but i will go with the alireza
ferruga first of all he's just breaking
all the records he was
now the young he's the youngest player
to ever reach and break the 2800
barrier uh he's has such an
uncompromising flamboyant style i love
watching his games and
if this what it takes to magnus to play
so for magnus to play so uh
i'm cheering okay well there is
we could preview every single player
like that i'll save my thoughts on on
maybe my favorite to win right now we
want to dive into who's going to win
today right let's talk about the
matchups and what are the pairings for
round one here we go we've uh well why
don't we start at the top hammer you've
got duda and rapport facing off yeah and
hungry yeah for me this is one of the
most interesting matchups of the round
because duda and rapport are not really
being mentioned very often as potential
winners of the event uh but uh if one of
them can get a win here from the start
that would change everything yeah uh so
so for them this is incredibly important
both need to get off to a winning start
and we'll see if one of them can can
make it i think you're making an
incredible point because judah and
rapport like you said not not talked
about that much but they're both very
exciting players very aggressive players
don't be surprised if a decisive game
comes out of that particular matchup
almira why don't we move to ding
nipomnishi and your thoughts on that one
well actually that was the
the game i was looking forward to
there are a lot of interesting matchups
but
i really want to see uh
what formed engines in because he didn't
play for quite a while especially on the
top level he had to qualify in extremis
like he had to play 30 games i guess
just to uh
to qualify for the candidates and he
beat jan at the last game of the
candidates so
it also will show like if uh she
remembers you know what psychological
state he is so it's and don't forget
young won the last candidate so yep
great points i think of course everyone
has caruana nakamura circle i'm gonna
let hammer be the first one to give
thoughts on that so i'm just gonna
quickly say before we start focusing in
on this american versus american battle
we have to give a shout out too that the
other matchup rajava versus ferruccia
the oldest player in the field the most
experienced player versus the youngest
the one who so many have their eyes on
will the nerves be getting to him ali
reza keeps saying he's relaxed not
nervous so that that's an interesting
one we'll keep an eye on but but let's
go back to the american vs american
matchup real quick and you pick fabi as
a tournament favorite your thoughts on
how aggressive he wants to be with the
white pieces against nakamura here in
round one um well a win is so important
he's gonna be aggressive but
more than aggression it's about opening
work right
do you have ideas in the openings as
your opponent is likely to play
and since this is such a classic match
up you can just see they've played each
other 45 times
already in classical games uh they know
each other and that means fabi is
probably extra well prepared against a
car
well and we'll see of course how
important is it for the most popular
chess stream in the world to not lose
the first game so many things to talk
about uh there's our
our first shot really from the floor one
of the players i think has already left
a water bottle for themselves and the
players are starting starting to fill in
that's the back of hikaru nakamura i
know that back very well not as well as
i know his facial expressions from
streaming but uh maria amrillinova the
photographer for chess.com and
so many fun things happening already
let's remind everybody that of course
games will officially kick off here at 3
p.m local time in madrid for us but no
matter where you are tuning in from
around the world here's a here's a nice
looking shot of where you should be
every day in a time zone that's probably
suitable for you whether you're at 6am
on the west coast or almost midnight
there in sydney australia
the uh
the daily action starts at 3 p.m local
pacific local local time here in madrid
and so make sure you circle circle your
time zone and be with us
you guys gave your quick
shout outs to what you think is going to
happen i'm going to quickly give a shout
out to what i think is going to happen i
saved held my breath in order to do it
live for all of you fans use the command
vote in chat you can go to chess.com
events and cast your vote daily and you
should do it daily because it will track
your results throughout the entire event
you can play along with your friends and
win cash prizes whoever has the best
voting results overall so i'm going to
start things off and ding nippon nishi
i'm going to go with a draw here much to
the chagrin maybe of many predicting
peace i'm going to take yon christoph
duda to jump out with a win
in the first game skipping back past the
marquee matchup i'm going to take our
oldest versus youngest battle to also be
a draw you see so many votes by the way
already coming in so shout out to all of
you fans in chat everybody who's already
casting their vote and now the big one
drum roll please just kidding i'm going
to predict a drive i think a car holds a
draw despite bobby's best efforts with
the first move amir you haven't had a
chance to weigh in on this yet so your
thoughts on the nerves the mindset the
psychology that both of these guys have
coming in they played each other so many
times now they're at the candidates
again what do you think is going through
their head well actually i went through
all of their games you know i'm
preparing against favi and hikari at the
same time so actually the statistics
that we have the empirical evidence says
that uh well hikaru has lost almost all
of his last games against fabio with
black so this will be a real test for
him right and what it would be his
opening choice it's also very
interesting is it going to stick with
the queen's gambit
it's a huge choice i think
something solid would make sense right
you definitely don't want to start with
a loss if you're hikaru in the in the
first round so what would be your advice
as black facing fabi's opening prep well
i i would be terrified to begin with
especially with these stats omir is
coming with that hikaru has lost several
times in a row with the black pieces
against fabiano
i think that the tempting option is to
to change your ways because you may
realize that something isn't working uh
but i i think hikaru he's he's a man who
sticks to his guns so i think we will
see the the same queen's gambit he has
popularized really at the top level the
the past couple of years
we saw hikaru taking off his jacket we
now see taymor rajab and ali reza faruja
shaking hands reminder again as we said
to all of the fans go to chess.com
events cast your vote use the command
vote do it do it now there's already
thou
i'm watching you go up in front of us in
real time more than 5 000 people have
have uh have already voted and you can
do so again to get your pardon cash
prizes and better to start now if you
really want to compete for the cash
prizes even though you should do it
every day it's a lot of fun so
fabiano carwana focused
will be making the first move
in this game with the white pieces
two americans in this event and they're
playing each other
in the first round elmira you want to
talk a little bit about why that is
that's actually a purposeful thing and
and can you expand on that this is what
we call the directed pairings you know
because we have a lot of historical
precedence like where uh
well we are trying to avoid collusion so
uh
this this is why the two american
players cannot play at the last round i
don't think fabi and hicaro would um
would collude in any way to help the
other but they're they're i mean so
there's history to that right and yes
you remember fisher you know who was
accusing the soviets i think after the
tournament in curacao and you know and i
can understand that of course those
tournaments were so long and he had to
play like as i remember four games
against each other against each opponent
so um
i think this is quite fair yeah
yeah hikaru has an issue with the score
sheet here yeah what is that uh i don't
know he asked for for a um
a judge to come look at it
uh and it seems like it's uh being
replaced
and uh we can't start until hikaru is
happy
we certainly cannot we see both players
smiling there so whatever it was
perhaps perhaps it was just too big of a
scoresheet it did look like a very large
piece of paper if i'm if i'm honest so
uh
didn't didn't see closely enough whether
they brought him a smaller scoresheet
but it
madrid and we are getting set for the
first moves to be made
and uh we see tamer job off also coming
over to
have some conversation there not sure
what that was
but okay we've got a quote from fabiano
here
it's the only thing that can almost be
compared to a world championship match
of course speaking about the candidates
tournament this is there's this intense
period of months and of course during
the tournament it's even more intense
just referring to the preparation all
that goes into it knowing what's at
stake
fabi probably not shying away from the
fact that the moment is very real kind
of the opposite of the comments that
ferruja has made about saying he's not
nervous at all elmira yes and actually i
was uh it was very interesting to follow
fabby's press conference here where he
shared that how players deal with this
pressure this is the tournament where
you have to make strategical choices
even at the very beginning
so like
he said and i was actually as a
professional chess player was surprised
with this comment because he said like
okay it doesn't matter if it goes wrong
in the first round there's 14 rounds
still to go you know you you can still
win the tournament you know i tend to
get so upset you know and it's like i
feel like the tournament is ruined and
this shows so much wisdom this is his
fourth candidate right how difficult it
is to qualify just for one candidate's
tournament then this is his fourth
appearance he knows he knows it's a
marathon not a sprint right and and i
think it's a great point
we actually saw on the photos that the
the president of the world chess
federation or kadi dvarkovic he made the
honorary first move on fabiano's behalf
and i noticed that before that move was
made fabiano whispered in his ear
and so i'm wondering if that honorary
first move
which we have on our monitors as being
the king's pawn
two step forwards will that actually be
fabiano's uh choice in which case he's
switching openings despite having an
amazing score with the queen pawn
against ikaru recently yeah it would be
an interesting storyline it's
again we
didn't know could he whisper it like to
change i was going to say well we saw it
happen during the world championship the
re i was going to come around to the
fact that there were several games where
magnus and yon for lack of a better term
trolled each other right by maybe
suggesting a different move than their
first move
will that be the case for fabiano we're
going to find out
uh it looks as though the king pawn move
is on the board yeah and carl has
responded with e5 yeah but hikaru plays
the berlin defense so it really
for me it's very interesting to find out
like
what would be a fabiano's preparation
the the berlin variation of the spanish
is considered like the most solid
opening in the history of the world and
fabiano is right now playing straight
into it fabiano just chose uh the royal
opus the spanish opening which is
fitting considering madrid i was going
to say it's it's not even just that the
berlin is so solid
of all the players in the world when you
think of experts in the berlin you think
of people like maxine bashir the grav
you think of hikaru nakamura hikaru
nakamura is he's not going to shy away
from playing his pet line okay now we
see the point fabiano going for the
quote-unquote anti-berlin if you will
with the move 4d3 yeah
so um it's it's a berlin opening from uh
nakamura
a big question whether or not he
expected this to happen in this game and
now we have a very interesting situation
where uh fabiano early on
exchanges a bishop for a night
uh
in the opening uh which is uh a very um
it's the most interesting trade in chess
but it might seem as an odd choice you
know in this position but actually like
fabian has played it already several
times and he's going for a particular
type of structure
well what's interesting is he's
he's played it many times but he's also
played the main line many times which of
course is not to capture on c6 whether
it be castling or c3 as moves that are
just as popular if not more so
just interesting to see the decision
early certainly we know the players are
bringing preparation but hikaru not
really faced and now actually taking his
first walk of the day
getting up and leaving fabi to to
remember his prep
yeah i'm i'm really surprised fabiano is
is even thinking for a second here
because so far hikaru has played his
main opening against the king pawn
opening uh he has played all the
standard moves black usually does at
this uh part of the game
and i think we're we're in for for a
treat right now i i think we're going to
have a struggle with
the players kind of comparing notes in
in a very topical opening yeah may i ask
a question because you know i'm not
really familiar with this plan but i
wanted to ask you you know more about
this position could fabi play d4 here
for example to break in the center
immediately because instead of knight p3
yes instead of knight b3 for example
just to well it's such a natural move so
i wanted to we'll show the fork that
we're looking for
exactly so uh like
why not b3 first
well actually this d4 move uh as far as
i know has been tested uh quite a few
times previously
uh and i think it was just decided that
that black would would get a decent game
and so fabiano is trying to
postpone the conflict he doesn't want to
like have his defense yeah create the
tension early on when hikaru is still in
his preparation he wants to calmly
improve his position and and create
long-term problems for hikaru instead of
testing hikaru on one short term problem
uh and then um if if he kara knows it
then you know he he makes a draw with
the black pieces which is in this
tournament just considered a tremendous
success
which once again puts the pressure on
fabiano he he got the white pieces he's
the one
who
uh who
is unhappy if the game ends in a draw
and we talk about i mean in many ways
the whole line of 4d3 is to maintain
flexibility as much as possible right so
obviously d4 has been tested and of
course a good move but i i understand
the psychology of what you're saying
hammer he's not here to play the most
forcing lines and see what hicaro has
has cooked up a draw with at home right
he's going to say the earlier i can get
a position that is out of theory and
we're both making moves playing an
interesting structure right with some
flexibility double pawns along with the
bishop pair it'll be a game a game as
they say right yeah
and i would say he has succeeded because
uh hikaru is now thinking
what do you think about that elmira i
mean if you're taken out of your prep
not to say hikaru necessarily is but
your thoughts on what's going through
your head early on knowing what you
highlighted before the game hikaru
doesn't have a good record with black
especially in recent years against
fabiano this is not d4 but
your thoughts on the nerves he might be
feeling to making sure he doesn't take a
wrong step here in the opening well i
think
well every chess player professional
chess player knows that uh well even
when you're faced with a problem or a
new opening idea you have to sit on your
hands you know you don't have to be
impulsive you you have to understand the
uh the nuances in the position
and i think that uh
that is what uh hikar is probably trying
to do now like to
regain his composure
and
simply to think about the position with
the maybe a new eye
yep
shout out to everyone tuning in we've
got 21 000 of you with us on twitch and
more than more than 10 000 with you with
us on youtube the the action has only
just begun we know that this matchup has
a lot of people very excited fabiano
carwana playing at karnakamore there are
also many other matchups i've seen some
comments in chat to check out some of
the other games don't worry we will we
will throughout the day
the uh
i guess last one i wanted to
highlight here we've got uh
i'm wondering i'm wondering is it car
now really thinking so what
what do you think is going through his
head now he's really he's shown for sure
that he is out of the opening
the thing is like well the main idea in
this opening also for wyatt is to still
to push d4 so probably what he thinks is
about the strategical idea to place e5
or not to play c5
uh yeah i i would agree putting pawns in
in the center of the board uh always a
good option
but at the same time hikaru will be a
bit suspicious
seeing as how if i have one very obvious
move
uh that's probably something fabiano has
prepared something he expects uh and
maybe there's some strategic
disadvantage to that if you go with the
pawn to to c4 as almira suggested uh
then you put uh
yeah c5 you put all your pawns on the on
the dark squares right and maybe hikaru
is reluctant to do that at this stage
uh even if it is a common plan in this
berlin opening
could be yes it could be met with knight
g5 then f4 maybe so what should he
choose in this position the standard
plan
uh also like with knight d7 as we have
seen in the previous position um
he has a lot of options and i think
that's why he's thinking yeah i think if
he were still in his preparation
uh he probably wouldn't want to waste
time at this stage i think his uh
his thinking here is is genuine uh and
he's trying to go through the
uh pros and cons of all the available
plans black has
and as you said you highlighted both c5
and 97 both of you there are a few other
moves in the position of course you can
play even this
interesting move bishop g4 wasting a
tempo
going back into a pin of the knight on
f3 has been played and of course
the obvious move like castle's also been
played here
so hikar really really thinking it
through
and we can see that the time-honored
tradition of chess
having the the kind of walkway for the
players in between the board and the
the the cameras are are being upheld in
this event as well
and it's good to see some traditions
it can be an arbiter it can be a
photographer but the amount of times
without without fail that someone walks
right in front of the camera that the
broadcast is covering it's like you
would think it is pre-planned right
actually what i wanted to say daniel
that like when you showed the different
uh possible moves they just had a look
at the number of games and it's also a
very important factor which shows that
like there have been not so many games
played after like knight b3 so it means
that it's a rare move
that's like uh so this is probably a
very big opening surprise yeah
a rare move one that hikaru is
going to be sure he knows his plan
before he commits
we saw vintage hikaru nakamura number i
think that was number seven there
looking up into the clouds
remembering opening theory if possible
how many of his uh expressions have you
numbered so i actually recorded a video
recently cataloging all of them i'm not
sure if the team has uh turned it out
yet they're working on it so um you know
you're not going to reveal i'm not going
to reveal it you're going to have to
check out the video coming to youtube
soon yeah but it can be like an
advertisement for the video it's an
advertisement for the video right there
you have to tune in but you can say how
many
how many different ones again i'm not
going to tell you there's too many
you're going to have to you have to tune
in and contrary to popular belief not
all of them have been revealed yet some
there are some new ones broken down in
the video so
yeah it's a lot of fun a lot of fun
why don't we why don't we let hikaru
think here and and maybe if we can check
in on on one of the other games
we uh we have so many games still going
let's remind everybody that of course
this is going to be a very long event we
have a lot of action ahead so do not be
disappointed if we're focused on one
game we will get to all of them with me
again of course young ludwig hammer
elmira scripchenko and uh you can go to
chess.com events to follow any of the
games yourselves if you're if you're
ever feeling that we're stuck on a game
too long remember you can go there and
uh choose your own adventure so all
right we're going to head over to
another game that had a lot of people
talking before the round dingley wren
versus yondu palmishi
we have uh a completely different
opening here not an e4 game in english
and we'll uh we'll dive in and see how
we got here hammer uh actually i am an
expert in this okay well then take it
away um so we will rely on your
expertise in this position yeah um well
actually i i have played this before as
white and black i believe uh so yeah the
the english opening when you start with
a bishop pawn okay and here black is
trying to build a big center so if you
notice the move c6
black is preparing to go uh d5 next and
just
get all those pawns
in the middle of the board uh white
tries to stop this
attacks the pawn forces the pawn forward
uh and thereby saying okay
your pawn may be overextended right this
will be my point of attack for the rest
of the game
and moving forward the trade in the
middle is made black's queen comes out
early attacking the knight
the knight needs to be careful so it
retreats
um and
now development for both players you got
to get your pieces out so knights and a
bishop uh getting in there
as well as both players castling and now
everything revolves around the pawn on
e4 this is the key of the entire
position if black can hold on to this
pawn black will be better right uh if
white can win this pawn
white will not only be better white will
just win
the the whole purpose of a3 guarding b4
makes a lot of sense too under the under
the guide of what you were saying right
white's natural moves are going to be
all about bringing pressure to the e4
pawn so a3 as much as it may not seem
like a move that prepares that it really
does validate hammer's point of course
as you said if black keeps the center
then all things are good for black as
activity with queens and brooks on open
lines
tend to be a good thing here we see the
head to head by round by every round for
dingley ren
in front of you there
good to just for all of our more
studious observers
mapping things out playing fantasy chess
if you will on what's ahead in the
candidates i especially note that his
best score in the entire field is
against uh his main competitor fabiano
carrano yeah it's interesting uh so so
if he uh wants to win this event uh
beating karana in one of the games is
probably a necessity your thoughts on uh
ding ding's approach here as white
versus nepameshi elmira you said it was
one of the games you have circled coming
in they are deadlocked in their career
well actually i've been looking at this
position and especially at the night on
the three there's for example like when
i started to play chess and uh
well there are so many positional
concepts that you have to learn and
there's
well this knight is looking very strange
but it's such a powerful piece in this
position because uh black's plan is also
to play sometimes queen h5 yes bishop h3
and knight g4
so one of the purposes of this knight on
the three years there's also well
defensive so he does not allow knight g4
and looking at knight c4 and
this is a very interesting uh
strategical positional concept because i
uh how would you develop then
android vic because
with black or with white now let's say
uh black would continue with um
well it's difficult seeing a movie yeah
actually like
that's what i've been trying to find out
what is the next move yeah
for the record i was going to say we
left opening theory officially right
back here when black played the move
castles instead of h5 at least according
to our opening spoiler which by the way
h5 would have also been a very
interesting way to approach the position
so we are we are in a spot where
presumably both players
i i love h5 because you know
that would have been a lot of fun i
agree but john taking the more solid
castles here well i don't think there is
such a thing as solid in this position
yeah i think we're going to be in for a
really enterprising game
regardless because it's so unbalanced
right now the advantage black holds with
that pawn in the center having the space
advantage really restricting the options
of white's pieces
and at the same time if you're not able
to keep on to that pawn
you might lose it and then you're you'll
be down a pawn and then it's going to be
a complete crisis so if i would to
launch an attack by playing h5 here
after queen c2 am i losing the pound
immediately yeah well that's just h5
yeah does h5 still have a plan without
the rook behind it you think yes h564
h584 okay could be like i mean
well you highlighted amir a great point
that the knight on e3 not only guards g4
for this plane of queen h5 it also
guards f5 if the bishop were to ever
come here i think that white would
probably happily snatch the bishop
before continuing with the plan how
difficult it is to find a useful move in
this position for black that's what i've
been telling myself for quite a while
and uh
quincy two is a threat
well rookie eight feels like the obvious
move
uh after quincy two you're going to play
bishop uh f8 yeah
i want to use my work to help guard my
my priced possession uh the pawn in the
center
[Music]
well we saw dingley wren's head-to-head
match up versus the field let's uh let's
take a quick look at yon napomnishi's as
he is on the clock taking a good think
you already know he's 500 that means
he's batting even here against dingley
wren but what stands out to you elmira
about any of the particular matchups
awaiting napomnishi's
candidates
well
i
have small troubles i've seen today yeah
it's it's like for me
for me it's all about how evenly now
yeah i was gonna say i guess i asked you
a trick question there really are no
match-ups that scream at you and maybe
it's why
yonda pandashi won the last candidates
right we know we know he's known as an
aggressive player
kind of a streaky player a very fast
player but his head-to-head against a
lot of the best players in the world
would suggest that he's also a pretty
solid player he doesn't have a bad
record against many
yeah but at the same time he doesn't
have a good record against many either
okay
and jan napomniochi during the world
championship match he had against magnus
carlsen he kind of cemented his own
reputation as a streaky player right
once he loses game six
in really spectacular fashion he just
goes on to lose another uh
four games i even forgot how many it was
just he was collapsing losing one game
after another until it became like the
the most ordinary thing in the world uh
so yeah when he wins he wins a lot when
he loses he loses a lot right and and
what these uh head-to-head scores can
tell us is that
um
it's all about the streaks it's not
about who the opposition is yeah so he's
capable of beating anyone but he's also
capable of leasing to him yeah no it's a
fair storyline of course we talked about
that a lot during the world championship
the fact that john could be his own
worst enemy and his own best friend
right sometimes it doesn't matter who
he's playing
but of course he is continuing to think
about what he wants to play next against
dingley ren let's back out again and
head on over to our featured matchup of
the day not to say that they all aren't
featured but of course so many have this
battle of the americans circled and
we're going to go look again at what is
happening
on the board an interesting and
interesting approach continues to
develop here we had since we left it we
had the flexible and interesting knight
b3 by fabi he took some time before
playing queen e7 more than more than 12
minutes it seems
before playing queen e7 which was not
one of the moves we highlighted we
highlighted c5 right knight d7 castles
knights don't move that way
sorry about that but he plays queen e7
and fabi
instantly responds with knight a5 well
this is a very interesting move which is
also suggested in a few uh like other
openings by computer because like this
is such a strange looking move you know
so knight a5 are you well uh he's asking
a question rugby because he cannot no
you can no longer play b6 because knight
c6 simply you know
and knight e5 and you cannot protect the
pawn so rook b8 is almost forced you you
don't want to play bishop c8 right
otherwise it's like so what is your
opening strategy about
and uh
then this knight is uh well is on the
edge of the board certainly but it's uh
sort of um
limits black's option and
maybe later in the game i will also play
knight c4
so when uh this will yeah it's
interesting
there was one other move is is castles
long something that could have been
considered at all
it would be a very risky decision to to
castle the opposite side of what fabiano
with the white pieces already has done
but i would say yes it was definitely an
option
but not an option uh hikaru was willing
to explore when fabiano so obviously was
still in his preparation right whereas
hikaru having spent more than 10 minutes
on that queen move
uh he is clearly not so he's going to be
quite risk-averse
here
and it seems to have worked out for him
because
fabiano is thinking
speaking of fabi's preparation that he
is so well known for it's one of the
reasons why he has one of the best
records against the field of course the
statistics say that ali reza ferrugia
has the best percentage wise but given
that he's also played not nearly as many
games against the field as fabian
carwana you could argue that fabiano's
record against the field is the uh shows
why many believe he's the man to beat
yeah but actually as we were discussing
in dings head to head and one of
fabiano's biggest problems is that he
has a rather significant
uh disadvantage uh against ding in their
uh head-to-head scores uh so um
i mean it's looking great like a good
score against the kajabov for instance
but a potentially good score against uh
rockport um but those fabiano versus
ding matchups are gonna be
one of the most hyped uh games in the
entire tournament but i think these
statistics are very interesting but what
i was looking at while i was preparing
for the candidates like how do players
perform with white and with black so
like these statistics are also very
interesting and especially for fabiana
he that the amplitude is very low so he
performs as well with white as with
black so maybe this also explains why he
was able to qualify like for his fourth
candidates he won the candidates once is
he going to win it for the second time
there were a few players i think in
history of chess who won the candidates
uh twice so maybe i think smith loves
i guess yes and so favi you know is that
joining very elite company yes exactly
so i think maybe this explains as well
the stability of his performance
well and i i noticed one other thing
from that head to head of course we'll
we'll come back to it and continue to
talk about it his last two rounds
against rajab and faruga are two players
that he has
good records against so we'll uh we'll
definitely
if bobby is in a position hammer if he's
if he's in the driver's seat if you will
toward the end of the event he may be a
very hard man to stop because the
pairings from that perspective kind of
stack up in his favor
but that also means he can make a big
recovery right so just um
in some ways it's
i feel like it's better to get your
uh advantageous pairings as early as
possible because you want to kind of set
the tone and get confidence by winning
but you could also argue that the person
leading the event
uh will always have some extra pressure
on them so coming from behind at the end
uh can be psychologically easier
but it then of course does require you
to do well
in those final rounds i guess the short
you know way to put it we always say the
best way to win a tournament is to play
well
and
and that's it right that's that's the
number one number one key so
all right well we've uh we've spent some
time looking here at fabiano and hikaru
i have a feeling fob you might be
thinking for just a minute so why don't
we back up and get to one of the other
games that we haven't looked at yet we
already checked in on dingley wren
versus yonder palmishi let's head over
to a game that
i predicted a decisive result in hammer
you kind of did with how you previewed
it as well i didn't really predict a
decisive result between uh duda and
rapport but i did say that um one of
them may
turn some heads right if they can get an
early win
and i think it was you who made the
point that these are two very aggressive
players actually like huge opening
surprise already if i like well let's do
it go ahead take us through it because i
have looked also i went through all the
games that uh young sister duda played
against richard report and actually he
always started with d4 why because uh
richard airport has a very
wide opening repertoire against e4 so
with the
the king spawn and
it's almost like playing against
themself in certain situations because
young schistov also plays those openings
he always played d4 and went for some uh
kings uh well gambit structures or like
bishop before sometimes so
but this is actually a very uh well
interesting opening choice it means that
he is targeting uh richard in every line
yeah and why not target a rapport
because uh he is such a creative player
who has commented in interviews i play
exciting openings because otherwise i
find chess boring what an attitude
to have in this candidate's tournament
where normally the players are playing
incredibly cautiously with the black
pieces because they know as long as you
don't lose with black you have excellent
chances right to go all the way in the
event rapport he has the completely
different uh attitude he's going
i want to fight and i don't care whether
i'm white or black uh
let's just have it out there
and uh yeah this sicilian choice from
him yeah is is uh fantastic and then a
very uncommon response from duda also
exciting uh from the get-go well this is
why you said that you thought this game
could have a decisive result right
because
amir you already made the point
due to playing like caruana right we
thought caruana would play d4 with a
very good record against ikaru duda says
no i'm also going to surprise my
opponent with e4 and i think if you're
going to do that against someone it
makes sense against rapport if you're
looking for fighting bishop before this
is yeah this is a barrier yes very odd
move so because normally you would play
knight c3 of course and uh or knight c6
yep
main lines yes you can take on c6 as
well or knight two three six knight two
six so bishop of four
this is such a an innovative you know
approach but but it's positionally sound
right it's weird once you see it on the
board and then you jump to the live
position you're like well the bishop
kind of looks useful there right we know
there's a weak d6 pawn in a lot of these
time-out of sicilians if not a pawn then
it's a square because it means the pawn
is likely on d7 so this is
i don't i don't know i'm seeing this
position on the board and going wow i
mean it looks like one i might play as
white
well now that you've got the start
now that you've seen it yeah exactly i'm
like this doesn't look crazy is what i'm
saying yeah no uh and and why would that
latest move as well
getting the famed moroxy uh pawn
structure with these two pawns
controlling in towards the center uh
it's it's a very kind of white is taking
a tight grip on the opponent
but at the risk of also overextending
because what now happens is the square
d4
is a square that cannot be protected by
any white pawns so if black were able to
get a knight up there for instance by
playing c5 now which i'm sure rapport is
thinking about
that can be a really nice placement long
term for the night
and and potentially be
a game winner uh in the long run ludwig
i have a question of course as usual so
if i am trying to break through in the
center immediately which one of the main
strategical ideas and the like sicilian
defense so if i play d5 here
uh
like what is the idea behind like the
whole line with bishop before is to take
cd5 cd5 and to play e5
um i i would guess here uh white just
develops knights so knight c3 you know
you don't want to take okay no i i think
white is very happy to be up in central
control to be up in development and yes
uh black has an extra central pawn that
is
well it's basically the only reason
people play the sicilian yep uh
because you get that slight central
advantage
but the
the problem with the sicilian and then
by extension also this position is that
while you get that extra pawn in the
center you also do delay your
development a lot
uh and so here i i would say if if you
try to make a pawn break in the center
um then then white would be happy for
you to open up the position uh
exploiting black's poor development
anyway these are the two options
probably that uh richard should take
into account here c5 or d5 well i i i
know i think he will point knight g6 i
just think yeah let's talk a little bit
about the psychology of that to me one
of the most interesting parts of the
candidates elmira we were talking about
all the preparation that goes in we've
now seen two opening surprises fabiano
and duda right and how much of how much
do you think that that's
that that's going into to the player i
mean how many more of those you think
we're gonna see right is this a big part
of uh what we think the players will
bring round in and round out well
actually i've been thinking about the
candidates well and try to compare it
with boxing you know it's like is there
a round of observation in the candidates
or like we see like new opening ideas
immediately from the first starting from
the first round so i guess they uh the
players cannot allow themselves this
round of observation they so it's i
think it's a very important strategy
uh and we i can see the quote i cannot
read it probably
it says it's very hard to see anyone
beating magnus of course rapport made
these comments recently i don't see it
happening if i had to combine two guys i
still think it would be very hard which
is saying a lot i don't know that i
agree that
combining two guys strengths and
weaknesses wouldn't wouldn't find a
super a super chess human to take down
the norwegian final boss
but uh your thoughts on that on that
hammer i mean
what
i'm i'm i'm not entirely certain what uh
combining two players would do because
as you say combining two players
strength
it sounds good but then you're also
combining their weaknesses right um and
yeah no magnus is a fantastic chess
player uh which
his reign as the number one chess player
in the world
kind of has has showcased no one is is
really uh
challenging him uh long term
and um yeah i i would tend to agree with
mr rapport that uh
i i think
regardless who wins this event they
would be
a significant underdog yeah against
magnus
well and we'll continue to talk about
whether we whether we think a match
would even happen obviously knowing
magnus's statements about farouja
speaking of
ferugia that is the only game we have
not actually checked in with yet
so at some point here i think it's time
to check on the oldest player in the
field and the youngest player and there
we have it tamora vajavov
is uh
playing the white pieces versus ali
rezabaruja another very dynamic very
interesting position on the board
initially hard for me to predict the
opening and now i see it was a it was
the queen's gambit declines and it's
mixing i think
is it the variation of yes
like i cannot
yeah yeah okay i'm glad i wasn't the
only one who was taking a a a pause to
say how did we get here so
starts out with a potential nimzo move
order everyone a queens indian declines
the nimzo indian bishop before we have a
transposition with d5
some very natural moves of course this
whole idea of the queen's pawn for those
who don't play this opening is to
sacrifice c4 in order to try to get a
big center and wouldn't you know it
that's what we get on the board and then
b5 okay this is this is some of the
sharpest stuff we don't see as often at
the highest levels these days both sides
all in black is trying to hold the pawn
and giving white to center and uh
white's going to try to protect the pawn
to maybe win it back
uh yeah no it's it's a really really
tricky opening from verusa and frankly
not an opening with a very good
reputation yeah
but one thing i note here uh is that as
as as you said white has regained the
pawn they sacrificed
um but in exchange yeah i noticed how
both of those central pawns both of them
are on the dark squares right so what
furuja is aiming for here is to have
extreme control of the light squares and
in particular uh the square d5
is very important yeah the the d5 square
cannot be uh uh attacked by any white
pawns right uh so it's it's a big
feature for black to maybe land a knight
there
um
in due time however before that he needs
to make sure that he doesn't lose the
pawn on c4 yeah because right now this
pawn is not defended by other pawns
uh it's it just looks horrible frankly
uh and uh it's gonna be uh if we move on
uh it's gonna be interesting to see how
uh oliveressa approaches the defense of
said punk well we can already see in the
live position how he did it you know
tarantino this movie there's a knight on
a5 which is awkward af as the kids would
say which means as friendly after a3 it
makes yeah a3 stopping the b4 square
from being used
um
which of course was played just before
it and then the knight comes to a5
not just to over protect c4 but
to use the open file given by the double
pawn it's just a very interesting
position as as you're both saying ugly
pawns but with it some dynamic
opportunities not just the diagonal and
the light square pressure but also now
the b file and the b3 square so
well first of all i wanted to say that
the openings uh well a choice doesn't
surprise me because uh
uh le reza first is going for a very
concrete position so that's uh
that's always been his style and also um
he's going for a very dynamic position
once again and sort of odd looking
almost like a computer would place
because uh alireza grew up with
computers you know it's like not at all
our generation
uh like how we study chess so
could we call it an alpha zero
generation it's not my generation he's
way younger than i am i am much older
than i i'm honestly i didn't realize i
was your generation i thought i was
younger than you guys you are you are
take that hammer well i'm just shocked
here at how old i am now rouge is
thinking about uh something maybe from
his generation we will take a quick look
at the short but
rather fantastic career of ali reza
farousha you see you see the list of
accomplishments before him of course he
got here by winning the 2021 grand swiss
he also the youngest player ever to
break he broke the 2700 rating barrier
in record fashion broke the 2800 barrier
in record fashion this is why many
people say for ruja is the future and uh
as you commented about his game elmira i
think that was a great comparison it
looks like a game a computer might play
as black um as we uh head back to the
position because rajab has moved with
queen to c2 and ferruccia is back on the
clock
i actually have one important detail
because yesterday at the closing
ceremony uh i met uh loresa's parents so
both of them i said the whole family is
actually here it's for the first time in
a while because uh well they were faced
with such a difficult situation because
alvarez wanted to play chess so they had
to leave iran yeah they settled in
france uh now he represents france and
so
all this just because
well the teenager like he wanted to play
chess you know like he was not free to
do it yeah you know when you look at the
situation from a different perspective
all of us you know are free to do
whatever we want yeah so it was uh
as important for him as oxygen yeah just
he wanted to keep on playing chess
tournaments a train and to have a shot
at the world title it's it's an amazing
story you're absolutely right and iran
of course is a country with
chess has been there for a very long
time but of course as you said
unfortunately not not something that he
could continue to do if he wanted to
travel the world with real freedom so he
now is in france and and is playing in
the candidates and here he is already
having played knight to d5 hammer
highlighting what you said that the d5
square an outpost and a very good one
for that night
yeah no i i'm really fascinated uh by
this game uh i i think fabruja with his
opening choice has um has taken enormous
risk
like this this broken pawn structure how
the pawns are not defending each other
that's incredibly risky play
and he's doing it with black in the
first game of his first candidates
tournament you know and just normally
you would think
first-timers play it a bit safe trying
just to get off to to a decent start
trying to get just get those uh jitters
away the butterflies flying in
formation uh but he's really gone for it
yeah uh from the get-go and and i really
noted uh the time situation raja above
already down 20 minutes uh it goes to as
i think this is an indication of furuja
actually kind of psychologically telling
rajab i don't think you have what it got
i think i need to beat you with both the
white pieces and the black pieces to
have a successful tournament
um
he's he's really kind of showing some
some in some ways disrespect to rajabov
he's like hey man
i'm here i'm i'm here to win it uh and
and to do that i need to beat someone
and i'm willing to play this risky
opening against you
uh
because you've been on bad form for uh
the past couple of months rajabov hasn't
won a game in in
point well the other the other thing it
says though hammer is it says that maybe
perugia was just telling the truth and
that he said
i'm happy to be here this is fun for me
i love chess and i'm not nervous people
say there's pressure on me people say
that because magnus sort of you know put
a target on my back with those
statements that i'm nervous and i think
well well i think okay yes he's clearly
playing a dynamic position as black i
don't know if it means any more
disrespect other than farouz is going to
play chess no matter who he's playing to
be honest or like i don't think that he
knows how to play safe yeah it's just
simply it's like he's uh well in nature
you know is to play this kind of chess
he is always aiming for complicated
positions unbalanced and this is where
he strives so uh
this is he's in his element for like
in this position so uh
i really think um
that
it might be our decisive game
today okay well i'm not sure we're just
going to have one decision i was just
about to say that i i see that we've
we've had a mistake in richard rapport's
game we already know that the dinghy run
yonda bamishi position is super super
interesting um shout out to chat just so
you know we're observing can't call out
every comment but uh
but we love you we love the activity
everyone is excited for the 2022 fide
candidates just like we are and uh i
think we're gonna back up why don't we
why don't we recycle this thing and and
although first we'll quickly read read a
quote from tamer jabba
everyone has chances especially at a
high level tournament it depends on how
you approach it
and i
i tend to agree and he says i've played
at a high level for a very long time
right i think he's kind of commenting
without commenting on the fact that not
many people looking at rajava as a
favorite to win the tournament right so
he's sort of saying hey i know i'm not
the favorite but everyone here has
chances and i've played a lot of chess
for a long time elmira well actually i
tend to agree with him uh well
the this tournament is very open we
might speculate as much as we want we
can have a lot of statistics to to our
rescue but i think
well at the end of the day we don't know
who is going to win this tournament so
everyone has a shot
it would it would definitely be an
interesting turn of events obviously if
a player like rajabov at this stage in
his career won it and uh well his
opponent might be giving him some
chances today with a with a very
double-edged position on the board so
tanya if you if you remember you know he
won the world cup like in 2018 and he
beat dingle iran in the final yep so
well he has what it takes you know when
uh well he's playing when the stakes are
high
if i might say so
yep
fair fair right and i think it's hard
because there are so many interesting
story lines to follow and all and all of
the games and all of the lives of these
players so uh i think it's a healthy
reminder that rajab played in the
candidates right he won a world cup not
too long ago and uh let's not overlook
him
we're not going to overlook a single
moment of this game today fabiano
caruana hikaru nakamura if you missed it
if you've been hiding under a rock the
americans are facing off in round one
and this is where a lot of people have
their eyes set we've seen only two more
moves hammer since we left actually we
saw one very big one i didn't realize
that we already have an extension of h6
and g5 over here so let's take a look at
what happened
yeah uh fabiano uh developing his bishop
pointing it down towards uh the black
queen and very often when you create
these situations with the bishop
pointing down it's rather annoying
because you cannot move your knight
without your queen being captured
so he carver did the only thing he could
do to stop that white bishop from
putting pressure on black's queen he
first poked it uh with the pawn to h6
trying to capture the bishop the bishop
says i will remain on this diagonal
pointing down towards your queen
and then hikaru went g5 which is a very
commental decision
and it's also the complete opposite of
what we were discussing earlier that
hikaru probably wants to take it slow
and not uh do make any unnecessary risky
moves um
he must have felt this was necessary
because on the risk scale
yeah
and let's tell that why it's so risky
not just because it's an extension of a
pawn that will never return but when
you've already played a move like this
there there will be no castling long in
this game which means
where's where's your king gonna go
castle is this position so uh
very often in the italian game you play
h6 g5 but you're still castle you know a
short so
maybe this is possible here as well but
it looks very dangerous
wow we are going we are going to have
action you feel that i just sat up in my
chair i wasn't on camera then but i
think we have our bird's eye view to
check in with a good reminder
to all of the fans that you can go to
chess.com events
and choose your own adventure you can
see any game you want
uh all four games are in progress
right now in this first round of the
2022 feed a candidate's tournament so we
see fabio carwana taking a think here
against ikara nakamura we'll check in
we'll check in with our birds of you as
soon as we can not quite yet and uh
and i'm excited to see what happens here
by the way so the more i look at this
position i know we highlighted that rook
b8 says you can't castle long and g5
feels like a move that once played you
would never put a king there we should
note however that it's not out of the
question right whenever you have these
types of whether it's an italian or a
giaco piano or in this case a spanish
game in which black has been able to
sort of clamp on the dark squares
castling short is not totally out of the
question of course it does come with
tons of risk because should white be
able to pry open the center then of
course you might regret all of the the
open space around your king but um
hammer what are your thoughts on the
direction of this game and what fabiano
is is currently thinking about i i think
fabiano is very happy
uh i think he has a relatively risk-free
uh position uh where he can try to take
advantage of uh the black king's
vows vows
whatever that word is
um
and um
and yeah i mean i i think he will want
to uh maybe do something at this moment
uh wondering where that black king is
gonna go so if i was fabiano here i
would be seriously considering the move
d4
right away yeah it's it's very
double-edged because once you push your
pawns forward in the middle uh you're
setting pawns up against each other uh
going for pawn trades
but
pawn trades almost always favor the
person with the two bishops yeah because
bishops are really good well the fewer
the pawns
uh so
strategically
uh risky to push the pawn forward in the
middle because of the bishops but at the
same time it's advantageous because of
the black king
being stuck in the middle and and not
having a clear path uh out so
these kinds of moves where there are
like uh pros and cons for the very same
move right um is uh is really
interesting and and to me like the
positions we have in this first round
are so great yeah i mean it's like we're
like kids in a candy store i mean
speaking of a candy store and all the
positions let's bring up our bird's eye
view and remind the fans that
as we said you get you get to pick your
own flavor it's the baskin robbins of
chess positions here on our show i
prefer rainbow sherbet as i've said many
times my favorite flavor of ice cream
your what's your favorite position right
now elmira and we'll head over to that
game well actually i wanted to follow up
with uh ian ludwig's explanation i
really liked it like i was thinking uh
yes in this game so because normally
when you play g5 you would follow up
with h5 so i wanted to ask you and redux
how black should continue even after d4
so like you should be consistent you
probably should protect on on a5 but
then probably play h5 anyways and maybe
castle artificially you know liking f7
or king f8 king g7 i don't know what
would be appropriate at the moment so
uh because this is already a critical
position
after d4 i think yes so uh
and
probably thinking about it i'm
not sure whether he'll play it but
you're
you're definitely right on cue elmira
that h5 is certainly something that
would have to be considered in response
yes this is the standard plan used you
know in uh in the well in the italian
opening so uh let's head back to the
analysis of this bobby game as we're
kind of breaking it down the fans can
choose their own adventure as as we
showed but so just to show what elmira
was talking about
after after d4 of course black can try
to defend it maybe eventually castle by
hand but the really critical question is
can black get away with a move like this
threatening to trap the bishop
well actually i was thinking first about
f6 but you're like um uh this is such a
bold looking move you know i would i
wanted to say that uh there is some
something legitimately dangerous about
h5
i was not sure how to
phrase it like i feel that this is so
dangerous but it might work
yeah it's a it's a really really tricky
position
uh and we've been so lucky to to get i
think
really unbalanced positions in all four
games
uh so i mean
i wouldn't rule out the possibility
of four decisive games well what to
shush your mouth when you're talking to
me you shut your mouth that would be no
but look at this analysis from almeira
right yeah hikaru just pushing those
pawns out at the board
trying to go after the white king
i i'm with you right i mean this would
be incredible it's uh it's hot outside
and the players are are bringing the
fire on board here so let's see what
happens
here you're going to lose because look
at this knight
before and then age four yes exactly so
booyah that's a trick that hikaru would
have up his sleeve we know that he is uh
one of the most tactically gifted
players in his in his generation for
sure if not if not of all time so what
what a trick
yeah no
we're gonna have some some enterprising
uh chess in this game and
in all the other games as well danny
you're asking us questions all the time
so i have you know a question for you
for example you are white so you are
having fabulous position you played d4
and you know like feeling confident you
know so i'm going to destroy and then uh
black plays h5 so what is the physical
feeling that you have you know it's not
like the concrete rational evaluation of
the position how do you physically feel
at this moment you're you're the
psychological i'm always on edge you
know that i mean i'm i'm a little bit
too too nervous but no seriously it's
certainly a position that as we see fabi
taking his time he has to be thinking
about that right because he hasn't
played d4 yet we're assuming hikaru
would have this response ready and fabi
is is while the one we were giving
credit to as far as preparation goes
hammer and and uh being the most
prepared player maybe in his generation
he's now down on the clock okay but he's
moved yeah
he's played d4 okay we could have
wow we could have liftoff before he kara
comes back to the board let's remind
everybody of some of the things that
make fabiano great
a slightly longer career than ali raza
parush has had in our last profile that
we showed but um
an incredible one of course everyone
remembers that 2014 sink field cup uh i
was there i get to say i was there when
bobby won his seventh game in a row and
boy was it was it bananas um
an amazing event that he uh that he
would go on to win he tied carlson of
course and his last chance at the title
in the classical portion
before losing in rapid so um
fabiano carwana
what a career a four-time
four-time italian champion as we saw and
now we're back to hikaru nakamura on the
board as he
he settles in for maybe a long thing to
make maybe the biggest decision uh so
far on any board here at the 2022
candidates tournament hammer
that's a bold statement uh because when
we had the the view of all the boards i
i saw some really uh fascinating stuff
going on there as uh as well so uh
i would say that uh it's the most
critical moment of this game
but to compare it to the other games
today is tough it's tough because all
the games are so you know he just gave
that pause we see one of his us
championship rings on his finger for
those who've never seen that ring up
close uh hikaru gave that a little bit
of a sh i know he's going to play h5 no
no f6 oh sorry i didn't go for it
there are two possibilities i think he
was considering both of them but f6 and
then h5 so when i was considering g4 and
well
i was so scared to play h5 first so like
f6 was my first option
like my first choice you know so well
the reason i got so excited there is
because i know his sh his shift when
he's about to push upon that little body
language when he shifts before he does
that and i thought it was going to be h5
it was f6 so i got a little too excited
about whether h5 would be on the board
but amir you're probably right f6 the
more solid decision keeps the position
locked up which of course strategically
we highlighted as uh
it's kind of key for black whenever you
play g5 before you decide whether or not
to go all in on the pawn storm well it's
well sort of a paradox for me you know
i'm probably like a pure product of the
soviet school you know so f6 seems
natural to me but i have something
inside me which pushes me towards age
five at the same time so
i don't know what to do
wow well
hammer i know you're uh
i know you're in deep think i love can i
just say i love when you're focused i'm
looking at you over there and i just
love that focused look
i was i was literally leaning back in my
chair people it's not like i was sitting
like this
the guy is calling me out for just you
know relaxing at the
very comfortable never never calling you
out very comfortable chair by the way
these have way better back support than
when we first uh brought the couch onto
a chess broadcast with f with fabiano
and hess
oh wait way way better back support so
i'm actually very comfortable i don't
know what you're talking about the back
support at our studio for the world
championship with fabian hess
it was not good well i cannot get
comfortable in any of the chairs so so
it's better because like i feel like i'm
playing all of those games you know
since i have a typical chess player post
you know i'm completely absorbed by the
position so and i was actually looking
at uh
uh ding nippom nishi and i think that
there was queen h5 and knight g4 and
like
i think at the board
go ahead yeah i'm pretty sure i spotted
a checkmate threat in that game yeah
let's let's back let's back this thing
up and let's head over let's back this
thing up to the studio and head on over
to a game no dingley ren and yonda
palmashi is what we want to see because
yon is uh
yawn is
bringing the heat right now
um
queen h5 and knight to g4
is uh
threatening queen takes h2 checkmate we
have our first threat of checkmate here
in madrid everyone just take note and
whoever had a prop bet going about at
what point we would have that you know
won
but first of all i wanted to um point
out that rookie 8 was played suggested
by our expert
and only then after b4 knight g4
bishop b2 queen h5 so let's show as
elmira was saying we left this game for
those fans who may be just tuning in
kind of highlighting that the critical
storyline of this position is about
will this e4 pawn stay and be a thorn in
white's side or will white eventually
have the time to kind of build up and
grab it rookie eight is a move that
indirectly defends that pawn because if
white were to play queen c2 you could
play bishop f8 and unleash the tower's
power to defend the peshka after b4
though we see knight to g4 from russian
and we get we get aggressive over here
on the king side this is i hammer i
really like this move because what we
were highlighting is that the knight the
knight defends these squares from the
bishop but not necessarily the knight
right because if this exchange were to
happen black is developing with tempe
the soviet chess girl would tell you
never capture a piece that helps your
opponent develop right and then black
would be in good shape so instead yeah
but it's it's moving away from the
protection
so you're not a huge
approach here no i'm just asking myself
what would have happened there
uh if you just take the pawn yes we have
to show that we have to show it
uh yes bishop before is it possible
okay knight takes or bishop takes a
knight takes maybe a queen a one so okay
so bishop takes e4 yes
so queen h5 probably that's black's idea
anyway so what's happening here
there's a checkmate threat so white
probably has to take yes because you you
cannot play h3 there compared to the
other positions so
this is just uh this is a lot of
compensation for black right you've got
pressure here you have the rooks coming
to the center
i don't know but if i simply played this
i have an extra pawn though okay let's
say bishop we just continue a little bit
bishop g2 because i don't want to leave
this bishop in the center maybe bishop
b2 is bishop g2
can you play bishop g2 here yes
so like
you know i i mean i i kind of like this
for white but i have been known to be a
bit of a greedy guy a greedy guy yeah
pretty greedy gary over here
we were talking about the alpha zero
generation this is one of the positions
which uh where black sacrifices upon for
a long-term initiative
uh which computers
well total
taught us a lot about recently so
uh
well i'm not sure how to evaluate this
position actually on that no
as someone who's not from the alpha zero
generation but would like to think
like to think he's not too far removed i
i'd like black hammer likes white i like
the idea of the pieces coming to the
center the bishop coming to f6
and tactically it's just a very
it's a position that feels like it's
going to get harder for white with every
move by black yes white's up a pawn but
with every move i i find black's pieces
getting better not worse so that's why i
get nervous
dingley wren
sort of agreed and played bishop to b2
he decided not to take the pawn but jan
offers a transposition potentially in
that and that white can of course take
here and then reconsider whether he
wants to grab this pawn now with the
knight but then e2 is hanging e2 would
hang that's right okay so
so yeah only well you can take it with
the bishops on knight g4 bishop g4 and
steal bishop before
and maybe we do this move maybe just i'm
just blitzing out moves here without
thinking too much
i was thinking about rook t8 maybe first
but i was not sure
so now we're threatening to win a piece
here with bishop c3 and rookie four
if the bishop moves we might consider
taking anyway and taking e2
so you're playing moves like d3 maybe
and i you know so obviously we don't
have to go too far down the rabbit hole
but i guess what it would it uh
would it probably
if he wanted to take the pawn he should
have done so previously and now he's
kind of committed himself into not
grabbing that pawn however
um
if he's not taking the pawn uh what is
he then doing about the enormous attack
currently being launched at his king
and and the black pawn in the center uh
is actually also a valuable contributor
to that attack um so i i don't i feel
like ding misplayed it i feel like ding
should have been greedy on the previous
move and he may uh regret his decision
not to capture the pawn in the middle
just on
the basics that nepamyachi he keeps
sacrificing this pawn
yeah and
then when you already said no i don't
want the pawn the pomniachi is like well
okay i'll i will not bother defending it
i will instead use my time on just
launching uh a devastating attack
against the white king and now if you're
not gonna make the trade of knights you
have to go with the move h4
which is such a scary move to play yeah
so you need to move uh that pawn which
is being threatened uh with a
checkmating uh plan
um
and we should know real quick for
everyone why you can't play h3 if you
play h3
the knight takes here with tempo and
then the bishop would capture h3 so
hammer's point that if you're going to
move the pawn the only safe square is h4
yeah and then there's going to be moves
and like g5
trying to like really spice things up
trying to open up
uh towards that uh white king could be
dangerous because then i can take knight
e4 you know and then
here right i mean we've got to show it
on the board just for the kids at home
because who doesn't want to have fun
with that i mean
now who might get checkmated on the dark
squares so
um it's funny because if the position
got two wild hammer and everything on
the king side was highlighted then you
would remember that black is kind of
down a piece over here so you have to be
a little bit conscious of the fact that
tactically if things heat up too quickly
and you never had time to bring the
knight back in either via this route or
c5 or something that black could get in
trouble there so
so wow wow wow wow we have
we have no games disappointing us in
this round every game is bringing
excitement
you know it always surprises me how calm
ding is you know as like i've been
observing him during all of this
tournaments and
uh he's very calm he
[Music]
like he keeps uh
rationally analyzing you know the
position and he almost never is affected
by emotions during the game like i know
personally like uh we've played so many
games and then i was surprised by a move
you know and then like
everything went uh well downhill
and we keep highlighting the alpha zero
generation the generation of players who
grew up with computers versus people
just right before them like my
generation we learned how to use
computers but growing up with them i
think you you tend to be a very
just skeptical rational practical and
and i think non-emotional person unless
it's really a part of your personality
because you've seen computers defend so
many positions you just you don't get
rattled as easily and dingly run
certainly one of those guys who just
never looks like he's lost his cool
okay and let's have a look maybe at uh
do the report yeah let's do that we uh
we'll head back over to the bird's eye
view remind everybody you can go to
chess.com
events i don't think anybody voted
likely if i had to guess probably nobody
voted for all four games to be decisive
so if you are that lucky fan out there
who's like
joke's on you danny i guess that every
game would have a winner then good for
you i uh
i will be surprised to see who's leading
oh my gosh
c5 after g6 that's
that might be so i saw chat screaming i
apologize to chat now that we took so
long to get here but let's go full
screen to the doodle rapport game
because you are
you are right chat
rapport surprised maybe by judah's
opening
was spending some time we highlighted
the fact that there's some pressure here
that of course the moroxy bind structure
makes it makes it scary to play the move
you want in the sicilian which is d5 but
after g6 from rapport
a question mark on the board
white plays c5 and there's no way that
wasn't cooked up at home hammer what a
sharp position due to has this game
headed absolutely no chance that was
cooked up at home why do you say that
uh because it's such an uncommon uh
position already
uh and and i think there's just no
reason for the uh players to anticipate
uh
the kind of mistake
that rapport made you need to keep in
mind that um when you're analyzing with
your computer one of the weaknesses of
doing that is you often get blinded by
the computer's suggestions
uh and you kind of miss out on some very
human ways of playing
because the computer doesn't mention it
because maybe it's a mistake right um
and and so there's absolutely no reason
i believe
um let's talk about what is the idea
what is the idea here yeah sure
so the idea is to prevent black from
castling
and
if now uh black were to take this pawn
that is being offered
then the bishop coming in
in the middle attacking the brook the
work needs to move
and once you move your work you're not
allowed to cancel anymore
huge move so for the record and i don't
know that we'll get due to to tell us or
not if he wins this game we interview
him i disagree with you i think that
there's this idea was original enough
and he played it so quickly out of the
gate with this fast opening
that
we'll we'll call i'll call your bluff
and i actually i think there's a very
good chance that if not this exact move
this idea was known by duda before he
played into this line because look at
his clock the idea is known
uh but uh
th this exact execution and like
this is a common idea anyway to try and
uh create some some discord in in
black's pawns because you're basically
saying okay i'll give up a pawn but you
get double pawns yeah so i i will admit
that the idea will probably be known but
the intention of trapping the rook in
the corner
i don't see that being home preparation
okay and i also want to note that there
is another move here queen to a5
okay well wow we are we are going to
find out
well i i wanted to say something because
i'm sort of like in the middle between
you two because i think when we are
analyzing a new variation or a special
type of position like
like
for example the old generation
would always have a range of moves you
know it's like they would brush away you
know moves like g6 or whatever as we
considered c5 d5 maybe knight g6 or even
e5 so this
uh seems to me like
a very plausible range of moves that you
would like consider while analyzing this
position while lately especially while
working with the computer i've been told
which was actually a very huge surprise
to me that
that you should analyze almost every
reason but no reasonable no reasonable
move yes i forget all my legs
so every possible move in this position
so you're not going to get surprised and
you're not going to be behind on the
clock you know so while playing the
candidates so maybe like both
explanations are possible
look at you almir bring in the balance
no wonder you feel in the middle you're
sitting right in the middle between us
so there's there's elemira
uh the balance to the battle between me
and hammer about whether this was a
prepared novelty or not either way we
have a ton of exciting chess ahead we
also have our first break uh before we
before we go to that we're gonna leave
all of you with a trivia question that
uh that'll be coming up right now which
2022 candidates participant defeated
magnus carlson in their first classical
game played at todd of steel 2017. i i
know the answer i know
you don't get to answer hammer you don't
get to answer okay i know the answer
because i have it right in front of me
no i'm kidding but all right we're going
to get more answers and insights from
hammer when we return we're going to
have our first look at a breakdown of a
of one of the critical positions on the
board so don't go anywhere when we
return it's more of chess.com coverage
of the 2022 feed a candidate's
tournament in a few from madrid
[Music]
did you know
you don't even need to download an app
just open any mobile browser and head to
chess.com events
you can see what's happening right now
check out top games
see results and so much more
try it for yourself at chess.com events
this club is called amigos del retiro
friends of the retiro the retiro is uh
the most big and important park in
madrid it's a very important park in the
city because it's right in the center if
you want to play chess you don't know
the place this is a
maybe best one in madrid
i
[Music]
want to hold a massive chess tournament
with dozens of clubs or hundreds of
players or maybe a small chess
tournament with local but competitive
clubs with club arenas you can
club arenas allow for tournaments of any
size with any number of clubs and
players customize the arena with any
time control with standard chess or mini
chess variants and with any starting
position you want club arenas are the
most flexible tournament format on
chess.com try one out today
[Music]
did you know you can watch top chess
events right on your phone you don't
even need to download an app just open
any mobile browser and head to chess.com
events
you can see what's happening right now
check out top games
see results and so much more try it for
yourself at chess.com events
[Music]
this club is called amigos del retiro
friends of the retiro the retiro is uh
the most big and important park in in
madrid it's a very important park in the
city because it's right in the center if
you want to play chess you don't know
the place this is the
maybe best one in madrid
foreign
[Music]
want to hold a massive chess tournament
with dozens of clubs or hundreds of
players or maybe a small chess
tournament with local but competitive
clubs with club arenas you can
[Music]
club arenas allow for tournaments of any
size with any number of clubs and
players customize the arena with any
time control with standard chess or mini
chest variants and with any starting
position you want club arenas are the
most flexible tournament format on
chess.com try one out today
[Music]
did you know you can watch top chests
we are back we are live we are in the
beautiful
city of madrid i visited that location
just a couple days ago and it was it was
gorgeous
all right
we uh
we have so much ahead round one of the
2022 fe-day candidates is underway
we left you
welcome back everybody uh we are
going to dive into the trivia question
that we left you with at break and uh
hammer knew it right away so we'll maybe
we'll let you answer it chat you have
10 more seconds before hammer answers
our trivia question which was of course
which 2022 feed a candidate's
participant
beat magnus carlson in the first round
of the 2017 tata steel event
and uh
hammer what was the answer i really hope
i'm right uh but i think it was rapport
it was in fact it was perfect what's
funny great timing by the production
staff because we had that trivia
question prepared regardless and we
happen to be on the richer report game
right there at the end so uh he's in
he's in maybe a little bit of trouble in
this particular game versus young
christoph duda but uh he did beat magnus
carlson in the 2017
todd of steel tournament of the first
round so um
okay well we've got plenty more action
ahead with me here grandmaster young
lubbock hammer
almiros kripchenko we have another event
going on that we want to remind you
about if you happen to have missed it
the 2022 chess.com global championship
is running and everyone has a chance to
play before we get into the title
playing stage and ultimately a knockout
that will feature so many chess legends
and the best players in the world you
can compete on saturday and sunday of
every week in the 2022 global
championship on chess.com consider
giving it a try and take your part in
prizes not just for title players as
well as being able to say that you
competed in an event with all the
world's best players
the world's best players now in these
four games we have all four games are
giving us excitement here i where do we
want to go do you want to go back to
this rapport game i don't know that it's
going to get better than this yeah i i
think we have to return to it because
there is an option
that the hungarian player has okay that
manages to win white's pawn
without damaging the black pawn
structure so uh we've had two more moves
since we uh last joined uh rapport he
played e5
and he's basically trying to chase away
white's bishop trying to say you're not
going to be allowed to attack my rook
after which
duda says well
sure i am i'm just going to go to a
different square so right now this
bishop is aiming in for that f6 square
danny highlighted uh once again
attacking the rook in the corner forcing
the rook to move
which will prevent black from ever
getting that castle's move in now
there there was a moment here right
before rapport made his move which by
the way the computer did not like so go
ahead go continue yeah so black could
have played instead queen to a5 not here
probably before or both here and before
yeah
actually queen to a5 attacking the white
king where do you want to show it after
e5 or right here it was possible here as
well right so let's look at it right
here why didn't he play when he first
had a chance
uh well i think the the reason in both
variations
in fact is simply knight to d2
so white is saying okay it's fine you
can have the pawn on c5 you can capture
it with your queen so that the pawn on
d6 is still doing an important job
preventing the white bishop from coming
in
and attacking the black rook in the
corner however here after the move rook
to c1
there's trouble uh brewing uh the queen
will move to b4 because the that's the
only square the queen can move to and
and still protect the pawn but it will
be chased away the pawn will move up on
the side of the board attacking that
black queen if the black queen now tries
to capture pawns then the knight gets
into play as well and what we're seeing
here is really a really nice
illustration of
development development advantage and
how important it is to get your pieces
into play rockport he didn't do that and
in this line he gets punished for it
well it's
it's a it's a poison pawn example as
well shows you what happens when you
bring the queen out
too early and uh and get lost along the
way um
he did not play queen a5 he played e5
and after bishop to
g5 has now played bishop g7
the computer is not liking rapport's
moves
we uh
we might have a position where rapport
is in very big trouble very quickly here
we have just logical things that white
can do
yeah after that trade the important
thing to note is black's pawn on c6 yeah
um because the position here is actually
very similar for both players with the
exception of how the pawns are placed on
the the left side on the queen side of
the board uh and this pawn on c6 is not
protected by the pawn on a7
which is um
different to the white pawns on a2 and
b2 uh who because they are next to each
other can also defend and this seems
like such a minute difference but maybe
at top level chess stuff like this
decides games
and having that potential pressure along
the c file down towards that c6 pawn uh
that is an advantage uh duda is uh is
capable of of
reeling in a win just because of that
and ludic i was thinking maybe he's
looking for
like some dynamic play certainly he has
a well well a terrible pawn structure
and these positions are so easy to play
for white but maybe he just wants to
finish uh the development just castle
and then play c5 knight c6 knight d4 and
uh like
it's very important for richard to have
active pieces so
i was thinking that well he didn't lose
by force in the opening already so like
he decided to play g6 bishop g7 then
probably castle and then uh well to look
for some uh
well dynamic compensation for the
structure
well i i think the key is the word
compensation
uh which
indicates in itself that you have some
trouble right uh that you need to to
have uh something in return for
uh and uh that is certainly the case
duda has a great position uh great pawn
structure and and maybe he can even do
something
better than just making the trade of
pawns with the long-term
uh
good uh position maybe he can even try
to make some sort of
an attack right now although i can't
really see how
uh he would be able to do that amir you
you made an interesting i think
observation about the psychology of
facing an opening you haven't faced
right and so you're kind of like
sometimes you go back into your habits
you go back into things that are just
normally strategically okay right so he
was faced with something he hadn't
seen or wasn't ready for
says all right i'm just gonna get
castled right you make that sort of
practical decision it's like a warm and
cozy decision not anticipating the
danger right you don't have a you don't
have a sense of danger sometimes when
you play positions that are new to you
and that's why he maybe played g6 and
has just completely missed this idea
from from uh from duda and
and perhaps is in big trouble so what is
the psychology there right whenever you
face something that you weren't ready
for
you're you have two options right try to
figure it out at deeply even though your
opponent might have prepared something
you don't know or just try to like you
said do that do that thing where you're
just gonna get the king safe and then
you'll think about it later and the risk
that can come from that type of mindset
and also sometimes you you go for the
development which is uh more natural for
you maybe richard uh he'll simply
richard he he likes to develop his
bishop like uh
in these types of positions he likes to
play g6 bishop g7 and also maybe this
was something but dude spotted while he
was preparing for these types of
positions so he's
that's why he played bishop before maybe
to begin with so it's it's very strange
but on the other hand i was thinking
that
black has such a strong center i want to
play d5
if you give me this choice what do you
think andrew dick you know if you simply
castle here maybe i can play g5 and have
this powerful center so you're almost
forced to take on g6
uh yeah that's certainly a a valid
argument i i personally i agree with you
i i would capture black's pawn
to make sure that that pawn couldn't uh
advance in the center and maybe become a
problem for me long term
but regardless of um
how duda chooses to proceed
i think it's fair to say that the
opening has gone wrong for for rapport
right and it's not the first time in his
career he's
an incredibly creative player he loves
taking risks in the opening and and
getting
um
uncommon situations but sometimes the
the problem with that playing style
is that you take too big of a risk or
you make a mistake like we saw here
and and that feels to me like what has
happened and i think duda is is about to
uh to exploit that i want to give a
quick shout out to our first featured
shot of the day
daniel gould says i think duda is a
slight favorite to win this game
what do you guys think i think now he's
more than a slight favorite right that
comment probably came in a few moments
before c5 the advantage is minimal at
best in my very honest opinion so
probably that was maybe true a little
bit before bishop to g7 was played from
from duda so we would agree with you at
the time i think now i would i would put
duda at more than a slight favorite as
we see the moves on the board c takes d6
queen d6 and castles
at this point as hammer pointed out one
of the real problems with this position
for daniel gould i think it's an
educational thing is that maybe there's
something aggressive now right i mean
it's been a very dangerous position
it looks menacing the king isn't out of
the center but as hammers said even if
there isn't something aggressive this is
a weakness this is a weakness white's
pieces are naturally coming into the
middle of the board and black is
positionally just kind of busted here
unless you come up with something
creative so that's why i would say dude
is advantage a little bit more than
minimal at this point elmira and what's
interesting is that white didn't
sacrifice the palm right
it's uh
the positional advantage is uh enormous
and
the it's materially balanced
yeah
wow wow well um rapport will will have
his work cut out for him as hammer said
this isn't the first time in his career
i guess that is that is a funny thing
though about people who maybe sometimes
have questionable choices in the first
stage hammer at the very least we can
say this i some people people who get
good openings might be a little more uh
thrown off when they're in a bad
position in the opening someone like
rapport
he's been here before if you will right
um and uh we'll see with that whether
that makes a difference or not but um
i don't think he's too rattled yet yes
look at his facial expressions yeah
yes he uh well he's not very happy about
his position and also like you know
candidates it's such a long tournament
there are so many uh well
elements that you should take into
account so like physical preparation is
very important so like this is a
marathon you already said
and uh well
we're in madrid it's very hot so how do
players cope with such high temperature
because it affects not only their
physical shape but also i think mentally
i think that numerous studies have shown
and i've read it like quite a while ago
that you actually performs much slower
and inaccurately while you know faced
with these temperatures really yes
actually this is like that explains why
i've been playing such bad chess my
whole life living in arizona
it all makes sense finally finally i
know why
i am moving out of phoenix first thing
and it's so important to players for the
place like
they they need to walk after the games
they need to evacuate this place this is
simply not possible here like you walk
for five ten minutes and you're you
don't have to tell me it was uh yeah
it's it's sweaty coming over here so
well for the moment
well they have to face uh
uh well
a lot of uh challenges it's like not
only on the on the chessboard
and the first round i find uh is always
the most difficult one because you're
you're settling in to uh a new place
uh you're uh you're finding your habits
during the game
um and you you haven't
played chess right you're not kind of
you're getting into your game mode right
uh but it's difficult to do that uh just
by saying okay now i'm gonna be ready
right you can tell yourself that for
20 times before the round but you're not
going to feel the tension until you sit
there so in my opinion the first round
is is often the most difficult one which
is why i'm surprised that we've seen so
many players being willing to take great
risks uh here from the beginning uh and
and we've we're we're seeing some really
fascinating games uh which
i
seems
unwise
but for me unwise for them but good good
for us right good for us as commentators
and good for the fans um
again reminder we're gonna back up and
show you of course that
you can choose your own adventure all
four games are interesting you probably
can't choose wrong uh today
why don't we choose another one to check
in on of course we've been talking a lot
about carbon and nakamura sort of the
featured matchup of the day if you will
i think we'll head back over there but
this is this is one that because it the
chest sometimes tells you where you're
going right we come into round sometimes
deciding what the big matchup will be
but due to rapport we'll certainly have
our eyes from here on out we're going to
go back over now
well we have a huge decision i was i was
just about to set up the fact that the
knight on e5 and
the fact that it was going to remain
closed but the bishop
capturing means that uh bobby's parting
away with the second bishop we're gonna
have a real imbalance of knights knights
here
yeah uh two nights for fabiano two
bishops for hikaru who does it favor uh
it's it's not easy to to say yeah
well we've got we've got the knights
versus the bishops dynamic let's remind
everybody of what happened in this game
when we left it
hikaru played f6 for the record those
who were watching you'll note that h5
we were suggesting it on our own as
spicy and it turns out it was actually
the computer's
first choice and it was because of this
really interesting trick
of d takes e5 and bishop to b4 but
hikaru did not go for that elmira ikaru
chose the safe line that you wanted
right the soviet
soviet chess student and you wanted this
move you got your wish and then
carwana plays queen to d3
now h5 comes
and perhaps perhaps this d takes e5 was
met with some skepticism for a good
reason by me because maybe he doesn't
want to play it maybe maybe bobby's not
liking his position i mean look at the
clock
right
first of all uh maybe we should explain
uh the reason behind queen d3 maybe fabi
wants to play knight c4 so like this is
uh this is the idea behind queen d3
uh but uh
but after h5 you don't maybe have time
for something like this right h5 is
coming with h4 and
again i guess my point is what what has
been the storyline of this game to
remind everybody right we saw knight b3
from fabi a new slash interesting or at
least not so common idea hikaru was the
first on the clock so most of us were
thinking all right what kind of
preparation does car want to bring to
the table he'll get an advantage with
white nakamura recently has bad results
i'm just setting the stage right but
what are we actually seeing maybe quite
the opposite hikaru plays plays some
logical moves launches an aggressive
idea on the king side and before we know
it we're in a position where
as soon as h5 is on the board i don't
know that bobby liked his position at
all and and how much time he took kind
of proves that it takes a lot of time
before ultimately committing
to playing
d takes e5
a lot of time
and now the transition
i don't know who it favors hammer i know
you want to give us a breakdown of the
knights versus bishop in a position like
this but your quick thoughts right now
on
on what you see on the board
it's it's very unbalanced yeah um and
not only is it interesting with white
having two knights and black having two
bishops it's also about the potential
attack that can come down towards the
white king hikaru still has the option
of pushing his pawns forward
towards that white king uh trying to
open up in front of it trying to uh
get a checkmate uh essentially
but at the same time
where is where's the car gonna do what
what's he gonna do with his king yeah uh
so yeah no it this is a really
fascinating struggle
between the knights and the bishops and
we have a uh
a comment from chat or another featured
comment here
by i believe it's fx streamer if i'm
reading it correctly is a car going to
win this
that would be crazy indeed we're all
sitting here thinking that maybe hicaru
has a better position with black than he
could have uh hoped to get he's up 20
minutes on the clock he did also just
take a sip of water now amira there's a
lot of psychology that goes around
and
some rumors in the chest streaming world
that when a player
takes a sip of water like that they only
take a sip of water when they're
confident doesn't mean they're winning
but they're confident
what do you think about that that's a
very interesting comment but i would say
that it's simply very important to
hydrate yourself
during the
game of chess because uh once again we
tend to forget about the
how physical the game of chess is
they're going to play this game maybe
four six seven if you're playing magnus
for eight hours and uh
well a lot of the mistakes are are made
simply because like our sugar level
drops you know that we forgot like to
hydrate ourselves like sometimes uh
maybe to eat a banana it's very
important with dry fruits so
um i think this is uh
a very normal uh hygiene like a
discipline okay so hammer gave a big
smile i think he's calling bs on the
drinking water if you're confident i
mean i think you might drink water when
you're thirsty okay
we have another uh another comment from
chat here
if hikaru beats fabi with the black
pieces that's gonna throw a lot of chaos
into the mix you can say that again even
if it's just round one of course right
first of all any win with the black
pieces massive in this event right
beating someone who you have a minus two
score against who is arguably the
pre-tournament favorite right when
you're hikara nakamura is for sure gonna
gonna turn a lot of heads but um
like amber said this
still has a lot to go right
you're happy that it's double-edged if
you're hiccaro you're happy that you're
up on the clock you're happy that you've
probably parried whatever prep it was
that fabi came with but this is um this
is going to be quite the messy messy
affair the thing is that uh young ludwig
mentioned uh g4 h4 but i was thinking
that it may actually backfire so g4 i
could play knight g2 and then take on d6
and maybe play f4 you know just to open
the files while your king you know
is still like
in the center so i don't know how to
continue here
yeah well black's king is never getting
out of the center yep
uh
king d7 to connect the rook because uh
it's not possible because knight e5 is
also yeah that must have been the main
move is i think when the evil bar starts
jumping there must be some reason so
probably white could just steal but
you're making a great point anyway
regardless of the pawn hanging or not
the point is that this is a no no yes of
course i meant in the long term
of course not in this concrete situation
yeah
wow okay
well hey karo is um wisely probably
taking a moment here right when you've
earned an advantage on the clock like
this you want to use the clock as a
weapon if you're sensing it's a critical
moment don't play too fast and uh
i expect a car to be thinking here for a
little bit so let's back up again
remind you that all four games of course
are in progress right now and uh danny i
have one last question of course because
i was thinking about my idea but then uh
could you take on c4 and then play king
d7 because i had this crazy idea of
connecting the rooks then rook comes to
this let's go let's go back yeah we'll
go back full board here and look at this
so maybe black
i think a car will be we'll be thinking
about it for a second but bishop takes
c4 and then g4 no king d7 uh right away
yes that's right i wanted to play rook
f8 and then maybe king c8 and
castle vs artificially it's interesting
i
is this possible
for sure it's possible very interesting
giving up the bishop pair exactly yeah
is a big decision uh because right now
white has a knight
while uh
against bishop which
some say the bishop is better
um
okay i'm not sure this is one of those
situations though because look at how
the bishop is pointing towards its own
pawns in two directions and in addition
to that black also has double pawns two
pawns that are kind of blocking each
other's path
uh which means that they are not as
valuable as pawns standing next to each
other so we like them next to each other
but not in front of
uh each other
and um yeah no i
and also you have your king in the
middle of the board
i mean if if hikaru is considering stuff
like this then i
feel like we're underestimating
fabiano's position i agree there's also
just commenting on elmira's point this
is a this is a nice idea a weird move
like queen to b3 hitting the b7 pawn
makes that hard and i think the main
point would be that if you played b6
white would make a move like this and
the point is it's just harder and harder
for black to actually achieve the goal
we talked about of tucking the king and
maybe this is okay for black but maybe
even queen c4 instead of queen a4 the
point is i don't know that it's actually
going to be as easy as it first looked
to complete what we were talking about
with this castles by hand sort of
approach and regardless of
regardless of perhaps the negative
effects of of giving up the bishop
periscope b3 you know it's like i was
looking at the position i was thinking
about rook d1 like
but uh
it's it's not an easy position to play
actually for both colors of course
all right well which is true for pretty
much every game that's true and speaking
of every game let's uh let's again let's
take another look we haven't looked at
rajab and farouza
for for quite a while of course we know
that dingley ren and yonda pomneshi are
also locked in an interesting battle i
mean all four of these games are
are uh
are awesome i mean this is some spicy
chess i think i think for java and
perugia deserve to get our attention
it's probably the game that's had the
most change since we last looked at it
and so on that note let's back up to
where we left it which was here after
queen to c2 farouza put the knight on d5
and uh
hammer i'll let you come at first you
left us with a a good a good picture
that you painted right you've got these
doubled weak horrible pawns here
for black but black has some pressure
he's got control over a lot of different
light squares and
in a queen's gamut when you have a big
center it's great when the pawns are
together you were just saying that when
they extend sometimes you wish you could
move upon backwards so um
i'm gonna go through the game and you
pause us when you see a move that you
think is worthy of commenting on hammer
uh
yeah um well ali reza is is trying to
defend his his pawn uh on c4
that seems sensible
and now on the next move he he's pushing
his knight
forward
also feels fine right after
this knight e4 from rajaba the pawn on
c4 is now under attack
it's being attacked by on on c4 okay is
being attacked by both the bishop and
the queen
so we would preferably want to do
something to protect that
and this is where oliveressa makes um a
stunning decision
uh if you ask me
first trading the night for the bishop
that's fine but then making no effort to
protect the pawn on c4 alejreza plays
the move knight to f4
and that is a free pawn uh white can
capture and he does and he does and
instead of recapturing white's bishop
uh ali reza sacrifices his rook
because he feels the rook is not as
valuable as getting that unopposed light
squared bishop to the center of the
board uh so alibreza here gives up a
rook for a bishop
a sensational play yeah
and um
in in that aftermath
um the the rook on f1 is attacked so
that rook needs to move uh oliveressa
then
um putting his bishop in the middle
and rajab making a concession moving his
rook for a second time
in a row he's defending the knight
in the middle of the board
but yeah we've had a massive change
uh in this position with white now being
up a rook uh but black having some
really nice uh squares it's so funny
with their pieces when you have
commentators blind this when we first
switched to this game it's like i was in
storyline mode talking about fuji i
didn't even realize what we were looking
at right we are looking at an absolutely
fascinating position with an exchange
sacrifice on the board talk about
enterprising play this is why this is
why people are excited about this kid
because this position is an absolute
mess white's compensat sorry white's
white's issues because of the exchange
give black a lot of compensation
and elmira i mean i know he's on the
clock right now taking his time but he's
up almost an hour exactly on on the
clock you've got to be thinking that
he's in a he's in a great mental place
right now and once again you know we
were talking about computers analysis
but
this was a sacrifice a positional
sacrifice or an exchange in the style of
the old masters you know like patrician
uh well he laughed to sacrifice those
exchanges and he was really winning
games you know in a brilliant manner so
this is absolutely amazing you know i
couldn't believe uh when i had a look at
the boys and like
rook b2 was played and
i think this is uh
uh what jan ludwig
exactly described as a stunning move
yes i
i know last time i said this you you
immediately said i was wrong and i know
that there's it's very unlikely that
this particular position or move was
prep but when let me ask you this when
you when you're preparing an idea as
unique as this type of idea right you
said it the double pawns
the the odd maneuvers of the knights and
the rook on the b file
what chances do you give that if not
that exact position he probably had
looked at some idea that maybe an
exchange sack is a common theme in this
type of structure because because it
just seems so likely not just given how
quickly he's played but how confident he
feels about black's position
just by looking at him what do you think
yes oh okay so now you agree with me
that it's prep i agree with you when
you're writing oh my gosh okay yeah here
we go sorry i mean it's not prep it's
not like but the idea is clearly
something yeah yeah so the idea of
giving up the rook to have that bishop
being unopposed from the the center of
the board uh that is absolutely
something he will be familiar with uh
and uh like you said he played it so
confident so quickly uh and he's putting
extreme pressure on his uh on his
opponent
and yeah this this kid can play this kid
can play with the black pieces or the
white doesn't matter what if you anybody
who's watching at chess.com events right
now you look at the time log spent on
every move you can see just how
confident furuja is in direct comparison
to however java has spent time on the
clock it's just
amazing and now after bishop d5 rookie
won
who wouldn't rather play black in this
mission whether there's another idea
besides the one i highlighted of just
making this battery a monster
at some point maybe you look to open the
f-file right even with like f5 this
position is about to become
very very tricky for rajaba
and what's most important once again
psychologically is this he doesn't give
um a possibility to a job of uh to have
a grip you know this is a very
unbalanced position where a timor is
feeling very uncomfortable
it's like it's not like a small plus
where you can keep on playing okay if
it's a draw it's a draw no not at all
yeah like just uh
look at this position
and there are no bailouts exactly
exactly you cannot you cannot transpose
you know into some like
equal end game i was going to say
translate a bailout for the audience
because i think that's kind of an
advanced chess player theme why do you
look at this mission and say that
there's no way forward job off to give
back his exchange basically and equalize
it
well yeah um well giving back the
exchanges is
difficult in general which is why
ferrugia sacrificed it
what i mean by a bailout is is kind of
there's no way you can kind of say hmm
i'm feeling uncomfortable yeah let me
just try and make lots of exchanges
right because that bishop on d5
i'm saying that's unopposed and that's
because white doesn't have a bishop that
goes on the light squares yeah rajaba in
this position he would almost prefer to
have a light squared bishop instead of
rook right because then he could easily
try and trade for that black bishop but
the white rooks are not positioned in a
way that he can um
capture that valuable black bishop
and as such he he kind of he has to stay
under this
uh extreme uh pressure yeah
what do you think
you wanna you wanna show some ideas on
the and also
look at this knight on f4 normally like
you you have this uh this desire to play
g3 but with the bishop on on d5 and no
like uh light square bishop left for
white you know this move seems almost is
impossible to make here
you know so the knight on the force
stays there forever
and i in this to sacrifice it on g2
so maybe queen eight i i like your idea
dana you know i think
queen i ate here speaking of uh all the
hype around the kid of course we have
yet another another featured chat from
the higher space that feels ominous
to refer to from the higher space
um
my my inner voice rarely says things as
kind as higher space has said here
magnus versus holly reza everyone else's
inner voice is a jerk too i hope
everyone's inner voice has uh has a lot
of self-doubt and i'm okay sorry i won't
put myself on the therapist chair right
now magnus vs ali reza needs to happen
honestly
uh honestly i think a lot of the world
would agree with you and uh so whether
that quote came directly from above
or or just uh just a random user on
twitch most people tend to agree with
you that that would be quite the match
up so
um
hammer
i just i can't keep calling for it i
need it i need the action it's like a
fun toy a fun prop that we've added to
the show
and i don't even know or care what you
want to show over there we're gonna give
something instructive to the fans here
uh and uh
throwing throwing to young lovely camera
he's actually going to break down for us
one of the instructive moments that
happened earlier in a featured matchup
we've talked a lot about fabiano carwana
inakara nakamura hammer take it away
uh yeah danny um so i'm i'm really
interested in this nakamura versus
karana matchup
in particular because of how fabiano
makes these early trades
with the bishop against the knight now
the bishop and knight exchange is the
most interesting one in chess because we
estimate their value to be about the
same but their different qualities are
they're so different in how they move
the knight can jump the knight is better
in tight spaces the bishop is a long
range piece
and that makes it such an interesting
trade and particular that in this game
it happened twice not only in the
opening
we also now had that uh additional
situation where
fabiano because this bishop was in so
much trouble with the black pawn coming
down towards it fabiano makes the second
trade bishop for knight and is now
trying to prove that the knights are
better than the bishops in general i
want to say that bishops are good
the the fewer the pawns left on the
board right now it's seven pawns apiece
which means that the knights may hold an
advantage but in the long run
hikaru may feel that the bishop's
long-term potential and their ability to
work on the long diagonals might
actually be the more important factor so
i it's just an interesting fight
between the two different qualities of
these pieces
i love it i love it speaking of
interesting fight we see fabi moved
picardo immediately respond
and uh
and yeah we're gonna we're gonna see a
fight for many more moves here between
the two americans i think one of the
most fascinating parts of the next
exchange we saw amira is that this
allows black to undouble the pawns you
see carter doesn't need to be asked
twice to fix that issue right and uh but
look at that queen of three queen e3
played right away a7 and g5 so double
attacks okay we'll hold the phone so g4
probably i did it in black because there
is no way that you can defend both
pounds so g4 is is played already okay
so this is carlo pays a quick nod to the
higher space there on twitch looks up
before pushing the pawn there and uh
yeah you're right that move was forced
to save the pawn just for the record you
can't you can't defend this one without
g5 falling knight or queen could
probably capture
and you can't defend this one without uh
fabi getting greedy over there so so g4
played i assume we'll see knight d2
unless there's is there some other
91 or 92 91 or 92 are both possible yes
they're
we're not going to discuss knight to g5
i thought aggressive moves oh that kind
of thing danny i feel like you're a lot
more aggressive when it's not your
pieces
i was thinking about uh yes knight t1
knight g3 and f4 you know like i'm
completely obsessed with those ideas
we'll highlight real quick why this
doesn't work it's because this move
comes with a tempo if not for that
hammer's idea would be great um but
because the knight doesn't have many
squares black can gain a tempo and then
play rook g8 so it doesn't quite work
but okay knight d2 has been played and
hammer you missed it you gave us a great
breakdown thank you for that on the
dynamics between the knight versus
bishop exchange you could still now h4
what h4 would you like i mean i i don't
know like if you play bishop c4 like
let's uh i want to defend him a little
bit so i want to take his side knight g5
no no not g5 well it doesn't look good
but i mean is there a possibility to
defend my knight and well
h4 and
it's not rookie eight it's h4 oh my gosh
wow it's tricky and then you have rook
hvac because of that okay yes oh okay
you can interrupt me for tactics anytime
that's actually really fascinating
because if you did play rook g8 h4 would
likely be the response because then you
can meet ambassador with taking back or
at least i'm losing i'm not losing a
piece i i i say that my position you
know is
okay anyway we have 92
and
we have a uh
a very focused okara nakamura
yeah and and now fabiano is going to be
utilizing um o'meara's move
uh the move she highlighted in like a
sideline
uh five uh
five moves ago
which is the move f4
fabiano will try to get his rook into
the game in order to get that rook
working you first need to get rid of the
pawn standing in the way of the rook
and so now pushing that pawn forward
is going to be one of white's main ideas
simply to to open up the for the rook
and i i'm still curious where is going
to put his king well he has to deal with
the pawn too first let's remember that
part of the whole idea of the fork was
that hikaru has to protect this pawn in
some way whether it's b6 or
b5 even that would protect it okay he or
a6 i can't tell which one he played
looks like a6
and let's look at let's look at the line
you talked about because i think that f4
is certainly the most challenging move
opening the position when a king doesn't
have anywhere to go
is usually what the doctor orders
well i have to run with my king so
probably i have to take on f4 and still
play king d7 you know that was i had two
ideas f4 and king d7 for both sides oh
wow
like
we said you were the resident expert
right this is your first this is our
first candidate your second so you're uh
you're all over it
but i'm not sure it's a good sign you
know for the players
i'd say the same thing whenever i'm
guessing moves consistently
i uh i ask the players to check
themselves so no but almira i think it's
a great point and it's it's a
what do they say it's a thematic point
right it's a common thing to play for
when your opponent has overextended on a
particular flank of the board and
they've and they've in a way neglected
king safety you haven't actually
neglected king safety unless the center
opens up right and so that's the point
behind a6 he wants to play king d7 now
well and run and run
and frankly
like the the black bishop is doing a
really good job restricting the movement
of white's knight so for instance the
knight would love to go to c4
uh but that square is being controlled
by the the black bishop
so um
yeah i'm
starting to like key carver's position
actually it's uh because he now has
showcased a clear path of how to get his
king to safety he's he's just gonna move
it over to that side of the board where
he actually does have pawns still in
defense
okay but let's let's go with elmira's
idea i think it's the most challenging
move in the position unless we have new
suggestions but
that's why actually i wanted first to
play 91 93 to play four and to take with
my knight on the fourth but probably
it's too slow no i'm not sure but we'll
go for it just to see what exactly is it
well if what if king d7 is
is wasted right exactly so that's why it
doesn't work of course so
it's too slow uh then knight d2 f4 you
take
okay that was just the
that was just my line so we're still
waiting
but i think it's a pretty logical con
like line that we should analyze a four
take
rook f4
king d7 and maybe uh rook f1
right feels natural
maybe i guess king c7 challenges okay
king c72 i mean both are probably fine
yeah yeah it's
it's interesting for sure um
so it's a tricky situation because the
kings are on opposite sides of the board
and yet
an attack against the opposing king does
not feel like it's actually such a
um
it doesn't feel like it it's what's
about to happen because uh neither
player really has enough pieces uh to
put in an attacking position
um so it's
it's unclear how how you kind of take
advantage of that opposite side castling
well maybe yeah well you're simply trade
rooks and uh play the end game where the
bishop well in the long term will be
much better
which once again brings us back to we're
kind of liking he covers position i
think it's that he he's he's about to
find a really nice plan solving the main
issue he had which was the king's safety
and i want to highlight one
other just sort of long-term macro point
that i think is education about these
types of positions because you
highlighted the kings on opposite sides
of the board when we're in middle games
we think of attacks right but in the end
game especially when you have a split
board the bishop becomes better than the
knight with every piece that gets traded
from here on out so that that's a very
important thing to recognize because it
it's a clear plan for black right it
doesn't mean you can just close your
eyes and ask questions later but you
make logical exchanges and every step of
the way the bishop becomes a better
piece than a knight when you have pawns
on both sides of the board and a king
that could join the party quickly is a
very very valuable asset in an end game
with bishop versus knight so
again obviously a lot to go a lot to go
here we don't know
we don't know what will happen but i
think there's a reason we see
a a focused carwana
a caruana who knows that this is um
this is critical right now unlike the
other game like whisper java for example
are there some bailout opportunities
here for white if you're i know there's
a lot of play left but what would you do
if you were advising fobby hammer what
would you tell him not to do in a
position like this
i i just find it difficult to navigate
uh honestly i would probably play the
move a4
okay
and i'm kind of anticipating uh black to
move their king over to that side
uh and so i kind of want to get my pawn
up there
uh to begin with
uh and and give myself some some extra
options in that area
i like that a lot actually a mirror yeah
i fix it also like might be very useful
in the end game you're fixing the
structure and also like a6 b7 c6 so
uh
sometimes you can sacrifice
a piece
um
but this
is somehow i i have a feeling this is
this very abstract for the moment uh
uh i feel that you need to play
something concrete
yeah well i i mean i
i'm kind of i'm kind of liking hikaru's
position i i don't think there's a clear
way for fabiano
well to answer your question danny yeah
does he have a way of just saying saying
i'm going to make a draw by playing this
in this plan no he does not yeah i know
this
well
looks completely crazy but if we can
come back to the initial position for
example if uh
can i start okay c4 i don't like to make
those moves but c4 king d7b4 you know
something like this completely you know
out of the blue so that was my idea
yeah no it's definitely worth
uh considering just if he's not brushing
this away immediately so i'm happy with
it
well it goes back to what we were saying
about kings on opposite sides of the
board in a middle game what do you think
of you think of pawn storm so why why
does bobby have to watch ikaro do it why
can't he get involved in that type of
action too i think it's a great
suggestion
um
just
actually you know i've always been
taught you know not only to um to think
about my own plans but you also should
anticipate of course what what is your
opponent's threat or
so sometimes it's even more important to
do something against that then well to
execute your own ideas
so then like
we understood clearly that hikaru wants
to play king d7
and probably the most uncomfortable the
most dangerous move on white's behalf
should be something that would
like uh put this idea to test yeah no i
think that makes
that makes a lot of sense um and we have
we have a lot more sense to be made
today i'm uh
i'm being told it's time to take a very
very quick break so don't go anywhere of
course there is plenty of action to come
on today's on today's coverage of round
one of the 2022 feed a candidate so when
we return we are continuing to be live
from madrid don't go anywhere we'll be
right back
[Music]
this is going to be a real-time
breakdown of danny wrench's games all
time on chess.com uh that's cool
oh
in the last month i am playing 83.12.
i'm less accurate than them in every
stage yeah man that that
okay yeah thanks a lot okay so tuesday
sucks i gotta stop playing cats on
twitch oh it's because it's final
tuesday
[Laughter]
look how many blunders there were back
in december 2020 and now december 2021
1600 don't look at this number
look at look at this number
best let's go to
uh tactics
mates
you'll probably need to work on these
ones yep
every single rook fork that has
presented itself to me i have found no
one has a higher percentage of rook
forks than i do
that's correct
these are literally the night forks that
you i've missed knight d6 it you saw it
just now what is wrong with me
i could have done here and then taken
this pawn and i'm winning because my
pawns get held together that's probably
the coolest part about this feature like
these positions against pass
rook there for rookie two
and he plugged his maiden one
oh my goodness i'm awful
[Music]
good afternoon
ladies and gentlemen
and welcome to the opening ceremony of
the world chess championship candidates
tournament
[Music]
[Applause]
hello
[Music]
madrid
civilization here
is almost as old as the game of chess
some claim the queen was given her
powers to honor queen isabella
that my friends is a chess legacy
passion for chess continues to thrive in
madrid
for the first time in 30 years spain's
capital plays host to the candidates
the most important tournament in chess
at the palace of santona the stakes are
high
eight of the world's best players
competing for the right to challenge for
the most coveted title in chess
the world chess championship
[Music]
the candidates is grueling
the winner requires mental endurance and
unbreakable focus
there are those familiar with the
biggest stages in chess
yet still chasing unfinished business
and others from the next wave of stars
with little patience for yielding to
those before them
miss amigos the next challenger to the
world champion of chess must come
through madrid
like queen isabella before them the
candidates is all about leaving a legacy
[Music]
candidates tournament
round one continues to roll on here from
madrid the 2022 feed a candidates
tournament
just getting underway so far none of the
four games we've had have disappointed
us we have action as they say uh we've
been spending a lot of time recently on
the karwana nakamura game but real quick
reset a reminder of who is here live in
the uh the hot city of madrid
young lovely hammer
fill it in for robert hess shout out to
robert we won't say that that'll be the
last time we say it just kidding
almira skripchenko and uh
danny wrench right here helping to call
the action as we get set let's look at
all four games and uh decide where we
want to take this next part of the
program yeah yeah i'm i'm actually
noticing uh a big change on the eval bar
okay and the game between dingley ren oh
yeah and jan nepamyachi nepamyachi was
the previous winner
of the candidates tournament he did
challenge uh the world champion magnus
carlson last year and failed now he's
trying to get another uh match up and
that latest move uh from ding that's got
a question mark on the on the screen it
sure does and let's try to figure out
why so
in this position
what's what's the key right we've got
we've got a great night on d5 if we're
doing a wedge a wedge sort of outpost if
you will the rook lift threatened
threatened something here right it makes
you look at g5 with a little more fear
at some point but but rook to d4 is a
blunder and the question is what is it
is it because of that just very direct
idea of playing for g5 and swinging the
rook
g5
if i simply take
well let's try it we need to try of
course like we can truth
this is a very good no computer doesn't
like it go figure it was a danny move of
course nope computer does like it hold
on give it time give it time
okay so let's just look at it g5 hg5 you
can't play rook h6
so
queen takes
and and now one very key idea or or
rather a feature in the position
is that if white tries to play bishop
takes e4 which we talked about from the
very beginning of this game the the big
problem uh or the big discussion here is
whether or not white will be able to
capture this a black pawn situated
inside white's half but but here the
problem is that black is not going to
make a trade between the bishops no no
no no you're going to sacrifice your
rook temporarily so that you still have
that bishop pointing down towards the
queen and towards the rook uh and this
kind of uh pressure uh will actually be
decisive uh in uh uh you're you're
cracking up what's going on
it's like i i it's reminded me of the
great american classics you know and he
said no no no no it's like dr seuss
no no no no no no no no you shouldn't do
that you should yeah no it's like when i
talk to my six-year-old no no no that's
we don't hit
we don't hit i built my whole chess
commentary career on
butts
i love it something something something
but it's actually not working here no
but it but it's it's a critical idea
that you're highlighting and i think
it's it's been huge to the whole
position as we've said from the
beginning the pawn on e4 is the
it is the catalyst either way right
it'll either be a great thing for white
if you can win it cleanly or for black
it'll prove to be the thorn that that
helps you launch an attack and by the
way the computer still thinks that maybe
black is okay on g5 maybe maybe jan will
find something else he is but to be true
to be told uh like after g5 takes on g5
queen g5 you know uh i would rather
stick with h5 h4 because rook h6 queen
h5 you know doesn't really threaten i
mean you have like queen h2 bishop h3
then rex but uh so uh this is also a
valid like continuation and notice how
white has these doubled pawns on the e
file
um
number one having doubled pawns usually
a disadvantage but also here those pawns
are blocking white's queen
from being able to contribute in the
defense the queen cannot be on that uh
queen side on the left side of the board
pointing towards the opposite side
because
white's pawns are are blocking also i
thought you made a very good point about
the the night danny the knight on d5
which is protected by a pawn and cannot
be chased away by a white pawn which is
incredibly ironic considering the fact
that white has two pawns that should be
able to kick the knight away but it's
just this important black pawn on e4 is
just standing in the way
and yeah the pawn on e4 is just it
cannot be emphasized enough
how that is the entire reason uh black
is uh is happy uh with this game
well let's let's talk some storyline
here because you know i realized elmira
you and i spent so much time with this
stat before the event just let everyone
know some some insight insider stuff we
you know prepared a bunch of stats and
things to talk about right we talked
about how if caruana was to win
he would be joining a very elite group
of people to win two candidates well
there's another person who would be
joining that group should he win this
candidate's tournament and he's playing
black in this game and we didn't talk a
lot about that right i mean yawn i think
maybe in our memories we all still have
a little bit too much negativity
associated right with what went down in
dubai and the fact that he ultimately of
course
you know uh was sent home by magnus
carlson but
this is this has been a pretty good
showing to start although he did maybe
just miss an opportunity according to
the computer but he's still doing very
well with the black pieces in this game
versus dingley grant i do not believe
that as a double question
that is
you are personally responsible i am
personally responsible for that one and
we're gonna adjust that we're gonna
remove that from the settings for sure
because that is not a double question
mark move but it goes to show how
complicated the position is right there
there's nothing obvious about this at
all and just making a slight pawn move
on the side
of the board is just does not
uh hit the uh
computer engine's fancy
and that's because not because it's a
bad move it's because there was an
amazing move yes
and maybe that move was g5 actually yeah
as far as what the computer wanted so
there we see
full screen dingley ren
and uh
so players are wearing suits you know
that the something that you
were missing you know before the opening
ceremony in ludwig you didn't have your
tuxedos so you couldn't attend so
uh what do you think about you know
their attires because i have a funny
story
to tell you
i uh to me it just uh it feels like yeah
all the players in suits i i noticed how
everyone
got out of their uh jackets immediately
before the game uh putting them on their
chairs and i just thought it's probably
this heat in madrid that that is causing
them because i i have this thing where
um you would often get rid i would often
get rid of my jacket when i was nervous
when my body was heating up and like
removing my jacket would be actually a
sign of weakness but i i guess for some
people uh getting their jacket getting
suited up was actually a show of
strength that's interesting of course
first of all we should mention the dress
code yes because you should wear a suit
but i actually looked through the
archives and i remember the story where
like bobby fischer who followed an
advice given by paul benko at the time
after his first candidates can you
imagine so bobby fischer was one of the
youngest participants at the candidates
and he decided to
change the way he dressed and he decided
that he would wear a suit and a tie at
every tournament which followed since
then so you see that he was a trend
center yeah and maybe maybe one of chess
the game of chess first real rock stars
right because bobby fischer was a
trendsetter and now we see that it's
true if you look back through old
pictures i guess a suit
i don't know in my mind i guess i feel
like
every
great chess player has always worn a
suit i can't not picture them not
wearing a suit at a board so it's hard
but it's interesting to note that it was
fisher who maybe
first started setting that trend there
and it was really important to him you
know so
well but now it's a given now it's a
given okay
well queen to d2 has been played by
dingley ren
uh holding this position is not going to
be a given
for for dangling iran in it
yeah i'm just looking at the evil bar
danny it just
like it said and nepamyachi made a huge
mistake and now it's saying ding made a
huge mistake as well this game is just a
really really difficult one and it goes
to show
um yeah computers nowadays
stronger than humans
there was a time humans could compete
with computers and right now that just
seems
ridiculous i still remember the first
time i beat chess master on mac and boy
was that a momentous occasion for me as
a young lad but no you're right i mean
like computers are just seeing the
positions so much so much more deeply
and
humans are no longer worthy
um to compete with an in gym but all
right what what is it about the position
after queen d2 that
is it that he's given him yet another
chance to play g5 i would assume so um
but
what's interesting is that ding's
intention right now is to do an alireza
ding's intention is to give up his rook
for uh a well-placed uh
opponent's piece uh olivereza gave up
his work for a bishop uh and ding is
gonna give up his work for the night
uh and that would
really put uh some fire to this board as
if there weren't anything as if there
weren't enough red fires
as if there weren't enough fires on
board we got more fire from chat ding is
a god but nepo is more fun i um
i mean i i agree with that noted
checks out
and and i also want to note that janna
pomnyacci one of the things he's the
most famous for is his incredible pace
and that he puts extreme pleasure uh
pressure pressure not pleasure but he
does actually take pleasure in putting
pressure on the opponent
uh
by by uh getting them really low on time
and playing his moves quickly but
looking at the clock times here
he's actually behind just just barely
though but yeah
i'm with you though nepo does
wait for nepa to be one minute behind
that's true it's for like me to be half
an hour ahead right it just doesn't
happen it's fair yonda palmishi's
reputation precedes him as one of the
fastest most aggressive players on the
planet and on that note let's take a
little bit of a closer look and get to
know yonder palmishi the former
challenger in this video
defending champion jan napomnishi is
back at the candidates affecting his
second straight bid to challenge for the
world chess championship
one of the more experienced players nepo
brings to madrid an aggressive style
that is both challenging to face and
entertaining to watch
two years ago nepo made the most of his
debut in the candidates with a round to
spare he won the event in convincing
fashion
that's all he needed jan napomishi is
the 2021 world chess championship
challenge
that victory led nepo to a world
championship match with carlson and also
secured his return to the candidates in
madrid this year
despite being one of only two players in
the field to have won the candidates the
expectations for nepo are not
particularly high this time around
however his confidence from having won
here before in addition to his years of
competitive experience may offer him a
shot to turn some heads
if nepo should pull a major upset and
face magnus carlsen again the two know
each other well
nepo has competed against carlson for
decades ever since the two prodigies
were 12 years old
[Music]
yonder pomnishi
well
his career is uh is is uh an impressive
one two-time russian champion as we said
the last challenger to the throne not
more than about i guess about six i
guess eight months ago if we're going
back to the beginning of the event
and wouldn't it be amazing if he made it
there a second time so
i i remember the last time i completely
disregarded someone
to win the candidates was it me that you
oh different it was not you danny uh but
it was someone of similar age
it was vishwanathan anand
who came back after losing the match
against magnus
almost choked on that one okay
i'm not that old hammer um okay
okay
anytime you want to compare me to vichy
on any subject or topic in the entire
world i will take it as a compliment
even if it's not so so i'm okay with
that okay but what i was trying to say i
really did not think vishwanathan anand
would be able to come back uh in 2014
having just lost
the title he held for so long
uh but he did
uh and uh right now janna pomnyacci
might do the same thing he might lose a
match and come back to get that revenge
uh going right away because according to
the computers
uh black has a big advantage here
and if he were to start
with the black pieces beating one of the
pre-tournament favorites that would be
huge for yana pognichi
but once again i think the computer well
gives a huge advantage uh for black here
is because like wyatt is lacking counter
play it's like i think it's uh one
the most important point in this
position and also you remember i was
telling you that's very uh interesting
to see how ding will do in the first
round because he he did not play the
high level uh the high level for a long
time it's i simply didn't know how he's
going to perform
and uh psychologically it's very
difficult when you are not allowed to
travel
uh well even if we take into account the
second lack of the candidates you know
then he didn't travel like since the
first leg i mean he was allowed to come
to uh to play the second half but he did
so
you know the tournament didn't go well
for him that's a great point i mean
i'll ask you elmira to look into the
crystal ball because what you're
you know what you're commenting on is an
interesting untalked about storyline
there are two players in dingley run's
career there is pre-pandemic dingley run
and everyone remembers him beating
magnus carlson in the 2019 sinful cup i
remember commentating on it with robert
hess and us saying is this a preview for
the world championship match is dingley
wren the medicine for magnus carlsen
he didn't he didn't perform well during
the pandemic and now he's is he a
different player at this time right i
mean it's been a couple of years since
he's been playing as consistently at the
high level and of course it's very early
to say that and he's a pre-tournament
favorite his career and reputation you
know is is part of the reason for that
but it is it is something that we may be
looking back on in a decade
and talking about that storyline
and this is such a difficult position
i mean like physically you know i feel
like i like i'm suffocating you know
with white yeah so you don't know what
to do i was looking at knight a5 you
know this crazy move you know the knight
b3 knight c5 but this is too slow you
know this
well and speaking of too slow what we
highlighted is maybe being too slow was
that g5 idea taking with the pawn
because we thought okay there's no way
black will have time for rook h6 and
queen h2 and bishop h3 which all three
moves are needed if you're actually
going to deliver a mating attack but as
we look at the position
what is white doing to stop this plan i
think hammer's exchange sacrifices is
maybe the only option
yeah um and nepali and she knows this so
napoleon she can try to put measures
into place that will make that exchange
sacrifice
as as a less effective yeah yes yeah
and is that maybe why he's not playing
g5 just yet right i mean if your
opponent's gonna sack the exchange
let them do it and don't create more
more problems maybe yeah don't don't
create those extra weaknesses right in
front of your king okay um
and but at the same time i don't see
what else
nepal nietzsche's doing so his previous
move getting the rook that was out of
play yeah in the corner of the board
getting that rook into the middle makes
tremendous sense
but now he kind of he maximized his
position
and once you've kind of put all your
pieces in good squares that's the time
for the breakthrough so i i do believe
g5 is coming up
um this trying to to remove some of the
pawns defending white's king
and
then
ding will sacrifice his rook for the
knight in the middle ding will wait
until you make those weakening moves
before he he makes the the sacrifice you
made you made a comment about my age do
you want to you want to do the pleasure
of reading the featured chat from spendy
thompson
uh
wow i am somehow older than hammer
but look half his age
i mean i don't i don't know maybe maybe
spendy just looks 12 and i don't know or
maybe he's commenting on your at your
age i mean that leaves we'll leave that
to the
interpretation i i find it interesting
danny that you made this comment to
almira and i before the broadcast which
it was like oh yeah no there's gonna be
negative comments but you guys you just
ignore that that's that's the first
thing i learned just you know there's
always going to be some haters i was
giving you the pep talk i was giving you
a pep talk that hey i as someone who
reads hate about himself for a living
okay i usually i don't find many
positive comments on the internet i was
giving you practical advice but i mean
sometimes well i didn't realize you were
actually gonna showcase
i uh well you you know you poke the bear
with the no i'm kidding anyway uh shout
out to chat by the way we do love you
jokes aside it's a lot of fun and so
keep the keep the fun coming and we will
keep the chest coming let's head over to
our our bird's eye view and take a look
at all four games in progress of course
we
oh man as we keep saying this round is
not disappointing i i i personally want
to get back to the brilliant exchange
sacrifice that was for ruja however i
kind of feel in the order of how we
bounced around we owe duda rapport
another look before we get back there
what do you what do you think
uh sure but only a very brief okay so
we're going to take a very quick look at
due to rapport um again for those of you
who maybe uh
maybe missed it there was a
very interesting approach from duda out
of the opening not just surprising with
the move one e4 but then surprising with
the super interesting bishop to f4 and
the timon of sicilian he had a very good
position after this nice move c5 but it
looks like the edge has kind of slipped
a little bit
knight a3 the computer didn't like but
uh okay we'll just we'll get to it
and
actually it makes sense because after
rook d8 with the queen's coming off the
board you already feel a little better
as black despite the weak c6 pawn
um
yeah but bishop takes d1 is curious well
i guess he didn't want to lose the pawn
on a2 so he was afraid that if he plays
rook takes d1
then the bishop can capture the pawn on
a2 and and now i noticed the computer
saying saying nightbeat oh that's the
move that he probably missed which is
such a mad move putting that knight to
be captured by the pawn knowing that if
there is a capture here
uh it will be check made in two moves
did you just call it a mag move like
magnus
did i miss hear that
yes
but that was a reference to magnus
that's a mag move
no
mad mad you said that's such a mag's
move no i did not say i don't know what
you said but i thought you did i was
going to give you props for the oh
really well then i did say that yes
thank you okay
by the way just to make sure we return
all things back to balance here in the
universe we have positive tip positivity
coming for you in the chat we love you
hammer we love you hammer so don't worry
we giveth and taketh away with the chat
comments but uh just so you know they do
love you um okay how does it go in this
song you know sledgehammer it's a
sledgehammer
this is brilliant though and i want to
talk about this because the question is
was this missed
i mean
i and
probably not that in um i think what was
missed was the move f6
and then uh you have to retreat the
bishop
seemingly
and then you'd capture the pawn but then
simply knight c4
like playing position
wow so i think something like this was
more likely to be missed these players
don't really
uh they they can spot a lot of trickier
things than giving away your knight for
a pawn to give checkmate
later on i think it's more likely to
that they mis-evaluate a position like
this right where you sacrifice a pawn
temporarily but you kind of make sure
that black's rook has a really hard time
getting back into the game well it's
interesting though because i i actually
i agree with you hammer i think it's
very likely that
that judah saw this sort of brilliant
idea of knight to b5 and again if you
don't take it by the way you're
threatening knight c7 and then another
version of checkmate on d8
but
but this is a hard thing to see where
you see the idea of giving up a pawn for
compensation on a weird move like knight
to c4 because
it's it's not an aggressive move right a
lot of times at the end of a line you're
looking for the for the knockout punch
not the sort of you know re-centralizing
of a sideline piece but
um either way the only other criticism
that might be worthy to do even though
it's during the event is he did play
through it very fast right and and he
was clearly better so so now that we go
to the live position because you you
made me promise for it to be quick
the advantage is no longer significant
for white right before we go back to
rajava farouja so
you know
he might regret how quickly he handled
that potentially critical moment yeah no
duda has has definitely misplayed the
situation he's still better
but uh
black has managed to get some trades
and the the pawn structure has been kind
of defended by the black king combing
coming over to to help out uh with the
pawn on on c6 and the pawn on a7 which
remains the the two big weaknesses in in
black's position well you still have
this bishop on g7 so you should uh solve
this problem as well mm-hmm maybe that's
why h5 was played perhaps to offer
bishop h6 and then if this you go back
to f8 and just play tickle right
draw offer
okay well speaking of draw offers let's
talk about uh duda's record head-to-head
against the field he's uh had a decent
amount of draws against his opponents
although
like ferugia not nearly as many games as
some of the some of the older more
experienced players right almira
anything stand out to you um i guess
he's playing against one of the
opponents he has the most games against
exactly but first of all i'm thinking
about do this victory against magnus
carlsen so maybe these statistic well do
not really reflect his potential and his
strengths although you know he he was
not very um consistent also in his
performance he needs
uh well probably
like a higher performance it's been said
that in order to win candidates i
suppose you need like
28 something like uh performance so um
he won the world cup he beat magnus and
he also beat magnus before when he ended
his uh
uh well not losing strike i suppose you
know so uh it was 125 games before he
he lost the game against young sisters
so um
what strikes me the most it's like uh
zero wins you know when i look zero like
around zero a job of zero ferugia zero
and nakamura also zero but in part
that's caused by the fact that he hasn't
played against yeah he's he's played
he's played so little i mean although
for the ferugia record kind of stands
out a little bit right zero wins and
four losses is not that's not a donut
that you're happy to put out and put up
in the w column um
although okay anyway i agree totally and
of course we'll continue to check in on
all of the head-to-head matchups between
our eight candidates throughout the
event um let's head over to our bird's
eye view remind you again you've got all
four games in action you can continue to
choose which game you want to follow
most keep our keep our coverage locked
in and pull up all the games at
chess.com events because we're going to
head over to rajaba for ruja
the most experienced oldest player in
the field in tamworth
we have the youngest least experienced
at least as far as the candidates go and
uh the least amount of games against all
of all of the collective other seven
opponents in ali reza perugia but it
doesn't seem to matter let's uh let's
check out what happened in this game he
played a an enterprising and brilliant
exchange sacrifice
on this move
uh move knight 18 with rook takes b2
giving up the rook for the light squared
bishop because it has a wonderful home
and as we kind of predicted the battery
would be the main follow-up a battery in
chess is when you line up a queen behind
either a bishop or a rook uh pieces on
doubled up on a file or a diagonal often
referred to as a battery and this
battery is
well it's an energizer bunny it's just
going to keep on going yeah but did you
just notice that only one move from
black and one move from white has
happened since we were last in this
match-up and look at the clocks last
time we looked at this game farouja had
a
58-minute time advantage yeah right now
that time advantage is down to just six
minutes yeah furuja has been thinking
basically for an hour straight
uh which is um concerning
what is he concerning or is not super
confident about his position it means
that he doesn't feel like there's an
obvious way uh to continue well
quincy too you know like what he was
worried about that's this obvious idea
of playing knight g5 you know an iron
the mate
so he was
considering
the risk so he took on a3
and i don't know like uh if knight g5 is
still possible probably uh which knight
we want to move
both both have merit right yes
well i wanted to play knight
eg5
and maybe just g6 or
g6 i didn't really like because then i
can even play knight e4 and maybe like
uh play knight f6 like so maybe it's not
like a good idea
well the reason knight fg5 was also
interesting everyone is because it's
less uh less direct but you have a
subtle discovered check and then
checkmate now on the agenda so this this
also may have been even even
better and by the way we might see it on
the board i mean bishop takes a3 has
been played so certainly rajab will be
thinking about both of these moves
but i wanted to counter point again just
because i love i love bantering with you
hammer the devil's advocate view to
to what you said about perugia taking a
bunch of time and lacking confidence is
that is it also a sign of maturity in
that when you recognize you have
an advantage on the clock and you know
it's a critical position you use that
time and you make sure you properly
assess as deeply as you can
where you want the game to go i agree uh
with that okay and if he had spent like
15 minutes per move that would be fine
but once you start spending 30 minutes
40 minutes 50 minutes on one single move
you're you're basically just going
around and around in your head right and
you can't really kind of
you're at that point you're struggling
to organize your thoughts and and yeah
showing some some lack of confidence so
i completely agree that you can and
should uh spend your time in the
critical positions and that it's um
especially good to do that when you're
up on the clock so that you don't feel
like oh i have to go fast because i want
to keep my time advantage no you want to
use your time advantage to be able to
spend that time in the critical moments
however
he did not spend 15 minutes for a couple
of moves he spent way more than that and
i think that is a bad sign
on the note of hammer's
criticism then he actually made me think
of another point i want to ask you about
one of the other storylines surrounding
ferruccia besides magnus carlson's
comments has been
his his
disappearance in 2022 his lack of
participation in many of the biggest
events
many of us of course remember the talbot
venice sort of self-written
autobiography on the match where there
was criticism to bodbinic because he
didn't play nearly as much as tal that
he was making those types of practical
mistakes using too much time not his
confidence everything hammer just said
just literally brought up that memory to
ask you like do you think maybe there's
something to that
it's absolutely incredible that you're
brought up to be like tom between
because just before the tournament i
also wanted to have a look at the second
match and i had to look at the games
when between one and do you know how
many uh
like decisive games do you remember how
many decisive games there were in this
match i think like from 21 games there
were 15 decisive games so it meant that
batwinik has spent all of this time
analyzing well his well his mistakes the
preparation the strategy the opening so
it was like
a new version of batwinnick who beat
that yeah so i think the same is
probably true for uh alireza because he
well he disappeared from the tournament
scene in in order to
well analyze well his own play also
maybe uh well also not to reveal the
preparation of course but there's so
much work to be done before the
candidates and not enough time
so maybe the reflexes that he had so
it's it's very important to take this
time and uh
well also to rebuild your repair tour to
well to build the team we didn't talk
about seconds by the way
we've got three weeks here in madrid so
we'll get into that maybe we also have a
new version of valeria you know playing
this tournament it's i think but
everything you just highlighted kind of
supports the point that you highlighted
preparation reinventing yourself keeping
things secret but there's one big
trade-off in all of those things which
is that you're not playing actively and
the practical muscles you build as far
as time management critical decision
making here we see team river java's
quote again talking about all this focus
on perugia everyone has chances and i've
been playing not necessarily preparing
at a higher level much longer than the
kit right so i think that that's kind of
the trade-off right and to hammer's
point taking 50 minutes is way different
than taking 15 minutes
well
it might be true and of course the only
tournament that taylorizer played this
year was the super bit in bucharest and
he didn't perform that well
but this is a valuable experience maybe
he didn't
show also like his opening ideas so he
wanted like also to have the feel of his
opponents and um
i'm torn you know because i think it's
really very important
to take the time and to evaluate the
risks especially in this position
and
maybe he was a bit of a like
impulsive player before what do you
think analytic
i mean
the guy kind of just seemed like a beast
uh he he was winning
um
uh everything
uh but um yeah no i mean i i do
appreciate the comments about it making
sense to kind of take a step back and
looking at what you can do better but
at the same time i feel like there's a
case to be made for alireza to just keep
playing as much as possible because he
was winning every time he played but how
often are we given an opportunity
well uh
to get a little perspective you know we
always play and especially there's now
there's so many online uh competitions
in life and then uh it's sort of of um
like
you have to rehab rehabilitate re
heavily evaluate everything yes so
because like normally you continue
continue continuing then you're 60 and
you know
and the life is good
so i think uh
that was important decision i think on
the board of like for resistance well i
i think he will be judged on that
decision based on how it goes on how it
goes here 100 percent couldn't agree
more and that's our job is to commentate
and speculate right but i think the
ultimate judgment will come down to
how he performs and which which strategy
paid off
speaking of performances we need to get
back to the one between the two
americans we don't have to split
attention if you're
following american players we only have
one game to focus on
and that is
fabiano carjuano versus carl nakamura
what and the king is on james i was
going to say what a position
here based on what we had are you are
you kidding me what happened in this
game
after we left it when fabiano was on the
clock with a6
he castled he played first first he
played b3
right and then hikaru castled yeah um so
we kind of made the assumption that
hikaru was trying to make his king go
over
uh to the opposite side of the board um
which would not have been a bad idea
considering that there are absolutely no
pawns
uh guarding hikaru on that side where he
did choose to put his castle
and now that he he has made that
decision uh fabiano tries to activate
his his rook so he moves his pawn one
step forward wants to make a trade with
that black pawn so that he can open up
for his rook uh the trade does happen
um and then rook d1
why was that such a good move
this move i don't understand
uh but then hikaru makes the
controversial decision to push forward
in the center this is this is a
super aggressive approach for
nakamura given given the position he had
and again it's
it's still clearly an unbalanced one
right the eval bar close to level and
you know the dynamics of bishop versus
knight but
if i'm if i'm just watching this as as a
nakamura fan i'm like
a lot more stressed here way more
anxious about black's chances you know
because while the pawns are in the
center they're also vulnerable while my
king is finally out of the center it
doesn't mean it's any more safe over
here right you don't want your queen to
be the only piece guarding your king
right this is
i think it's objectively fair to say
that that was that was a very risky
decision if not necessarily
the the worst one than just tucking the
king over here
it just feels very very scary to have
walked right in
to danger and uh
we we are going to have blood on this
board i believe this is this is
very double edged here
yeah and and i think
um let's just say that
no maybe this is right how do you play
because yeah if you play e4 c4 no yeah
e4 c4 and that undermines the pawns and
also the clock is reflective of the fact
that maybe hikaru less sure if if if you
don't play e4 how are you guarding the
pawn so so i feel like we have to look
at this line
yeah
i was not sure maybe you trade first
then uh c4 or c4 first
like
okay so you just want to liquidate
everything you've taken it all off the
board yeah
but it's just it's funny how you just
like in your head as a human you say i
can't take here the queen takes and she
and then she attacks my bishop but in
reality
uh that might be what black has to do
and then you just what i guess go here
and you're just okay
my voice says i'm nervous
well especially with knight g3 yeah or
even just or even just takes but okay if
it takes then queen d4 i'm sorry i was
missing queen before but 93 makes a lot
of sense because g4 is
oh man
amazing how a computer looks at this
position and says oh danny silly danny
tricks are for kids this is just a draw
we're just going to take all the pieces
off the board but
i
i mean that white knight is kind of i'm
gonna put the knight on f5 and i'm gonna
check mate i don't know how
this looks scary for black
wow but what is the computer evaluation
i cannot see this minus 0.2 so it's
better for black but barely i mean
that's why i just look right here i
don't look i don't look at the top
i forget like to look at the bar on the
left just
if we go back to the current position
okay um i i think
if hikaru could keep his pawn on e5
um this would be quite acceptable for
him so i'm not sure that it's
the
the black king is the problem here okay
i think right now the problem is that
black is unable to keep those pawns next
to each other and that's the optimal
strategy you want to use with pawns you
want to have them controlling both the
light squares and the dark squares and
they can only do that when they're next
to each other
and what fabiano is doing now he's
trying to force the the one of the pawns
uh to to move forward and and then
you're gonna be um concerned uh about
the lack of
well a dark squared control if the e
pawn moves forward or or a light squared
control
if the other pawn were to move forward
and and like almira said yes this
undermining move is is an interesting
idea but you might also want to make the
trade of rooks first
and like
i mean if you could as white you'd love
to also like put a knight on d4 or
something right but one of the
dynamic factors that is that is making
this position work for hikaru is that
while while it feels flimsy you don't
like that you had to advance the pawns
as hammer said
it's also white's pieces that are
struggling for ideal spots right so it's
it's kind of uh
like if white could just put a knight on
d4 or let alone one of these other dark
squares
you'd be like oh
but it's not so clear how white does
that other than the undermining idea
excuse me pawns don't move that way if i
could do that that might also be
interesting by the way anyway uh c4
but if black can just take it then maybe
maybe black's okay
yeah but but here maybe black cannot
it's a tricky position damn it's a very
tricky position but it does feel like
um hikaru being forced off that pawns on
opposite collars uh it does feel like
that is
advantageous there was something
bothering hikari he was looking you know
yeah yeah he's away and
i don't think well he likes his position
very much now
he's deep
he's deep down the rabbit hole right now
ladies and gentlemen that is a the
second slime that is a hikaru nakamura
who has taken the red pill
who are his seconds yes well we know he
works with chris littlejohn yes we know
for sure of course and uh that's chris
chris is here with him in madrid hi
chris shout out to chris um
other than that i i have no i have no
idea
who hikaro might be working with i know
that because he mentioned in in the
interview it's a very interesting
interview it's like a very sincere one
because he asked several players to help
him to prepare for the candidates but we
don't know well well
we have no names yeah we have no names
well
i don't think we have names for
for many right we know that fabiano is
back to working with choo choo love
right it's been seen and noted of course
i've seen nikita togo at the opening
ceremony so he is uh helping i was
teasing him i was because he was
standing close to yon i'm like i assume
you're here as a second right and never
mind he was like yeah that's the only
reason i'm here so yeah ludwig are you
here as a second
in these guys
well i'm i'm danny's you're just you're
you're number one you're not number two
in my heart no i'm kidding um
anyway well no but seriously we saw
carlos shaking his head we know that
this is a tough position
going to be much deeper right now than
anything we're calculating not
not to disparage our commentary but
there's just no way obviously we would
be keeping up with whatever it is that
has hikaru shaking his head in
frustration it's probably many many more
moves ahead of the live position we're
looking at um
and he needs to make he needs to make a
big decision here
the e pawn is hanging it's that simple i
mean there's a concrete thread on the
board
you got you got to play e4 yeah
honestly i'm i'm curious what his
alternatives are yeah like what is he
thinking about how can he protect this
pawn in the middle
without moving forward well he can take
first so rook f1 and then play e4
if that makes any difference but then
yeah you know but that does make a big
difference yeah he probably will
uh capture the the white rook first
because
fabi will if e4 is played
okay no we're gonna find out well i
thought but i was wrong
well the action is on the board hikaru
plays e4 caruana immediately returns um
for many of our online chess viewing
community who are huge fans of hikaru
it's also an experience to watch the
players come and write down a move a lot
of a lot of players and and who are new
to chess and learned online whether it
was queen's gambit or anything else
they've never written down a move on a
scoresheet before so i've gotten a lot
of questions i'm just i'm sharing i've
gotten questions from fans who asked
like what are the players doing when
they return i'm like well you have to
write down your moves and they're like
well why doesn't doesn't the pgn just
keep track of it it's actually an
interesting point like because score
sheets started before we had the
technology we do i digress well it's
also there for people whose games are
not transmitted on the internet it's
fair
uh so it's it's a tradition well i'm so
old you know since i'm a dinosaur you
know it's just like i actually like
before you were jordan games so i
actually had a few times where you had
well i had to seal you know my game
under the envelope so you know so you
join the game you ride the move
then you analyze the whole night and you
come back
and then you the play resumes so
yeah i i think to to newer viewers that
just although many of them saw the
queen's gambit and there's that whole
scene with the german so actually it is
true a lot of them are more familiar
with it because of that scene anyway all
right we move on from the legendary beth
harmony we head back to our bird's eye
view before we're going to switch things
over to the i think we have to go to the
dingley run yonder palm tree game guys
right um guys and gals excuse me we've
we've got action
in the wrong
way a second is there is there a winning
move on the board right now for black
how did we get here
uh
we had said it was i'm not going to
spend a lot of time but all right rookie
eight
king h2
and after bishop g4
is a bold move
like you're facing this massive oh my
gosh you're king and you're just putting
the king on the same
line i think the i think the movie has
to be obvious right just
g5 yeah no for sure it's obvious oh
computers hate me as usual
apparently i was wrong but this whole
sequence you know like i think with more
time the computer will come back to
agreeing with me the g5 is the move okay
but that actually it all makes more
sense to me now at least i see the move
too yeah rook h1
so this is this is actually very clever
from thing yeah he was wondering how can
i get more pieces close to my king to
help out in defense
and he says i'm going to move my king up
so that the rook can kind of join from
yeah
that's a fascinating idea so
this was probably his idea on the
previous move as well
yeah absolutely wild he plays king h2
walks into the face of danger
to actually defend his king from the
danger of the queen what an interesting
idea so rook
rook f6 has now been played
and it attacks the f2 pawn i guess
that's the other way to expose the fact
that the king left g1 yeah
and now if the queen steps back to e1
to defend the pawn then you can play g5
then uh jan will go g5
uh because
if the queen now steps back
uh the
the
the the rook
from
the opposite corner will not be uh be
able to to join the party yeah so king
g1 we might be back to g5 well there's
no way he's playing king g1 right yeah
there's no there's no more rook h1 so
that's so well i was actually saying
queenie one but yeah the the the
reasoning is the same
that the the rook is unable to to get
over to that other side
um
and what does that leave like how do you
defend this pawn on f2
uh you can try to go rook f1
um
but then there's this bishop and uh and
oh wait just bishop two yeah the bishop
and queen are actually pointed down
towards a white pawn
and
yeah that doesn't work either by the way
the move i accidentally suggested
quotation fingers has been played on the
board
it actually seems like the most logical
thing to do in hindsight because of
everything you highlighted
every other way to defend the pawn was
worse rook f1 bishop e2
queen e1 g5 is devastating because now
you no longer have rook h1
so in fact king g1
makes the most sense
but now
nepamyachi will make his move he will go
g5 a move frankly we've been waiting for
uh for quite some time now
trying to open up uh towards the white
king and yeah it's very likely that ding
will be checkmated i think maybe it's
also
an important moment
because dingo has only 22 minutes left
so now he has to deal with this move you
know so g5 now yeah he took his time he
took his time able to increase the
pressure
well i think was uh
well playing
somewhat you know senseless move to me
like queen d2 then knight a5 you know i
don't know what he was actually doing it
looks like a computer which had a bag in
a like an algorithm so uh king h2 of
course there was a rook each one idea
but
it was you know not very harmonious when
when you play a complex game against a
very strong opponent
it's always fun
yonda palmishi's quote right now
you enjoy the process i think uh a fun
quote from jan i think that emulates his
personalities other people know him you
know an exciting player enjoys chess if
he starts off with a win against dingley
wren he will definitely be having fun
and enjoying the process
of the 2022 fidei candidates wouldn't
that be a storyline if i feel like one
guy who many people have said
not necessarily overtly dismissed but
because of what happened in dubai are
just not talking about yonda pandashi
but a win with black
is there any game that's more clear of
an advantage for either player no no i
mean he's totally in the driver's seat
here but simply paraphrasing
young ludwig you know
having pleasure and putting pressure
john ludwig as he said
about john he uh
he has pleasure and putting pressure on
people and i think well what you said
was actually really true that he didn't
play g5
until now until the 20 minutes on the
clock and i think you made a really
mirror's point there as far as how the
x's and o's on the board are reflected
in the psychology i think is is really
important to note there because
less experienced players when they see
an idea and they may even be right that
it's a good idea they rush it right
experienced players they massage the
position they get their opponent under
time pressure and only play the critical
idea when they know it will have uh
maximum impact
and i think dingley wren we're gonna
look at his head-to-head because it's
one of the few players we haven't looked
at yet but i think dingley wren is uh
is in a head-to-head matchup that he is
not happy about right now in round one
versus yonder palmishi hammer anything
else about his particular score stick
out to you i think i know where you're
going to go with this but i'll let you
do it anyway uh i think the fact that he
has quite a significant plus score
against fabiano carrana
is definitely something to look out for
although
considering now what seems to be
transpiring yeah maybe ding and karana
are not gonna be the two players going
head to head like many had expected
myself
included
maybe we're gonna have to look at
new match-ups that are going to be the
most crucial ones
if ding is to lose his uh uh first round
game and and like fabiano like we saw
has some potential of of winning so uh
one favorite may get an amazing start
another one
a horrible one
and that kind of changes the whole the
whole uh tournament
well said dingley wren is uh now under
20 minutes um i don't have every other
player's clock in front of me at least
not where i can see it but i think he's
i think he's the first player under 20
minutes so not a good sign and
elmira back to the psychology i know
that we say that ding pretty much always
looks as cool as a cucumber is that a
thing or is it as cool as the other side
of the pillow well for the moment he
looks as red as a tomato to me
ding not has not played very well
compared to nepo feature chat um i think
right now that's uh that is 100 true
and now we've got another one nepo is
terrifying in these positions completely
agree with that one this is
these are exactly the type of positions
where yon is uh at his best and i think
almira made a really great point about
it's not that he played g5 it's how and
when he played it
and and ding is ding is facing the heat
here yon
uh yeah he definitely is and and i just
thought maybe we should take a look at
one of the more
uh obvious moves uh in this position uh
which would be for white to capture the
black pawn on e4
nice try danny but uh i yeah oh i
thought we were gonna show the checkmate
line that's what i want well let's let's
just let me show it real quick sure just
because some of us you know need to see
checkmate on the board every once in a
while to continue
our fascination and love affair with the
game so the book comes over and the
point is
actually no we'll do something even more
fun
i want to go after a rook i don't want
the night i'm just showing the idea of
how dangerous this is and that should
this happen on the board
real problem so that's not the obvious
move the obvious move is to take e4 take
it away hammer
um well yeah um
to be honest danny i don't really
understand why it's so bad to capture
this pawn okay let's find out yeah we we
kind of talked about this pawn for the
entire game saying that if white could
get rid of this then then it would
probably be uh quite uh
quite nice you're playing actually with
the piece down unfortunately you know
this knight on a5 is not in the defense
so uh there is no way like you're going
to defend your king
how are you going to defend the citadel
yeah tell me
uh well i'm struggling with it as of now
um
yeah no i i was going to take the the
knight in the center i was just going to
try and trade
as many things as you would as possible
yeah threatening checkmate on h2 so i'll
have to take back
um
and yeah
to be honest i was kind of hoping to
make more trades
with something like rook f1
but it it does occur to me that it will
lead to a checkmate in five moves
uh okay so um i'm gonna show it real
quick yeah
takes takes
shake and bake
shake and bake again if the king ever
goes to e1 queen g1 is made
and uh wouldn't that
wouldn't that be a bad way to end it i
don't think we will but look at that i
didn't think we would have this either
but grandmaster robert hess apparently
recovering just enough right now
from the uh the covet virus to say that
okay for those who asked b5 is to loosen
the defense of the knight on d5 so
apparently robert must have suggested b5
for white okay white threatens b takes
c6 b takes c6 knight takes it so we're
going to show it
b5 and the idea that robert's pointing
out is of course you cannot take here
because that pawn is critical to the
defense of the knight
and the idea is that if something like
this happens
a trade on c6 followed by knight takes
c6
sacrifices a piece only temporarily to
win the knight on d5 that's actually
hey robert house you're pretty good at
chess maybe you should consider
commentary for a living um that's that's
an idea we should look at for sure thank
you robert go back to bed
yeah
so i guess the big question is is number
one will ding find this b5 move
and and number two if
if he does anything else probably it's
just game over yeah this looks like a
really strong idea from
the man who you cannot spell chess
without let's look at this line again
though so if takes takes robert's idea
really highlighted well right
white is simply capturing here and
undermining the knight but okay h takes
g3 first right this is the key point
threatening queen h2
and after f takes g3 does black have
something else in store now that white's
king has been sort of blown open right
it feels it feels
uh
ominous i guess the end is nigh
at least it would seem that way but i
don't i admittedly don't see a knockout
blow for black
yeah the computer is saying queen e5
which is just an incredible move queen
e5 here yeah it's just oh yeah queen e5
wow i didn't see it but but like
the knight is actually not hanging
because of the rook oh yeah i was
testing you that's kind of clever
and but i mean i would also be afraid of
the opponent getting a pawn
one step away from becoming a new queen
but that that's a huge computer idea
because obviously it's queen takes g3
and
well now you can take the knight
but i'm assuming there's some sort of
rook lift for mate i mean like h3 it's
like look at those double pawns we
talked about this earlier yeah but those
double pawns white has is like the worst
thing ever because it means that the the
white queen is just unable to contribute
in in defense
and ding look at ding he he just
continued grabbing stuff he captured the
pawn on b7 now he's trying to get his
knight back into defense computer is
giving a massive advantage and it's got
to be the same idea h takes g3 h takes
g3 queen e5 is that not it
it looks oh wait there's no there's no
knight g7 bishops move backwards dan
thanks for the tip
yeah yeah that does feel like an
interesting option
uh oh my gosh this is but here like
after eight two three after just three
queen e5 i can still defend with queenie
one
that's true can you then knight my two
three oh okay
okay let's let's pause 10 seconds here
for station identification on the yonda
pandashi attacking network what is the
move i don't know that it's queen e5
but what else is
e4 is hanging now i mean i i kind of
like this idea from dave yeah no i mean
he's definitely trying to get pieces
back into defense yeah
and um
quite succeeding in that i i did notice
that the computer wanted to go h3
instead of h6 g3 can we flip
what can we flip the board like i find
it's much easier to attack when you look
when you look at this you can't do that
it'll mess up all of our templates it
has to be we just have to visualize it
from black side um
but wait hammer you said the computer
likes h3
it did at some point
why uh well the idea is that you're
attacking the bishop and if the bishop
moves you just continue forward with
that pawn yeah uh and then your rook
comes in
uh and you know there are a lot of black
pieces right you should
and that seems kind of scary yeah
threatens me
so that means you'd have to take e4 here
yeah but even when you take on e4
there's oh with the knight
uh i'm not saying it's good
yeah i could probably just take on g2
and just get two pieces for the rook
makes sense
no actually it's checking oh wait no no
it was check although if rook d5 it was
checkmate for the record this is a fun
idea but of course black is checkmating
you instead of allowing you to
fork on f6 um love that e-bell bar heart
attack
okay um
we have zoomed in on yonda pomnishi if
you're just tuning in this is only round
one of the 2022 f8 candidates where have
you been your mom has been calling and
saying hey the candidates is going honey
did you know you should go watch it
we've got the candidates rolling and we
might have our first decisive game
moments away i know it's early but
elmira and jan
well first we've got a fun feature chat
from our own bic
producing and chatting at the same time
he says nepo learned he's so much at
he's so much at the board compared to
the wc
example learned what it's like he's not
staying away it's it's very important
for the concentration base i didn't i
missed i put the wrong emphasis on the
wrong syllable i get what you were
saying bit i agree go ahead america i
think yes it's sort of a young reloaded
you know like he also analyzed his games
and i suppose you know he's been
quite impulsive at times so i think that
even if it's not your move you're
staying at the board you are still
analyzing the position and you know it
does not distract you so
that's uh it's a very fine observation
yeah i i have a i have a slightly
different take on the same observation
though
yawn walks around more when he's not
happy with his positions and it's
something that historically i've
observed a lot about his career so me
and robert commenting on the 2021
candidates were saying the same thing
consistently we're like look at this new
nepo he's focused he's at the board he
was taking his time and
when it wasn't happening in dubai my
initial response was that that was the
cause but i think it was actually the
opposite i think he was walking around
because jan when he feels dejected about
his own chess he tends to not put as
much effort at the board when he's happy
he tends to be a little more dialed in i
have another explanation like from my
personal experiences like because i also
walk a lot and
like peter swiddler works a lot it's
just it's very difficult for me to
handle the pressure of waiting
for my opponent to move you know it's
like it's also a way to evacuate this
pressure but i know it could be
uh very disturbing at times so uh like i
know that i asked myself for so many
times that sit
sit down yes sit down just sit down you
know like spend like a few minutes more
he does point this way stage three
the the kind of anti-human but
strongest move according to the computer
we might be moments away from a decisive
result here well i i tend to disagree
that it's anti-human i think it makes a
lot of sense
attacking one of the opponent's pieces
and this whole idea is of course based
on the fact that once the bishop moves
you will continue forward to give a
check i'll show this one real quick
because it's also a fun one you give
check and when the king runs
well okay i actually thought it was a
knockout but where is the knock yeah i
don't really see it there's no oh bishop
g2 bishop
bishop where what g-22
yeah and then bishop h
bishop g2 you queen yes
no you go bishop g2 is black
no first of all bishop g2 is black wow
what a move
by the way
your fist pump at spotting bishop g2
that was epic over there i've never seen
a grown man more excited about spawning
a tactic by the way it's also queen f5
whatever okay
so good okay h3 is played there is no
move yet uh dingley wren down to less
than 15 minutes on the clock
uh we already looked at knight takes e4
should we look at it again uh yeah
we didn't really make a conclusion did
we i think elmira said just take the
bishop right
yeah but then take the knight and
well but then rook age four
i wasn't sure this was obvious what's
funny is that this is how good the
position has got that we're just
completely dismissing we don't want this
because you know we want to mate right
but of course giving this check is
probably a pretty clearly winning ending
for black
uh no no because of h6
okay for many reasons danny but yes that
being one of them okay
no well please try entering that move
well i already know that there's better
i'm just saying this is also possible
well just see it i don't want to see
what the email board does
okay
let's make it i'll do it just just so
everyone can yell at me
okay it wasn't that bad
i get it i get it okay uh we've got uh
oh someone says danny hammered once
again i think that tweet that not tweet
that chat has double meaning
and uh
i i am indeed getting hammered on this
show
right now
um
all right hammer
yeah okay it does
there there does seem to be some
attacking opportunities
for black in that situation that means
that getting those the knight and bishop
for the rook was actually uh a good
thing
of course but then um
i still feel that the position
is completely winning you know so
for black there yeah yeah
it's like uh
you might be disappointed you know that
you well you didn't that you didn't mate
your opponent but
at the end what matters the most is that
you simply win a game
yeah it's um
and ding now
fortunately for him he
only has to agonize over this for
another 11 minutes well we did have some
questions uh about the uh time control
uh in this event and right now there's
two hours
uh for the first 40 moves they don't get
any additional time
so so ding right now he needs to make
another 13 moves in the next uh 11
but also
he needs to avoid getting checkmated and
i too feel the ladder
is more difficult uh than uh than the
first yeah we didn't talk about the time
control actually at the candidates
because we are used to playing
tournaments with different time control
so and normally we would have like one
one hour 30 30 minutes plus 30 seconds
you know so we use a different time
control at the candidates and the world
championship
no i think the reason they are using
this time control is because this is
what also what is used in the in the
match yes exactly that's what i'm saying
so this no no i mean not different here
and the world championships so different
than the official tournaments that we
used to play so that's uh that's why so
uh
for traditionally at the individual
tournaments and uh team championships we
are used to play with the
quicker time control
but all a quicker time control but also
one that is more forgiving
if you use up all your time because you
know at the minimum you'll always have
30 seconds to execute each move whereas
uh here uh if you use all of your 120
minutes that you start out with if you
spend
like 119
in the first 30 then you got one minute
to make 10 moves and that's it if you
don't average uh a move every six
seconds you're out but you lost the game
it's funny because i mean when i was
playing competitive tournament chess um
and i don't know what it was for for
both of you but i was very aware of how
much i i took note of how much time i
had on the clock and i would almost
divide how many average minutes i had
removed once the opening stage was over
because sometimes after the opening
you're already thinking on you know as
early as nine or something right
sometimes maybe you're almost 17 or
something right but the moment i was out
of the opening and i knew i was going to
start spending time did you guys ever do
that was that just my mental illness i
would do a quick average math i'm like
all right i can take three minutes per
move on average and and i would complete
time control like everyone did this okay
i'm just making sure because i don't
know how crazy like i'm like i've never
known a person in my life
no no this is a completely crazy time
management
no i i was saying i would have said it
it's not that i would do it but i would
make a mental note right of course it's
sort of uh well but you're trying to
anticipate you know but for example look
at alexander grishoek how is he playing
his games you know so i
i mean every situation should be
like looked at as unique especially in
chess you know the situation can change
well so dramatically and uh well
what i would do is like i would note
that sometimes i would spend more time
than then i should have right
on which would you would you do this
ever like if you've got now you're down
to 20 minutes and you've got
you know 15 moves to make would you like
did you ever sort of do some sort of
mental plan or map on how you would
manage your time for the remaining
of the time control
now that i can think of okay interesting
i think we're about to have a checkmate
on the board
what
uh
look at this ding has captured the pawn
in the center of the board with his rook
we didn't even think about that because
we were looking at the bishop is
attacked so we got to save the bishop
but with taking using the rook to
capture
ding is now threatening the black rook
but then we can take on g2 and use the
same mechanism and sacrifice the rook
and f2 precisely okay so we already
looked at this checkmate
so takes on give up the
give up the rook
and then we already have it rook takes
f2 king takes f2
and the rest as they say is a matter of
technique we looked at this when white
had no rooks but it turns out even when
white has two rooks that's fine
you it doesn't matter that white is is
two rooks up hold the phone ladies and
gentlemen tuning in
we might have our first decisive result
and it is not the result that many
people predicted
if yon
finds this now sort of clear combination
he will be
punching his ticket to a victory look at
that look at it he sees it he's a little
that's a young opponent
that's a yawn who knows
john's hungry john's hungry he sees it
oh yeah no he definitely sees it this
game is over and john nepomneochi with
the black pieces
the comeback story he he has been um
underestimated by many
uh myself included i just say i i did
not see jan uh winning this once again i
thought he's too unstable maybe he still
is time will show it's a marathon of a
tournament but he
is about to get off to what is the
greatest start possible deal beating uh
the bookmaker's favorite to win the
entire thing with the black pieces
what a result
well i told him that you know dean was
bookmaker's favorite so what a start but
actually i was thinking maybe it's also
easier to play a tournament when you're
an underdog you know i've been looking
uh
at the team sports especially like how
they deal with uh
the pressure and fabiana was talking
about this at the very beginning so some
of the teams especially in baseball you
know in american baseball they uh
they uh intentionally start even if they
won the title several times they
intentionally start like
uh
as an underdog
like psychologically
so it's clean slate
you know we start all over again he's
played h takes g2 he sacrificed his rook
and uh well
ding yeah
he knows nepo is is about to sacrifice
another rook are you going to let him do
it
i feel like i i want to make this rule
in chess danny yeah that you have to
play it out to checkmate if you see it
there's also there used to be
times where people would announce mate
on the board right and this is this is
of course something that was like an
epic intellectual achievement to
announce that you've seen the mate
before your opponent doesn't happen in
modern chess but this is as close to uh
to again it's close to any game where it
might actually happen yawn knows it's
checkmate the engine has announced that
it is a forced mate
dingley ren knows that there's not many
ways to deal with the threat of queen h1
other than taking the pawn on g2 with
the king i actually think the
the longest way to avoid mate is like
moving the f pawn and running the king
out but there's no world where he would
do that i think he's likely to take on
g2 and the moment rook takes f2 is
played he will resign and shake yon's
hand how much you want to bet
well i don't know i had once victor
corchenoy in front of me and like i was
about to get mated so he looked at me
and he told me oh mira i think that you
know how
i think you know how this is going to go
this can go two ways the easy way or the
hard way whatever happened to cringy
lines in movies like that um
anyway i think jan could look at dingley
run and say
this could go two ways buddy
the easy way or the hard way
poor dingley ren and again we did talk
about this story line it's an
unfortunate one that will probably
continue
he's still not the same player that he
was pre-pandemic will he find his form
in madrid we don't know but yan
certainly seems to have it going early
and also ding arrived quite late
uh to madrid yes he only came like two
three days yeah that's right that's
right um and to me that is i was really
surprised when i saw that yeah because
he's also coming with a quite big time
difference yeah from china six hours so
um
yeah i
i feel like
it's easy to say after the fact right
right so i'm speaking with with a lot of
hindsight
but i i i feel like he if it was
possible he should have arrived in in
madrid earlier
and uh right now he's
yeah he's he knows that he's about to
get checked also he's traveling alone
you know it's it
might be a very important factor to
consider so uh
and you know he has a lot of pressure on
him too right he's the number one player
from china
um china's best chance at a world
champion
maybe ever
is
that those types of comments and hen
statements are resting on the shoulders
of dingley ren so starting off with a
loss especially when you have the white
pieces is not
now not how he wrote the story and his
travels to madrid so
of course we wish him the best
throughout the rest of the tournament
anyone looking at yonder pondishie uh as
a fan is is just super excited right now
about what
what this player is bringing
to the table and uh
of course there are three other games
still going so if you're just tuning in
we're gonna stay right here until the
final moments for sure uh we will
of course be diving into the other three
games in progress
all of them still with lots of chess
ahead but um
that's a sad that's a sad dingly run
right there
so looking at his opponent
i mean this is so this is obviously a
big result how surprised are you hammer
this is what we're looking at um i'm i'm
very surprised um and ding has been such
a a classy player such a solid player
yeah um
and for him to lose with the white
pieces is
rather rare and to lose with the white
pieces and one of the biggest games of
the year
i i can understand why he's just
so upset with himself right now
amira what's going through his head i'm
not so surprised because as you've well
if you've told our audience you know we
were doing uh well some research before
the tournament we were like uh trying to
establish the psychological profiles of
the players so i
well i underlined it like
before the tournament started you know i
i thought that uh it might be
a very
tough situation for ding you know so um
here we are from the very first round
yeah well he didn't handle the pressure
um the opening didn't go so well i think
ian played also yeah jan should get a
lot of credit yeah you know young played
so aggressively right and we saw this
moment where jan sacrificed a pawn in
the middle of the board
and and ding said no i i do not dare
capturing europon and that was the start
of the attack nepalnyochi now is
completing you you called it i mean
seriously full credit hammer at the time
you said you know this is a critical
moment
that dingley rent did not take the pawn
i was wrong about that critical moment i
anticipated that ding
would accept defeat but he's gonna
he's gonna let it play out a little
longer just green h1 queen a1 and queen
queen h1 queen e1 a1 and and maybe then
we see resigns i mean
we'll just show it real quick on the
board before young plays it but queen h1
king f2
queen takes a1 i'm threatening to get a
second queen in addition to queen f1
checkmate
so you have to take the pawn and then
bishop h3 is presumably okay so there's
a little bit of life that you take the
pawn and that does force you on to find
bishop h3 so that makes sense because
okay he'll find it but you have to see
that it takes queen h1 and if the king
moves just queen to f1
should be lights out here so okay so
makes sense that ding is going to make
yawn play the next few moves
now i'll say he'll probably play it out
until bishop h3 is on the board
right
i
i i don't know i think he'll resign when
when jan captures the rook
um
but yeah
devastating start for for ding but those
are the realities of competitive well
anything
that someone's got to win someone's got
to lose
and today jan nepam nichi the big winner
and and frankly he might not be the only
one
we still have three more games
going on
all of them with the potential of of
having a decisive result we will likely
see the finish here take a very quick
break before diving
full steam into the battle between the
two americans i see i see you chat i see
people yelling there is
there's a lot going on between carman
and nakamura and unfortunately for fans
of the most popular chess streamer on
the planet it doesn't look to be going
his way
at this time so
wow
has has day one delivered or what are we
having are we having a good time
well i i know someone who's not having a
good time right now danny but uh the
commentators and the neutral observers
have really got bang for their buck uh
so far
and uh i'm i'm surprised the uh yawn is
is uh oh no it's not jan's move of
course right
it's ding by the way we hear you chat we
see you yelling at us you know what
we're not going to go to break
take that we're going to stay right here
and go right to caruana nakamura as soon
as as soon as this particular game is
done we uh we hear you chat and we want
to we want to see what happened there
one how did karwena's position go from
better to winning and two what if
anything can nakamura do to hold that
other position you see you see all four
games in front of you right now
and uh again we want to stay right here
with dingley wren and yonda pam nishi
but we will be looking at and nakamura
in moments
and we had lots of move happen on the
board
uh the queen has come in and captured
the white rook in the left corner i said
bishop h3 would be resigned there you go
hammer i called it
i love playing guess the resignation
moment with hammer you know it's really
high level stuff
it's really important stuff
and also the big chess tradition of the
arbiter standing in front of the camera
when all we want to see is the middle of
the board and the handshake why can't
the arbiters go to the other side of the
clock like can we get a communication
am i being unfair on that are you with
me on that
well it depends like
if you're a player if you're a
commentator but then maybe for some
technical reasons he cannot go behind
you know
the uh
like the board
all right well we're going to head over
to the game that we kept saying again
congratulations to yonda pomnicci who
will likely be catching up with our own
dina bellankaya downstairs in just
moments but but we got to jump back to
this one
fabiano has found found a plan found his
form whatever it is or or what we kind
of predicted that hicaro's plan of
castling short was
was just too risky
uh well it could certainly look like
that um when we see the the eval bar
being massively in fabiano's
favor right now but frankly the
reasoning for that is not at all obvious
because hikaru is not even down a pawn
the the main problem in his position
right now uh is that his king is just so
vulnerable yeah uh with the white queen
having uh infiltrated in behind the
pawns and frankly well normally uh a
queen getting in behind uh the pawns is
is um
it's normally spells trouble
but here it wasn't actually that
difficult of a thing to accomplish
considering how aggressive hikaru had
been right uh with those said pawns when
it started here queen e5 was played well
i guess we should go back to where we
left it elmira we left on e4
bobby traded before playing c4 so that
that was indeed the the right line rook
e8
i guess that was the first move that the
computer really didn't like
we looked at at dtx4 understandably that
is a hard move to make to allow queen
takes e4 but but even this was maybe
good for i don't know what black was
supposed to do here no it's just it it
seems to me this whole situation
the other line because we didn't take on
the fate and oh that's right we allowed
to trade yes so it's actually a more
precise more precise language yeah we at
first look at that
yesterday
we had looked at this and then here and
this was much more stable for a car to
hold so elmira is pointing out that
fabiano improved on the analysis we had
by taking
and then playing c4
apparently hikaru maybe could have
played queen f6 as a as a means but i
don't know how you walk into the face of
rook f1 it feels very scary and also
what's kind of the point
i don't know so he plays rookie eight
captures on d5 and knight f1
this is but already this is one of those
positions where you look at without even
seeing what white's next move is it
doesn't matter right we're all nodding
our heads off camera you can't see us
this is just exactly what we're worried
about when you're talking about a
position where all the black spawns were
overextended white can play a number of
moves and be better forever
finds the way to get the queen behind
the pawns has put the lady on d6 and
where we currently stand
it's just this is going to be a very
hard position to hold
for the black pieces yes 93 is coming
93 knight g3
when this knight comes into f5 or h5 i
mean this is the problem is that
danger will robinson
yeah no it does seem like the black king
hi everyone i'm sorry but we're
experiencing some technical difficulties
here in the studio i hope you'll be
patient with us as we get things in
order before we return
hi everyone i'm sorry but we're
experiencing some technical difficulties
here in the studio i hope you'll be
patient with us as we get things in
order before we return back to the
broadcast this video will now play on
loop
hi everyone we're experiencing some
technical difficulties here in the
studio i hope you'll be patient with us
as we get things in order in order for
the broadcast to return this video will
now play on loop
hi everyone
we're experiencing some technical
difficulties here in the broadcast
i hope you'll be patient with us as we
work hard to get it back this video will
now play on loop
hi everyone we're experiencing some
technical difficulties here on the
broadcast
i hope that we can get things in order
soon this video will now play on loop
hi everyone
i'm sorry but we're experiencing some
technical difficulties on the broadcast
right now i hope you'll be patient with
us as we get things in order this video
will now play on loop
hi everyone we're experiencing some
technical difficulties here on the
broadcast
i hope you'll be patient with us as we
get things in order
this video will now play on loop
hi everyone
we're experiencing some technical
difficulties on the broadcast right now
i hope you'll stick with us and be
patient as we work to return this video
will now play on loop
hi everyone we're experiencing some
technical difficulties on the broadcast
right now
i hope you'll be patient with us as we
get things in order
this video will now play on loop
hi everyone
we're experiencing some technical
difficulties on the broadcast right now
i hope you'll be patient with us as we
work hard to get things in order this
video will now play on loop
hi everyone
we're experiencing some technical
difficulties on the broadcast right now
i hope you'll be patient with us as we
work hard to get this
back in order
this video will now play on loop
everyone
we're experiencing some technical
difficulties on the broadcast right now
i hope you'll be patient with us as we
work hard to get things in order
this video will now play on loop
hi everyone
we're experiencing some technical
difficulties on the broadcast right now
i hope you'll be patient with us as we
work to get things in order
this video will now play on luke
hi everyone
we're experiencing some technical
difficulties on the broadcast right now
i hope you'll be patient with us as we
work hard to get things in order this
video will now play on loop
how much longer does this have to go
guys
hi everyone
we're experiencing subjective
difficulties on the broadcast right now
i hope you'll be patient with us
as we get things in order this video
will now play on loop
hi everyone we're experiencing some tech
for you fans hicaro still hasn't moved
so in theory you didn't really miss
anything and all you got
was a special treat of content of our
special video for if the transmission
should ever go down so i hope you
enjoyed that fans
we are uh we're looking at a tough spot
for the five-time us champion right now
that's the reality hammer
yeah no hikaru's king is in a big
trouble
he's trying to figure out how he can
prevent the white knight from getting
involved
into
an attack
and frankly he's struggling to figure
that out which is why he's uh he's
taking his time
yeah it's tough you know especially
because if you're if you're in your your
own head as hikaru
at some point in this game you were
feeling very comfortable you know you
felt like you had parried the the
pressure
right against the uh maybe the most
well-prepared player in your generation
and faviona caruana
right you were feeling good as black and
now this has
this has definitely gone off the rails
yes certainly
so um hikaru here
uh he's also getting quite low on time
uh
he's down to
nine minutes uh on the clock and a
reminder the players are not getting
additional time per move they make so
it's very critical
that he stay
uh in this um
that he he starts moving quicker
is what i was saying and
it's difficult to move quickly when you
can't find a good move and and that's
the uh struggles uh hikaru is uh facing
right now he's spending all this time
searching for a good move but when the
reality is they're just there's no good
moves available and that has got his
faces going yeah
and and we can see he's very unhappy
about this current situation
as he should be and time is ticking he
has only eight minutes on the clock even
for a speed demon and blitz blitz bullet
legend like a car this is not a
situation you want to be in so
that said we know he's one of the most
resourceful players on the planet
perseveres uh
like no other in many ways so we'll see
what kind of tricks he has in store for
fabiano in his defense of this position
so
he looks like he was about to make his
move there
still not now back in the think tank
here we go nope yes
bishop to c6 was that it it backs up the
bishop
logical move to put the bishop on a
defended square where it continues to
defend the e4 pawn
yeah
but that also means it's a very expected
move for fabiano yep
so he's going to answer with his move
pretty quickly
he's going to get that knight in towards
the middle of the board headed further
up to that f5 square than he just
highlighted and if the knight is
successful in landing
on that square it's going to be game
over
so it's very important what hikaru does
now
and i guess he has to protect the square
i guess he has to go rook to f8
i'm not sure whether he can play rook f8
or whether he could get away with queen
to f8
i'm not sure we're we're seeing the live
position update here
again if there are any technical
difficulties right now we do apologize
icaru has moved on the board we don't
see it i believe he played queen to f8
yeah
he did he played queen to f8 so i'll go
ahead and move it
uh i i think it's hikaru to play
i i think the queen is still in front of
the king on the count do you think so
yeah okay am i wrong
i mean it would be the first time ever
danny that i was right wrong but
is that
being wrong for my wife okay i don't
need it um
okay
you're right okay he leaned in to move
and he and it didn't make a move i'm
sorry my apologies
looks like i uh the camera angle was
awkward i thought i saw a hikaro hand
move and then he didn't and uh
now he's now he's giving us
not a happy face hikaru is in a tough
spot he knows that will he resourcefully
find a way to make this this difficult
for caruana what what is the defense
here amir if anything
wow
this candidate's
tournament is delivering from day one it
really is gosh
if you just tuned in janna pomneshi
defeated dingley wren one of the
pre-tournament favorites with the black
pieces saying hey i know everybody
remembers to buy but let me remind you
that i am uh one of the most dangerous
players on the planet
fabiano caruana
now looks like he might join join
yon with a win in the first round
ricardo looking to make tactics
desperately g3 what an interesting move
by the way yeah no very interesting move
from hikaru he's trying to create just
um chaos
on the board and he's definitely
succeeding in doing just that
um i'm very tempted
uh with the white pieces now to go rook
f1
so i i
to be honest i i can't really see what a
hikaru is planning if i go with my
knight up the board which was the
previous intention but knowing hikaru i
know there's something yeah so i'm a bit
um let's show
um
yeah maybe yeah also that seems yeah
good yeah taking a free pawn would
normally be my number one choice i don't
know why i dismissed it yeah taking the
pawn seems okay
but i think you removed rook f1
just simple
threading knight f5 and i guess if takes
h2 you can even what put the key on h1
was my idea the umbrella defense where
you use your opponent's pawn against
them
here comes knight f5
and then my idea was that if black here
were to try and go uh rook f8
uh to try and well have more control
of that f5 square
um
i thought maybe just trading everything
might be good
like uh i was saying rook f8 here danny
uh and then i thought well
i have a knight a knight can jump and
attack both the light squares and the
dark squares
so i was thinking just make lots of
trades and win the end game
but oh no my queen
i can tell you're not an endgame
fan danny you you want to get it uh
decided i thought i thought i was
actually winning on take two two so
apparently i didn't go full eric rosen
white is still although it's kind of
awkward actually i guess you can check
here and then win the pawn so you give
up give up the night but anyway okay
funnily enough g3 has been played
caruana's still on the clock
well there's a lot of good moves so the
good news for fabiano is that he's
trying to decide between many options
that are all good for him
but on the other hand that's one of the
most difficult things in chess
when you have like three good options
yep how do you decide which one is
better they're all good
but which one is the best
first of all
maybe hikaru wants to sacrifice the jeep
on and then once again to use this e3
idea once you go and get five at some
point
what is what is the move on knight f5
i don't know i just know hikaru
takes and king h1 i'm just curious what
it is
but now i can always play e3 at some
point
so you move the queen to not g4 but okay
somewhere like this queen g5 i like this
and here comes each and then the three
next so okay
this is a very interesting uh defensive
resource if i if i might say
because
g3
then rook f1 probably is the the best
move in this position
uh in the current position
i mean uh when uh we started g3 rook f1
yeah what you what you proposed yeah
that's what i meant with the with the
current decision so yeah
fabiano taking his sweet time right now
uh but uh there's definitely uh
possibilities now uh for um
trying to get ahold of you guys for um
trying to create some some trickiness
but
yeah right now it's looking good for him
for hika for fabiano i mean
sorry fabiano does in fact choose to
just take the pawn he says okay hikaru
if you're just gonna give me a pawn i
can capture just like that i i am gonna
take it
and i'm gonna ask you why you're down
upon for for no good reason
so you see i think that's the
uh probably the safest move
we were we were discussing like how
how players actually make those
decisions so uh
i asked you well i asked why not h takes
g3 so
[Music]
yeah and now the queen coming into the
center hikaru desperately wants a trade
of queens right now and who can blame
him the the black king is
suffering and has been for a long time
and that's because of the potential of
an attack against it
and the white queen is the main
instigator of said attack so trying to
get rid of that would be a massive
accomplishment well at this point it
wouldn't make sense to trade queens when
your king is so open but probably he's
picking flavors at this point
unfortunately for hikaru yeah no i can't
see fabiano making the queen trade here
um
i i would guess he moves the queen and
then the question is uh what square
queen g6 or queen h6 or maybe queen g6
or queen h6 both look good
i mean at this point anything that keeps
the queen on the board and keeps the
option open of this night which by the
way now has a new option right
g4 not just f5 is available for carwana
so
it's a very unhappy hikaru
yeah so i i i guess maybe queen
h6 but queen h6 has the the disadvantage
of allowing queen takes g3 so fabiano
actually the more i think about this the
only um option fabiano has to avoid the
queen trade
is to also give up
that pawn on g3
uh so i feel like hikaru definitely
accomplished something right with this
uh
let's show why the idea is that if you
give check black will go back
and you could continue this game i guess
but hicaro's point is if you're going to
keep the queens on the board you have to
find a square
that isn't g6 you have to find a
different square which might give up g3
yeah
right
so that's that's an important point
actually we see hikaru
knowing that he's worse doing what he
does best which is
which is defend and be resourceful he
doesn't go away quietly into the night
and he's uh he's holding on
well queen to e5 has been played carwana
now using his advantage on the clock but
it's not as big of an advantage as as
you'd like
you'll be lower than hikaru in just a
moment so
got to make a decision quickly here we
are at move 34 which means both players
have six moves to make until they reach
time control where they are given extra
time on the clock
so in the drama that is the uh the
approach to time control it often feels
like the game is uh
is just moments away from ending but i i
would guess a result is not imminent
here i think that hikaru will probably
defend
and we will likely reach time control
and fabi will have to do some work to
convert this extra pawn and better end
game i was trying to calculate the
variation like queen h6 first then queen
g3
probably we are not meeting with knight
f5 queen one king age 12 something like
i just wanted to say
for sure but you're losing after king of
seven i think
runs yes king grants that's what i was
trying to calculate so this variation is
not possible that's actually really
tricky though right i mean yeah but it
looks almost looks like it's over
so uh queen g3 then and uh ah but the
knight is protected because i was uh yes
i overlooked this so maybe you can play
rook f1 here
yes then yes tonight is only three is
protected by the queen so after rook f1
uh
well knight to five is coming
you're basically just trying to find
moves to avoid trades
and the black king is not happy
so then yeah then it is possible so yeah
queen is six cringy three uh rook up one
then and now we'll have to find yet
another
key defensive move you can bring the
queen back to g7 and offer another queen
trade
maybe that's
the obvious idea
white can go back to d6 no well i would
try something like queen h5 or queen h4
because and then rook f4 and then g4
yeah actually that's a really strong
idea both moves rook f5 and rook g5 i
was only focused on the knight coming
into those squares but a rook lift
but if i play ah so maybe then queen h7
the rook is protected okay queen h7 and
you have to
find another square yeah just no matter
where white's queen goes the black queen
just follows suit trying to make trades
and and that's why fabiano is using so
much time right now he's trying to
figure out how he can uh get away from
that queen trade and frankly i would say
he's spending too much time because he
was up several minutes on the clock in a
winning position now he's actually down
on time and they still have
an additional six moves to make
before they get more time so right now
fabiano has to make six moves in uh
whatever time he has left
it shouldn't be a challenge for a player
of his level but you know he's still
thinking so even though it's three and a
half minutes now it might be one minute
by the time he makes this move
well likely what happens is they spit
they've equally spent some time and then
we're gonna see these last few moves
rattled off very very quickly but
definitely the position is critical he
knows it and he keeps the queen on the
board gaining a little bit of time on
the clock in a weird way not because of
income but just because you make one
more move and get close to time control
which is what do they say every russian
school boy repeats this is the this is
the uh
the phrase well this is a trick
yeah yeah
you just repeat get yourself one step
closer to that magical
40-move marker
so now he only needs to make an
additional four moves yep but this time
he needs to put his queen on a different
square yeah
so he made that back and forth making it
two moves or less until time control
very tricky guy yeah it's actually huge
i think again a lot of people forget
just the
importance of that practical practical
point which is with more time you can
make better moves so you don't have to
deliver the knockout now if you can find
a way to reach move 40 and not spoil it
yeah well especially while playing
without increments yeah
actually makes sense because
back in the days you know we were
playing with the
entire club back when we were playing
chess back in the day when we were when
we were playing chess in the times of
yours in the times of
your yeah the
it is an interesting storyline we're not
talking a lot about because for those
who may be just following the world
chess championship cycle now or in the
last match in dubai
increment has only recently been removed
and while there's a lot of arguments in
favor of that right for the games to be
more exciting for moments like this
where someone could really lose on time
there are some there are some naysayers
who are against that idea of removing
the increment it definitely can lead to
some lower quality moves potentially
with no time so but all right queen h6
creates some lower quality moves because
the players are bad at managing their
time well wow tell me how you really
feel well i i just spent two weeks in
stavanger norway for the norway chess
tournament there they also had this two
hours uh with no increment
concept and unlike kajabo for instance
he played there and he was so bad at
managing his own time and and many like
players who normally don't get into time
trouble also
uh were were just
bad at realizing that
you know
just make your moves a bit faster so um
i i think chess players are very prone
to just using all their time in the
moment
not really considering too much what's
gonna happen but can you blame them that
they grew up and they've played in these
tournaments with increment for more than
20 years so i understand what you're
saying and it's a good hot take but the
reality is when you develop a habit of
managing your clock in a certain way
knowing that there's an increment and
now there's no increment
right i mean that's fair right it's not
it's not like you can just flip a switch
and suddenly you're a different time
manager by the way rojava has less than
a minute we're focused on this game and
now we're focused on someone's butt
which is just fantastic
fantastic
we are uh
there we go
uh we uh the the reality is uh no
increment is leading to some
drama here rojava has less than a minute
against farouja as they peter out into a
rook ending
where rajabov is maybe a little better
okay we'll find out all right um
well i think it's going to be a draw
somehow i think
yeah this this particular game
well we just moved uh the board to uh
rajab of rajab is up a pawn with the
white pieces uh but it never now we're
back to hikaru now we're back to hikaru
who did grab that pawn so hikaru is not
down upon currently and that is also the
nicest thing you can say about his
position
uh his king is somewhat vulnerable
fabiano right now will bring his rook
into the attack
and uh yeah hikaru will uh try to get
those queens exchanged off
and we're not certain how fabiano is
going to avoid it but luckily he is
and he steps uh
two squares back
almirah predicted that this retreat was
better than going back to d6 correctly
so
uh queen h4 or queen h5 were both
possible
but and they both one of the main new
ideas is that that opens up this rook
lift which of course is a new problem
that black now has to face yeah but what
about queen e7 i mean hikaru doesn't
have a choice hikaru just needs to
continue
offering trades he does it in a
different fashion but the idea is the
same just trying to get those queens off
the board uh there's one more move uh
until we're at move 40. so when they
make their next move their the players
will be getting a lot of additional time
fabiano now safe over an hour on the
clock immediately takes off and hikaru
defense with his queen offering the
queen trade yet again which means this
time scramble is over
and we may be able to join uh some of
the other scrambles yeah hikaru reaches
time control
but doesn't get up from the board which
maybe said something right about how he
feels he knows that his work is not over
with despite getting more clock fabiano
on the other hand immediately took a
break
and uh we take a look
at the three games remaining
as we quickly showed
the raja buff faruga game
although
okay this one has not reached time
control yet so there is there's still a
little bit of drama here with both
players having about a minute yeah we'll
follow this until they reach time
control and uh then we'll uh
we'll take a break and then yeah
we're gonna make sure that every game
reaches time control before we take a
break don't you worry
don't you worry chad right now we've got
only a couple more moves to make here
yeah
um furuja is trying to defend he's just
making sure that he gets his king over
to that side of the board where rajab
had an extra pawn
and in doing so uh for russia has given
himself an end game uh down a pawn but
because there are so few pawns remaining
he should be able to to hold uh out for
a draw even so
indeed it's it's an awkward draw
a little bit right because it's not the
traditional sort of two on one you know
when when there's no pass pawn and and
you have a lot of thematic well-known
kind of defensive ideas there's there's
going to be some trickiness to this
right even at the highest level i think
that there are opportunities to go wrong
so for job offers he will still try yeah
he'll try and as an experienced player
who's won himself more than a drawn end
game or two because that's what brian
boitano would do
he's not going to just take a draw on
this game
for sure let's quickly check on the
other game to ensure that it has reached
time control before we
send this thing to a break
the uh
the only other game that is remaining i
guess of the three left karma nakamura
or jabba ferugia
is duda versus report but we have also
reached time control here it's funny
this end game actually looks
very similar to an endgame study
um that i was given by divoretsky of all
things um as you know diveretsky's
biggest disappointment here did you know
that was my hashtag divareski's biggest
disappointment no yeah that's my that's
my nickname that was my nickname in my
early 20s but okay uh jokes aside we are
uh
i think dude i heard my joke with that
little smile there
oh danny that's hilarious diversity's
biggest disappointment we're gonna we're
gonna take a break
and when we come back we will have still
so much ahead there are still three
games in progress uh much more action in
round one here likely at least one more
decisive result before we put this thing
in the books and we may have a special
interview with one of the players when
we return so don't go anywhere
chess.com's coverage of the 2022 feed a
candidates from madrid returns in a few
candidates is the most important
tournament in chess
taking place every two years the
candidates qualifies the victor to
challenge the reigning world champion in
a world chess championship title match
the 2022 candidates will feature eight
of the world's best chess players
they've all earned their spots through
two years of fierce competition they now
head to madrid spain where everything
will be settled over the board
one of those eight spots is always
reserved for the previous world chess
championship challenger
jan napomnishi would love nothing more
than a second chance at the throne but
he has to get through seven other great
players in madrid first
two spots went to the top finishers of
the most prestigious open chess
tournament in the world the feed a
chess.com grand swiss ali reza farouja
won the grand swiss turned the heads of
everyone in doing so and has become the
youngest player in history to cross the
2800 evo rating barrier he would become
the youngest world chess champion of all
time should he win the candidates and
ultimately the world chess championship
match
fabiano caruana joined him taking the
other spot from the grand swiss the u.s
number one and third highest rated
player in the history of our game is
also the only person to never lose a
classical chess game to magnus carlson
in a world chess championship match
two of the spots were claimed by the
winners of the dramatic 2022 fide grand
prix cycle
grand master hikaru nakamura is a former
world number two a blitz and bullet
chess legend and the most popular chess
streamer in the world
he was joined by gm richard rapport the
hungarian number one is one of the most
creative and dangerous minds in the game
today and nobody is looking forward to
facing him in madrid
fide awarded one of the eight spots to
the wild card invite grand master tamar
rajaba
raja missed the 2021 candidate cycle in
consideration of covet concerns but as
the oldest most experienced player in
the field he's looking to use that
knowledge and punch his ticket to the
world chess championship title match
[Music]
and finally
two spots go to the top two finishers of
the world's largest knockout tournament
the absolutely grueling feed a world cup
young christophe duda the polish number
one
punched his ticket by ousting none other
than world champion magnus carlson in
the semi-finals of that event
judah would ultimately defeat karjakin
in the final to win the world cup
however karjakin due to suspension from
play by fidei sees his spot go to
china's number one grand master dingley
rent
dingley rin takes the spot due to being
the highest rated eligible player
according to the may 2022 feed a rating
list
so that's how each of our eight
competitors earned their bids to madrid
inside the palace of santona it's about
who can sustain the mental endurance to
secure the coveted slot as challenger
for the world title
but we're not sure who that will be just
yet we do know this
we'll enjoy watching every minute of the
candidates with the chess.com community
as we see how the most important
tournament in chess plays out together
[Music]
madrid
civilization here is almost as old as
the game of chess
some claim the queen was given her
powers to honor queen isabella
that my friends is a chess legacy
passion for chess continues to thrive in
madrid
for the first time in 30 years spain's
capital plays host to the candidates
the most important tournament in chess
at the palace of santona the stakes are
high
eight of the world's best players
competing for the right to challenge for
the most coveted title in chess
the world chess championship
[Music]
the candidates is grueling
the winner requires mental endurance and
unbreakable focus
there are those familiar with the
biggest stages in chess
yet still chasing unfinished business
and others from the next wave of stars
with little patience for yielding to
those before them
miss amigos
the next challenger to the world
champion of chess must come through
madrid
like queen isabella before them the
candidates is all about leaving a legacy
[Music]
do
gamora is back in his chair
he knows he has his work cut out for him
defensively
he knows that uh
this is a big moment it's funny the
computer being very harsh on queen age
four
the reason is because queen h5 i think
was was much stronger
no it's just because it's a repetition
it's because
fabiano went back and forth ah okay no
but i think here originally queen h5 was
the reason
okay i think well i i think regardless
as long as fabiano just avoids the trade
uh he's doing so well because even
though he's not up a pawn or anything
it's just the
uh exposed black king
is is a massive issue for ikaru and and
notice how hikaru here despite being
able
to go queen age seven
offering the same position for a second
time he's actually thinking about it
because right now he he feels like well
i didn't really like the position i had
i don't want to give him another option
to go there
um but i have another option not really
and that's the coverage problem
there must be something else he's
thinking about or he wouldn't be paused
i mean
he knows he's in a tough spot
but i think it actually is important
that you don't always just repeat when
you're the when you're on the losing
side yeah no it's it's very instructive
from the car last time he had this
position
he had seconds on the clock
now he has uh a bit under an hour the
circumstances have changed completely
and he should take his time as he now is
is doing
there he is trying to hold hikaru
nakamura does not want to start his 2022
feed a candidate's bid with a loss he is
going to do everything he can to hold
this game
and you know hikaru and i
talked recently after one of his rapid
chess championship victories one of his
many rapid chess championship victories
he does it a lot um
and it was it was a tournament where he
started off on the wrong foot
and every round he got by me and i think
it was anna rudolph that day my
co-commentator were like
this is a bad sign you don't get many
chances to put someone away and
sometimes you have that experience where
tournaments where you started off on the
wrong foot can ultimately help you find
your form as long as things don't go
completely wrong right so of course he
still has much work to do here and
fabiano carwana is surely in the
driver's seat but it's only a plus two
advantage and hikaru holds bad positions
for breakfast he loves him nom nom nom
nom nom right and if he holds this game
you might ultimately be talking about
a a motivated hikaru and hikaru who
finds his form a little more quickly
because of the tough spot he was in in
game one elmira what do you think about
that well the thing is that this
position is a very technical one you
know i like if there would be a few more
pieces on like where the character of
the position would be completely
different there is plus two and plus two
you know that's a huge difference so i
think that uh
uh i think that here fabiano will
convert you know his advantage rather
confidently so
um
is he thinking about you know
i honestly cannot tell
uh i saw
in twitch chat uh some people were
shouting out for uh bishop to d7
uh which does have the advantage okay
that's interesting uh
preventing the the
white knight from coming to this f5
square and the geforce
it also prevents the rook lift because
you guard g4 yeah and you guard f5 right
so you can't go here to rook g5 and you
and if you could go to f4 i guess but
the point is that g4 is protected so but
but my concern is that this also opens
up options for white to choose a
different direction with the knot
for instance knight d5 maybe not right
away maybe not right away because if i
do go knight d5 here then the queen
comes in for a nasty check
attacking the king and knight
hilariously it's still only a draw
though because which kind of illustrates
how bad yeah all this stuff
is positioned
you can blunder uh uh a knight and and
still be able to save the game when you
can draw with queen g3 and queen h4 or
even maybe queen h2 that's
that shows you how open your opponent's
king is
yeah
so actually this bishop d7 was just oh
please played it okay
and now i would uh expect something like
rook d1
um and the point of this move is
quite simply to put some pressure
down the the open file yeah uh so uh
rook d1 pointing down towards that uh
black bishop
um but also preventing the black queen
from making this double attack we saw
earlier i like that uh and i'm
considering the plan of going knight to
d5 but i'm also considering almira's
plan
of work to d5
i mean
getting the rook into the attack would
be just as valuable as getting the
knight there so
black probably has to play bishop e6 ah
so you mean that the key is practically
forced to give up the pawn on f4
so bishop e6 has to be played but then
the bishop is blocking the rook
and i'm able to capture the pawn and
actually the computer kind of hated that
no but
the white's still better yeah sure
but i think it's also very instructive
the fact that the computer is not that
big of a fan
of actually managing to win this pawn on
yeah
because
if we go back one move i think that's
the best way to illustrate it here or
everything no sorry if you go in okay
back one because here the pawn on e4
is essentially blocking both black's
bishop and black's rook
so this pawn in many ways can be
considered a disadvantage like if hikaru
in this position
got the option of okay you have to make
a move or
you can remove one of your pieces
hikaru would choose to remove his pawn
on e4 i'm trying to take it off the
board the board won't let me
uh because then it opens up for the
bishop down towards the white queen and
it opens up for the rook against the
knight yeah it's fascinating sometimes a
pawn is your best friend
sometimes your opponent's pawn is your
best friend especially in the case of a
knight we know that not many pieces like
blockading but knights thrive in that
position and the computer is basically
telling us look i like white's position
not so much because i might win a pawn i
like white's position because of the
potential to attack the king and so
it makes even more sense why bishop d7
was a good move by hikaru because
these are the types of moves that that
he has built his reputation on
resourcefully finding only moves that
feel a little bit counter-intuitive
um i feel like in a recent hype video we
saw from the grand prix when he found
this move f5 as black you know he's this
is what he does he is not going to make
this easy just so all the fans know
almeira and hammer and i were talking at
the break we're like yeah all these
games look like they
might have been almost over at time
control i'm like no we're going to be
here for hours everybody buckle up i
guarantee you
at least one of these games takes us
takes us here for a long way
danny i was looking i still it's a very
direct knight of five because bishop f5
rook five i want to play rook g5 okay
your only move is probably rookie five
here no how can you
e6 rookie six yes rookie six is maybe
even a better option
okay so um
there must be something with here what
are we missing because like i
i it feels like i'm in some sort of like
philadelphia position queen and rook i
mean black's king is not having a good
time this entire game but what what is
it it's check and rook h5 rook h6 there
must be something here for white
oh now you go to g5 or you go to
d5 yes ruby favorite d7 is a nice idea
oh okay thank you
oh that felt so good
no but really how are you defending
yours no i think that's it okay so this
is a this is sort of an instructive
little because queen one rook d one
first yeah yeah let's show that at the
end of the line if queen to a1 you have
rook d1 with tempo that's what a battery
is queen and regard each other and now
no matter where the queen goes your next
move is rook to d7
with devastating effects
wow
okay so but you have to be very precise
in your calculations if you play not
knight f5 if you're not winning you're
spoiling all the advantage so uh and we
all know like how deeply fabiana
calculates
i think that he's considering this move
now so knight f5 bishop five rook f5
so uh
not rookie five uh well now that you've
kind of completely dismantled my move
uh i i guess a rook e5 should be
investigated but why was it dismantled i
actually liked rook g1 bishop b6 and
queen e4 i understand
okay let's go back to that line after
rookie five because i think that this
was really the defensive point that
we can just see that rookie six was
losing to that
shuffle idea so now let's go back to the
first suggestion of rook d1
even though the computer says your
advantage is not that big here
winning this pawn you know
it's always tempting winning a pawn yeah
um
it's funny if you could just put this
bishop on c6 black is winning
yeah just like if in one move you could
play bishop c6 you're sacrificing the
rook on e3 and bob's your uncle on g2
but you can't do that and bishop d7 i
believe probably just queen d5 check
you need the second board and the back
house chest you know and the best oh
yeah yeah exactly or even you just take
action probably just take the pawn yeah
okay
yeah no i mean
cars never gonna make it easy for you is
he no he's not i mean
it's it's hard there's no version of
commentating on these positions without
me having hikaru bias itis i commentate
on his games probably more than any
other player and you just see it happen
so often he's so resourceful
he perseveres
so well and i think it is it is because
of the reputation that kind of got him
to where he is he's an online
chess legend he's played maybe more
games than like anybody else in his
generation right if we count online
chess games and
he's just
he's aware of how many opportunities you
can have in a bad position and he keeps
us cool and
objectively this position should be
winning for white but
winning it will be will be another story
for sure
so um
should we take a look at this uh duda
game that we haven't really yeah we can
do that
we gave the the duda game a lot of
attention early on
in the first 10 moves and then as uh the
polish player kind of let his advantage
slip but i feel like
we started ignoring him this sort of
position that magnus would would love to
play like at the very beginning you know
when the end game started you know he
loves having two bishops you know and
gradually improving the position
so i have a feeling that
maybe he had more
no young sister it's funny it tells you
how strong magnus's reputation because
when you said this is a position magnus
would love to play i wasn't even sure
which side you were referring to i was
like magnus would win this position with
either side he has a pass c pawn if he's
black and he has the bishop pair if he's
white no actually like i think a little
bit like before they they traded drugs
i think um
it felt that white
had something white definitely had
something i mean not like not something
practical like we can go to that
position so you want to go to king d7
before the rooks were created i would
think
perhaps white shouldn't have played rook
a6
uh well i mean i i think just i i i
correct me if i'm wrong i'll mirror but
like around move 20 very early on
in this end game we still had that
situation
uh with uh black having that uh
inferior pawn structure uh was this when
you were referring to no no later on
because we like because
black
uh
tried to trade the dark square bishops
you know so but he played bishop buffet
first
here somewhere here
the advantage feels like it's already
slipped yeah i mean
report has sort of used his separate
pawns to his advantage and that he's
using the open squares and the open
lines
yeah rockport did a really yeah he did a
very good job coordinating
to kind of protect those pawns which
which isn't an accident for those
watching watching this type of high
level chess it's super instructive to
see that everything hammer was
highlighting about the weak pawns is
true they're isolated and not great but
black didn't make a decision to keep the
king over here
black made the decision to run the king
to the queen side knowing that the king
would be needed and very useful later on
and i think that type of foresight can
sometimes
take a much worse maybe losing position
into a holdable one so rapport gets a
lot of credit for how he coordinated his
defense
yeah i'm i'm really disappointed in in
duda but i'm i'm also uh
it must be said that rapport did a great
job of defending this computer wanted
king c6 instead of rook d8
but i'm not sure
exactly where
where duda missed his advantage then oh
right right here there was a huge
opportunity but there was a blunder
well engine is saying this is completely
winning for white which must come as a
bit of a shock to the players
uh at this stage uh pawn to a4
is
a really mysterious move to me
uh i think it has to be about uh the
pawn on a5
ah just fixing it yeah that that pawn
can no longer move forward but after
bishop d4 i mean what do you do after
bishop d4 like it's uh
just it's a very strange review it's
being suggested
[Music]
wow yeah no i
computers i guess maybe h4 and g4 is the
idea like knight b4 knight b7 now at
some point the knight has to move
uh
your point is you're creating an outside
pass pawn over here maybe
but i mean to me and this still looks
like a tricky position for both sides i
don't know why the eval bars is so
enthusiastic on on white's behalf but
yeah there was definitely and this was
also the stage of the game where they
just had no time right
uh and and that's pretty typical that
yeah these opportunities are often
missed it is obvious the advantage that
rapport has here versus here right i
mean so i think the optical no but the
the reason for why a duda did this is
because he won a pawn
he brings the rook back yeah retreating
the the rook
forced the king off the defense of the
side pawn
um
and and then he captured it it's
fascinating though because the cost came
at a very uncoordinated rook
because if you move the bishop i think
black has c4 and then bishop c5 is that
it
probably yeah so
just to show it for everyone the whole
point is if you move black has something
like this
maybe no
no he says actually just give up the
exchange and you've got no no no but
they think that's uh yeah a little bit
of a horizon effect suffering from the
computer right now well it was bishop
takes c4 daddy
bishop's ah i missed that
you take and then you have an error yeah
in between the computer is just so nasty
with it it's funny every time i think
the evil bar is wrong i realize i'm just
going too fast and not appreciating that
there is a better move i didn't find
yes but still daniel look at this
position because your rook on b3 is very
awkward so
uh maybe you were right so just go
bishop e1 here and then so you're saying
yes bishop should have done this well
look at the rook at b3 so what's like
i'm not sure how to continue
but i just realized because your bishop
well bishop b2 is threatening yeah so
you just like make a move yes make him
something well maybe not that move danny
well maybe
i was not sure yeah that'll be eight
yeah i apologize so
okay
so okay king c7 instead just make a move
oh
perfect
but i'm only finding it because you
pointed it out that
basically i don't play c4 because i
don't have to play c4 the rook can never
leave the b file without b2 hanging you
can't play a4 there are no squares on
the b file hence the reason why my for
those maybe we're going too fast forward
that's why i hammer that's why hammer
scolded my rook a7 move because it would
have allowed rook b8 and also after king
c7 you can play c4 bishop c5 but there's
bishop c4 is no doesn't work ah yeah so
after after king c7 black is actually
threatening the earlier idea
that i was showing with c4
okay so
what a tough position this was no it was
certainly tricky the players were in a
huge time scramble so i guess if we
learned anything from what we just
analyzed there to get you all caught up
with the live position it's that it was
incredibly complicated but really if
you're applauding one player's efforts i
think from the beginning you have to be
looking at rapport's spot what he was
able to do in regards to coordinating a
proper defense
and just be impressed with what he did
because he gives up the a pawn
and now now duda had to trade the rooks
right there was no other way to hold on
uh moving the bishop wouldn't have been
an advantage in fact maybe moving the
bishop loses the rook to king c7 and c4
so instead he trades rooks which gives
back the pawn
and we head to an end game
of uh
of relative equality as they say like i
said a position you know it's an equal
position when you say it's a position
magnus would win with either color
yeah no i mean white is is definitely
still for preference but the bishop on
a6 i think is the key piece to note here
uh because that bishop is unable to get
back into the game
the knight on d6 is perfectly
protecting all the squares white's
bishop uh wants to use
uh and so
the only real way uh for duda
uh to kind of
release his bishop from the edge of the
board uh would probably be
to
go capture opposite code bishop ending
yeah but then then that's going to be a
draw well first you need to play bishop
g5 yeah you need to protect the bomb
hammer's hammer's point for those who
don't speak fluent opposite code bishop
ending is that
if an obstacle bishop ending occurs even
if you win this pawn which you might not
by the way like maybe you don't even win
it but just to prove the point if you
take and win this pawn
so many of these end games are just
impossible to win because when your
opponent sets up a blockade on the
opposite color square of your bishop you
have no real means of breaking that
blockade and so we see
uh many end games despite someone having
a one or even sometimes two pawn
advantage and in a rare case even more
pawns uh you're unable to win so so
that's kind of what hammer's saying is
that if you look at the live position
the knight has some octopus arms and
closing that bishop on a6 and probably
the only way out is to essentially offer
a draw by going to an obstacle bishop
position
but
yes here comes the butt yes
uh
so now well bishop g5 has to be played
okay to defend the pawn
uh and there is this idea uh of uh king
to d1
uh so bishop g5 was just played by uh
king do you wonder who should be seven
first
uh well king d1 i thought okay
um and basically you're just trying to
bring your king in to capture the pawn
on c4 so i'm going to work my king up
through the c2 square then the c3 square
and then try and capture that
black pawn on c4 and it would be a big
difference because if you take there
it's the same color bishop ending which
is very different than the obscure
bishop ending white will have real
winning chances there because there's no
real no real auto blockade as they as
they say right
what's going through judah's head at
this time he knows he had a great
position out of the opening maybe
squandered some good prep who knows time
will tell
but now he's got to buckle down and try
to win this thing for a second time
elmira what's the right mindset there
well you could also look at the
situation differently uh
richard had the very like bad position
he is almost on the verge of making a
draw and
he could release you know the tension so
probably this is the moment or where do
this still has to well
to find the plan like i like very much
king d1 because like uh richard could
say okay it's a draw you know easy
defense no there's still well a few
problems down the road so king d1 king
c2
and you
black has to find a few precise moves in
order to make this draw yeah not simple
i actually like this kingdom one kicks
you two kings but okay if i uh start
attacking your bishop so king d7 king d1
king d7
let's try it
king d1 and king
no i'm not like we're just trying to
because otherwise uh
what else do we have and king d7
so bishop a5
back to the simply otherwise i would
play king c6 and now king c2
i like this
note that there's more than one way to
undermine the knight too i mean not that
the bishop to d8 forcing the bishop
there and going to e7
you could always go here if you needed
to like if somehow king c3 was met with
king c5 my point is you could you could
check it back
you need to keep the bishop on a three
so when you play king c3 i have to give
bishop d4 check
you see like when you play king c3 my
bishop has to check you
so probably at some moment i have to go
bishop b3 back
yeah how about this moment
yeah
ah
but now bishop did it yes because and
then bishop j now king c3 it's like a
triangulation sort of yeah yeah exactly
losing a tempo to gain a tempo
that that's quite tricky yeah i'm very
glad i came up with that yeah
so that means actually what varetsky
says well you if you cannot defend
passively you should always look like
well for an active defense sort of you
should
hold your position in an active way so
what what else do we have we have f5
there i think
not bishop e3 but or something
i'm looking
while your bishop is still on a6 we we
should uh this makes sense do something
very concrete but i'm not sure this is
such a good move either so i i think
also what you can do
uh is instead of moving the king back to
c6
um you can just go well here bishop b3
maybe
anything
i can go bishop h6 i'll just do anything
i'll let you get the king to c3
uh well maybe not all the way to c3 i'll
all go
bishop e3 here you should be so that
when you go
king c3 i can go bishop d4 check
and then when the king goes before i was
going to go
bishop f2 i'm afraid i think c3 can be
three and then yeah the paulette is
corralled
i i was going to go bishop f2
i'll wear
um instead of c3
um
but um there may have been some
trickiness i i missed
i don't know if you can do that danny
when um instead of c3
uh bishop f2 was trying to be tricky so
um say that again here
he wants to give bishop b one check like
at the position that we were analyzing
king d1
king d7
let's say bishop b5
king c2
well bishop h6
bishop
king c2 bishop e3
uh
king c3
and my idea was to go bishop d4 check
here
and then when the king steps up i was
going to go bishop f2 with the intention
of going bishop e1 and pointing out that
the the a5 bishop was kind of awkwardly
placed uh because when we give a check
we can capture the bishop
afterwards uh however
uh apparently this was not uh
as clever
as i had originally thought
why not actually like how do we defend
i'm not entirely sure but the computer
was not happy
so yeah
i think the the re the point uh to to
stay with is that uh it's still a tricky
position
uh there are ways for white to improve
their position there are
probably not ways for black to improve
their position which means white has uh
the pressure to to keep
improving
and then trying to figure out what
happens that's what i wanted to say like
there's still some venom in this
position and like richie has to be very
careful
uh you know just
well not saying phew you know it's done
it's a draw
because
it's not an easy draw for the moment
i like the point though about the fact
that white holds all the cards white can
can play tickle as long as you want
right and and uh magnus would do that
right just sort of
find every way possible
to uh to bounce around the position
don't make it so easy for your opponent
to defend but
all right well
yes because that's that was exactly the
point in well if you come back to the
game between timur ajaba and ali reza
furuja because um
he doesn't like defending those
positions you know technical draws you
know so he's upon down but it's it's a
draw probably but then you still need to
make it yeah it's just because it is a
draw doesn't mean you will hold the draw
right and we're going to see of course
if rapport can hold this position
against judah but while we wait to find
out the answer to that as well as the
other two games that are are still going
our own dina bell and kaya caught up
with yonda palmashi who thus far
has had not just the biggest win of the
day the biggest win of the tournament
let's see what the victor yonda palmishi
had to say with dina
and we are back
with yanni pomnishi who has just beat
dean loren in the round one of video
candidates 2022. yan first of all
congratulations thanks
you just beat the highest rated opponent
in the tournament with black
isn't there a better start to a
tournament
no i mean i win is always a win but i
guess it was quite smooth and uh overall
i didn't analyze but i'm quite pleased
with the game but i think that you know
highest rated to lowest rated i mean
everyone is pretty strong player here so
that's not such a big difference just
great that i managed to score
coming from russia i bet you're enjoying
madrid's weather yeah a lot a lot
finally finally some warm weather
weather
you must have played in many museums
before is this palace up to your
standards
well i'm not going to live here so i'm
not going to transfer
are you unfortunate that you're not
going to live here well i think here is
also a court so that's maybe not such a
good idea to live here
fair enough
just out of curiosity do you have some
new members in your team for these
candidates
i won't tell you
and now we are now we are back
again
as due to
due to fiddles the piece right
a lot of players do that when uh when
they're looking for something to do with
their hands they fiddle the piece
how's that for an observation
yeah
um they don't have to care
they don't have long hair so although
some of the players do fiddle their hair
i've seen i've seen more than a few
people pull their own hair out
while playing so yeah hamburg what were
you going to say
well i was i was going to talk about
some chess never mind
you know what are you doing what do you
think this is uh i don't know what
you're talking about harry have you
noticed that uh nipple reloaded has a
different hairstyle as well you know
like i did i think after the match you
know he was looking like um
a samurai for quite a while yeah that's
oh that's true yeah but he cut it
during the match well yes but now he
kept it that way so yeah okay no that
that's a good observation
well um
judah is
as i as i said i think that often what
happens is we have a we have a big time
scramble right around mu 40.
i think some point here we have to get
back to karwana nakamura because the
longer fabi thinks although okay he
actually did he just played
he just played rook d1 so we have that
um
i was about to say the longer fob he
thinks the more i feel like maybe hikaru
is putting up putting up some problems
but
karwana did eventually play rook d1 as
originally suggested by our own
young ludwig hammer here
yeah and honestly i'm surprised hikaru
hasn't moved yet
because as far as i'm concerned that
threat of moving the rook up to d5
which would let the rook
get into a very dangerous attacking
position i feel like that has to be
stopped
and and that he hikaru here should play
the move uh bishop e6
knight d5 is also a threat it is almost
as devastating as rook d5 but okay i
agree go ahead no no i i thought that uh
he could still uh parry this threat by
after rook d5 i think that i still have
rookie five and then if you take rookie
fight queen five queen g8 queen eight
what what are you doing in the meantime
yes but i have to make a move yeah yeah
exactly
because because otherwise you don't
actually have rookie five right because
of queen to d8 check exactly and the
bishop is hanging so
um
it's very difficult to so i cannot play
bishop c6 because of knight f5
that's another problem so um
that this is now we're coming around to
why hammer is surprised bishop c8 i
think it's just knight d5 ah knight g5
yes we considered this
before
i think bishop e6 is a is a is a very
hard move
you think
well he hasn't played it yet so i
i'm i'm thinking he's not thrilled about
having to give up the pawn
yeah
yeah true
fair enough
well i don't like giving away full time
i love the disdain in your voice well
the thing is getting checkmated is worse
than losing once we finally agree yeah
but
but my point is i mean it's it's a big
decision to make right you're changing
your whole defensive setup to give up
the pawn but hikaru yeah he played it he
does indeed make that decision
and we have bishop e6 on the board and
uh
hikaru gets up to take a quick break
he's up on the clock
which again is no longer the dramatic
storyline it was as the players neared
move 40 but uh but it is it is not a
notable difference here 14 minutes yeah
but actually getting an additional one
hour after 40 moves is quite rare
like the these championship tournaments
are one of few places where you get that
much additional time so the players will
be used to having to kind of stress even
after making move 40
but here they got all the time in the
world and it's kind of it can be
difficult at times to kind of find the
right pace yes because we
normally we're used to a different kind
of scenario you
barely make it to the move 40 then you
run to the bathroom
then you have a half an hour yes half
you have half an hour left then you have
to be very precise while you make your
move 41 so basically you spend like 15
to 20 minutes and you were in time
trouble once again so this is although
in that time control again most of the
time we have increment so it's a
different it it is interesting and i
know i apologize to those who
have never maybe played over-the-board
chess or don't quite follow the language
here this this is a very interesting
storyline because most of this
generation grew up playing the type of
time control elmira was just describing
where yes move 40 adds time but it's
usually less the trade-off is you have
30 seconds added to your clock every
move that's the increment we keep
referring to
and so you will see games one by guys
like rishik who you mentioned getting
down to literally one or two seconds
making them move calmly getting 30
seconds rinse and repeat that as they
play a position right it's it's a very
different feel right here we here we see
time pressure is is very real in this
sense because you are not getting saved
by that increment so you have to manage
your clock as hammer said many of them
maybe don't manage it well without
increment right hammer and that's kind
of what we see
so um
it's
having this extra time is well is almost
a luxury you know yeah
well speaking of
luxuries we all have a little more more
time here for a second i think we should
back up when we have a chance remind
everybody that there are still three
games going
um you can take a look at the boards
we'll give the macro
description of it you've got for ruja
in a position where he should be drawing
but i think rojava is going to make him
work he has an extra pawn we have duda
sort of playing for two results it's not
without some risk but for the most part
white is in control with the bishop pair
and then we have the game we're looking
at right now where
apparently
apparently uh we we have a a computer
that has changed its mind i think maybe
we will go right back to caruana
nakamura i apologize because with some
time to think
and that is one thing we should remember
that
the computers are accurate
instantly especially on blunder checks
often pointing out the mistakes as
humans miss but with time they can also
come up with really deep ideas that
we're not necessarily seeing and the
computer has suddenly said in this car
wanna game
that knight to d5
which doesn't actually surprise us
because it's the idea we talked about
yes but compared to the other line that
we analyzed we had the rooks on the f
file so it's even stronger it's even
stronger so the computer has suddenly
said
that knight d5
so if you're taking which is
specifically the move hikaru was trying
to present with his latest bishop uh so
now uh
rookie five probably doesn't work
because i think please check and check
right just so rook d8 rook d7 wins the
queen
which means you can't take it and so the
computer is saying hikaru has to oh my
gosh you have to play this and then run
the king to f7 is the only way to keep
the game going
that's rough oh
wow but uh
you know it feels like something hikaru
would do it looks exactly like something
hikaru nakamura would do and in fact
this is not the the winning way for
for fabiano yeah 97 check is not the one
i was just sort of highlighting
the key point to the line the computer
says only now you take
which is uh
not obvious
but i i guess the point is here that
this time when the queen captures the
pawn in the center you're also having an
attack on the bishop which you didn't
have previously yeah uh when the rook
was defending the bishop but also when
you take a pawn then you can transpose
to transpose to an end game so okay okay
i'll trade queens eventually and i will
play
with an extra prong
is this a winning ending if the queens
and knight came off the board
yes yes no no but i mean i want to keep
my knight as well so i was like ah okay
but it would be a winning rook ending
hammer yeah i'm asking for a friend i
obviously knew the answer i was asking
for a friend
i'm
pretty certain
i was gonna say you said that
so confidently well that's the trick to
commentary danny let me teach you
something
you are teaching me more than a thing or
two i'm just gonna get the end game and
see if the computer agrees with you
you're just saying this is just an easy
win i mean i didn't ask you whether
magnus would win it i asked you whether
it was a win yeah no i it should be an
easy win yeah
okay by the way
carwana has found the move knight to d5
and interesting it took it took us we
didn't really find it all ourselves it
took the engine thinking on the position
which is one of the advantages of us
staying on the game the engine after
thinking for five minutes showed us this
95 move and fabiano says
i got your engine right here buddy in my
head when he carries about to do his
king walk
he was ready to make his move
immediately it seems like he expected
this knight d5 move and he's about to go
right now rook f8 just right away
wow
not only does fabi find it but hikaru is
ready for it potentially
this
oh yeah he's going after the rook
there's no
doubt about it
um we gotta zoom in on the uh the hand
gestures by the way that's another us
championship ring on the other hand he's
got more than a few of those
how many rings does he have he has five
in total
when did they start so every time every
time yes every time you win oh i'm sorry
i took the question
non-literally because he has five u.s
championships so i actually don't know
how many rings he has i know he has two
okay but maybe there's more
i don't know
because like when you're winning the
french championship we have a different
tradition we're getting
uh a porcelain base from um
a factory which was produced in
porcelain for the kings and now is
supplying uh the president
so that's a different tradition that's
funny in norway we get a silver trophy
called the king's trophy oh
yeah from winning the norwegian chess
championship norwegian chess
championship
i've never won a chess championship so i
don't have anything to compare it to
it's okay danny we'll tell you how thank
you thank you i keep trying to invent
tournaments on chess.com that i might
have a chance to win and i keep failing
in the process but okay we're not going
to talk about that did you get knocked
out of the
white i said we're not talking about
that okay we don't talk about bruno um
we do talk about hikaru
he is uh
getting prepared but i'm not sure he's
playing rook i mean the way the hand
keeps kind of nearly swiping i feel like
he's about to move the queen but that
wouldn't make any sense because knight
f6 check so
so indeed i think it probably is the
rook
um
indeed by the way you note that he
played rook f8 and gave a little bit of
a gary kasparov sort of screw in did you
notice that
the legendary gary kasparov no but you
only do that when you're winning no you
only do it when you're confident in the
move i think okay
and so i think he was confident it
happened almost immediately so uh
i don't know how do you
defend this position
yeah and and what's rough is that
fabiano he just took that pawn in the
middle of the board right away there was
no hesitation whatsoever
and hikaru still has that problem of his
king having absolutely no defenders
uh in front of it
uh and i think he'll probably be
interested in making a queen trade i
think i think he has no choice right the
question is will father be interested
and i have a i have a feeling favi will
not be interested in such a fair uh
amira your your thoughts on i mean just
from the psychological perspective that
keeping the queens on the board longer
makes it harder right i mean just move
the queen anywhere it's not easy for
black to defend of course no but i was
more thinking about queen g4 in that
position i think that jan ludwig
suggested this no or
it was not your it was uh
my it was slightly implied
not taking on g5 but to
uh offer trade on g4 so to keep the
bishop on the board
just here like here i see that okay now
this
i'm not sure this solves black's problem
this is this is a much better approach
than i was taking with bishop d5 so um
so the rook is hanging first of all you
if you want to avoid
this
trait you need to
do something different
so uh this uh trade of queens would
leave hikaru in a difficult position
down a pawn but it would be savable the
the black king would feel so much more
comfortable if the queens were to be
exchanged off and i think this is the
reason why the uh engines were kind of
figuring out as they were thinking that
the position was actually
much better for fabiano than they had
originally anticipated because the
engines after a while
made the realization
that
we don't have to trade the queens we
don't have to take
on g4 and and if queen g4 here
one of the options where you both save
your own queen and keep the the white
rook defended is by just moving that
queen all the way back
to to d to e1 how queen you want why
queen e1 instead of queen d3 i have no
idea oh
i highlighted this one and i feel like
you purposely chose a square that i
didn't highlight no i i'm it's because
the engines were saying queen uh okay
well so either way it
keeping the queens on the board is the
essential essential message yes that um
queen you wine is actually uh i think
maybe the difference is now that i uh i
think about the position you also have
this lift rook g3 rook g3 oh okay
those ideas once again so and you can
also take with uh your rook on d5
it makes it makes a lot of sense
obviously the longer fabiano keeps the
queens on the board the longer hikaru's
defensive job will continue but
hikaru as we know has a huge community
on twitch and youtube but many were
surprised when he qualified for the
candidates
let's take a closer look at how hikaru
got to madrid
in qualifying for the candidates hikaru
nakamura ratcheted up the level of
interest in what is already considered
the most important tournament in chess
with millions of followers as a popular
content creator hikaru brings along his
sizable community while also attracting
more casual chess fans
although once ranked number two in the
world most believed nakamura's best days
competing in classical chess were behind
him
that changed when this japanese american
grand master leaned on his exceptional
calculating ability to win the fide
grand prix
the unexpected victory earned him a bid
into the candidates for the first time
in six years
a five-time us champion hikaru has
stayed sharp of late by dominating in
speed chess formats nakamura is
currently ranked by fide in the top two
in both rapid and blitz
a chess giant on twitch and youtube
ikaru brings a special buzz to a
tournament that already holds the keys
to becoming the next world champion
and there are certainly those who have
yet to rule out hikaru from catching
lightning in a bottle here in madrid
[Music]
well wow wow i think jonya's breakdown
first of all huge shout out to donya was
uh very very well done and as he said
five-time u.s champion a four-time
gibraltar winner which is super
impressive by the way when you consider
that that's an open tournament it's not
easy to win events like that as
consistently as he's done
uh amir he's a gold medal winner he wins
online chess like nobody's business your
thoughts on hikaru nakamura and just how
surprising and amazing it is for him to
be competing in the candidates well
first of all i think that uh
as a professional chess player i am so i
have so much admiration for uh for his
career because he's stopped playing
classical chess
and uh dedicated his life to streaming
and i like always thought that um
professional chess players have
this kind of
um
dilemma you know
should i compete or should i diversify
and should i like
devote myself to streaming completely i
think
hikaru is legitimate everywhere
so he he has won it all and he i think
has done more for the game than anyone
else and then
comes back
wins the grand prix and qualifies for
the candidates
for me it's an absolute miracle but also
i think uh
this also gave him also the necessary
perspective maybe to play this
tournament in a different manner
and i had uh well a completely different
thought on of matter because
i had the feeling through the interviews
that hikaru
felt like he was always misunderstood
and this community like is giving him
this absolutely unconditional love you
know so he's coming back even stronger
and we're when we are talking about
millions people like millions watching
chess like those millions are literally
watching hikaru yeah so
this is uh this is something which uh
which is so powerful and when i'm
reading those interviews he's saying
like i just i want to give back
i want to do it more
this is something which touches me a lot
yeah
wow well said i
i don't know i don't know how to how to
add to that i think you said it super
well and and he has done so much for the
game and
and hey karu
well now chad is pointing out that for
all that he's done here carl right now
i'm looking stressed which is probably
true and let me let me move on from
almira's great comments about her car to
you hammer and
kind of build on what donya said at the
end of that video can he karo catch
lightning in a bottle i know you said
fabi's the favorite and obviously right
now this looks like a very tough
position but
if we were doing that content maybe
before round one and just as we talk
about hikaru's chances what chances you
give him to catch lightning at a bottle
here in madrid
um well they're gonna decrease uh if he
doesn't save this one uh but i would say
uh the player i think
is going to win the event is fabiano the
player i want to win the event is
nakamura yeah uh which is um partially
egotistical in that i think magnus would
never
skip a potential world championships
against hikaru that those two have had a
rivalry since they were in their teens
yeah and um magnus uh would very much
like to settle the score right and kind
of prove uh unequivocally that he is
the superior player
um
and but
that being said also like he conor has
some mad skills
i don't think anyone can deny that the
way he's just rushing through these uh
rapid championship tournaments on
chess.com every weekend yeah it's
incredible like the consistency with
which he wins against like
tons of top level players
is is just yeah it's unmatched well and
and i think the storyline on hikaru was
that okay he was doing that online
for the last year during covenant with
streaming but okay he's not doing it
over the board and then he goes and wins
the grand prix and gets himself to
madrid as elmira said i think you made a
really great point which is that you
could argue hikaru is playing his most
comfortable
confident chess in his entire career
precisely because of the community that
he's built and the community that has
showed him that love right that he he
feels at home when he's streaming and
the confidence and the love that he has
for chess uh is is showing on the board
and of course we're saying that well we
know hikaru is in is in a very tough
position here but um
you know i don't think you're alone i
think a lot of people would say
something very similar that i think
fabiano is going to win if i had my way
i would love hiccaro to win this event
because the nakamura carlson world
championship would surely turn heads and
as we have there from chat
we have onion leaves says spam this
flower to give hikaru power spam this
flower to give hikaru power the flower
power is real if you are a subscriber to
hikaru nakamura's twitch channel you
know exactly uh what onion onion leaves
is uh referring to there so
send hikaru your power if you're if
you're a fan of nakamura hoping he holds
this obviously he's facing off against
his american rival caruana who
will likely get the job done that eval
has just gone even
farther up at plus eight with this very
subtle but powerful rookie one yeah
really really good move here from from
fabiano not fearing the exchange of his
powerful knight because he knows that
even if his knight is captured he will
be able uh then uh to
to attack
the black king more easily he's saying
that even if a trade here happens then
black loses the very important defensive
bishop
which may actually be just as or even
more important than the uh aggressive
qualities of the knight yeah
let's show the main line that probably
occurs and something like bishop takes
queen takes
i guess the king moves and is it is it a
rook lift or is or is white just
i mean even taking the plan i guess
that's
that's really bad news unfortunately for
hikaru if that's if that's the kind of
move that white can get away with yeah
it is now becoming a matter of technique
as they say
yeah
so um yeah just
very
it's been a
it's been a kind of strange game
uh because as you said
um danny from the opening it did feel
like hikaru
was doing very well if anything maybe
even got the better of it yeah
but
ever since hikaru chose to castle his
king in the area where he had no pawns
protecting it
uh it has gone really downhill since and
like the reason is always the same it's
always about the safety of the black
king and honestly we said this already
when hikaru pushed that g pawn very
aggressively we were like well
sure you're kicking back white's bishop
but you're also now um creating
long-term uh trouble for your own king
and at the end that's
that's
what
it's gonna take to to bring down hikaru
today yeah
i'm trying to find the schwindel trying
to find a swindle for black
elmira you're very quiet over there what
are you looking for that's that's not
easy because there are a lot of
variations to calculate even like a
simple move implies
that there are a lot of checks and so um
i'm trying to find the tactical idea
well i i guess hikaru needs to go
um
i was going to say bishop d7
well i was looking at this move but i'm
just now realizing that this might
blunder the bishop
um
he currently needs to move his bishop
the bishop is under attack it needs to
move but the problem is despite having
like eight different squares it can move
to
none of the squares are are safe
yeah we can highlight just why
h3 pawn g4 queen f5 there's 97 check
bishop bishop to c8 is safe
uh actually maybe only temporarily so if
there's a trick and then queen g4 check
can take the yeah
ah okay i'm gonna show it real quick so
the point is after check
the the king goes to h8 you run into
knight g6 yeah and if the king goes to
g7 you take on c8 and then as almira
pointed out queen g4
finishes the job
bishop to d7
immediately runs into
what actually knight e7 queen d4
97 but king of seven right or well then
rook the f1
rook f1 and then
king h8 knight g6 no wait but
king g7
then queen d4 play queen f6 you cannot
take your division
if i'm not losing immediately i am so
sorry he will play uh bishop d7 then
okay so this this is likely his only
move then surprisingly
again just to show that bishop d7 97
check king g7 elmira saves the day with
queen f6 because of queen f2 check and
well in fact it's now white who gets
checkmated over here on the h file so um
okay so no he did not play this
he is uh still on the clock
likely gonna play bishop d7
for those of you who are just tuning in
we've had one decisive result here in
round one of the 2022 feta candidates
yonda pomnesi shocks at least some uh by
beating dingley ren with the black
pieces
and of course the other two games
besides car 1 and nakamura are still
going you can see them here the reason
we're not focused on them is not just
because most of you want to see caraway
hecarim but because the truth is
neither of those games has a lot to it
right now right uh the question
will be maybe an hour or more from now
on whether or not faruga holds that
engine because rajab is not going to
make it easy he's going to keep pushing
and duda is yet to do anything but play
tickle over there with richard rapport
because uh
at some point he will make a plan i
assume to go for the win but he's not
showing anything clear yet but i think
that actually uh he brought his king to
c3
and uh well well in uh
do the report yeah we'll come back to
that
no that was a good point yeah the king
he's making progress is your point um
this is this is a surprising move
i mean that's ice cold uh not protecting
your bishop because then you can do a
counter attack
on the white knight instead the question
then becomes what if the knight moves
and for instance were to give a check
on that black king as you said i love
the term cold-blooded because that's the
kind of move hikaru hikaru goes for
moves like this on a regular basis and
now i was thinking the move knight to f5
but then maybe
yeah no queen of six f6 f1 probably
oh my gosh that's just harsh
thank you
so that that looks kind of
finished
so i i think this is where fabiano is
going to go
he seems poised
we
talk a lot about hikaru nakamura's body
language or at least i do he's a very
emotive player one of the things that's
so entertaining about his streams but
that's a fobby and it's that slight tilt
of favi yeah that's a fobby on the prowl
but on the other hand knight of five
then bishop well maybe i can take
well queen is seven ah queen of seven
sorry is queen of fighters
well it's one option uh the moves are
coming in quickly now yeah i believe
this is going to be decided within the
next
uh three four minutes uh all fabiana has
to do is retreat his knight to f5
i do not see
how hikaru is gonna deal with all these
threats i do believe he's going to
resign the game now
maybe queen g6 here
or like rook f1 still
yeah okay i was wrong
he will not resign now
but he he's agonizing
because this is
it's not a nice position to be in for
hikaru
[Music]
ah but um is queen b7 you know the
hidden threat
yeah like in some variations well of
course
he's going to
okay karu does play queen f6 the
question is will rook f1
will rook if one be
the resignation right unfortunately i
think it's it's getting to that point
well
fabiano is definitely playing his move
very quickly yeah he's feeling confident
but he car
resigning isn't really what he does is
it
but
the problem is like rook f1 now if king
g8
uh do you mind doing the moose damie
uh so rook f1
if the king tries to escape from being
on that same file as the black queen and
the
white rook you can't try to go king g8
uh you run
but then queen g4 is very effective
okay queen g4 then um
forcing the the king into the
the corner
and then i i had some idea for how the
game would end but right now i forgot
what it was
uh oh yeah queen age five followed by uh
knight h6 okay
yeah i know you said hikaru is not a
person who would resign and i think in
the in the world that we are used to
seeing him and accustomed to him being
as resourceful and swindly is swindly a
word swindly as anyone
um i think that's the case but i have a
feeling that if rook f1
is found that uh
we might be
moments away from a handshake
agreed
which is going to be a fantastic start
for karana
and a disappointing start for hikaru
but
that's that's how it works you're uh
you're always going to have a tough time
with the black pieces
and
especially when facing
one of the most difficult opponents
there is fabiano quran
and and uh based on almira's stats this
reinforces
fabiano's
amazing grip against hikaru with the
white pieces yeah he finds work of one
maybe maybe about to find a move we'll
see he might have one less trick in the
books
indeed you're correct he plays bishop to
d5
but elmira as you said there's just
there's a there's a record that fabiano
now has with white against a car despite
switching to e4 here
the last couple of victories did come
from one d4 the trend continues right
fabiano has had success against zecora
recently with white now to be fair
fabiano has success with white against a
lot of players right um but um
yeah i agree with you though hammer this
was an interesting storyline it felt
like hikaru had solved all the opening
problems was in a great space
right we were liking the direction um
and yet here we are probably moments
away from
from the hands being
extended and uh
fabiano's starting off his candidate's
campaign with a victory elmira
yes so we're looking probably at night
h6 here
knight h6 jack any move is winning but
the checks are always going to be the
first thing
these players
explore
and in this case the checks are also
going to yield the decided results
well you know the first game that we uh
had to commentate uh during the second
leg of the candidates is uh
fabiano against maxine rashelagraf you
know when fabiano made the spectacular
sacrifice and the
game lasted for eight hours
uh that was an incredible game
the check is on the board and the key
here is that
icaru played bishop d5 everyone maybe
maybe hoping bobby would go for 96 check
allowing him to play this end game with
rook and bishop versus queen
but knight h6 check is a very different
story because after king to g7
bobby will play queen to g4 check and
continue the attack
with queen g6 being met by knight f5
the hand is extended hikaru resigns
we'll show the line here queen g6
knight to f5 and now if the king touches
the the f-file the knight can go to h4
unleashing a discovered check
and winning the queen
and this is why
hikaru nakamura goes down in his first
game here in madrid i think h7 there is
queen h4 also yeah i will show that real
quick king goes to either either square
on the h file there's queen h4
winning the rook
well there you have it wow what what a
day we already have two decisive games
the first two games to finish
were victories for fabiano caruana and
yon napomnishi respectively
we uh
we got a lot more ahead
but right on the other side of this this
break we'll dive into the other two
games but before we head to that we want
to let you know about a really important
event coming up it's blitz champs for
those who don't know it we have four nfl
superstars before you larry fitzgerald
kayvon thibodeau micah parsons amari
cooper and others are competing in this
incredible event in july
july 9th and 10th we have a hundred
thousand dollars going to charities uh
these guys will be picking their own
cherries of choice it's it's not pog
champs but it's blitz champs and for all
fans of the nfl or really anytime we're
seeing celebrities who we admire in
their own fields competing in chess it's
awesome and uh it brings us brings out
the fans cave on thibodeau of course a
growing star within the chess community
if you guys don't know he has a fan club
you can sign up for it and you should
consider doing it just
just google kvon thibodeau's fan club on
chess.com and you'll find the link once
again it is july 9th and 10th and it is
going to be epic we will be right back
with more action round one of the 2022
feed day candidates continues from
madrid in just a few
[Music]
good afternoon
ladies and gentlemen
and welcome to the opening ceremony of
the world chess championship candidates
tournament
[Music]
[Applause]
hello
did you know you can watch top chess
events right on your phone
you don't even need to download an app
just open any mobile browser and head to
chess.com events
you can see what's happening right now
check out top games
see results
and so much more try it for yourself at
chess.com events
this is going to be a real-time
breakdown of danny wrenches games all
time on chess.com uh that's cool
oh
in the last month i am playing 83.12.
i'm less actor than them in every stage
yeah man that that's things you should
do the more game review okay yeah thanks
a lot okay so tuesday sucks i gotta stop
playing cats on future oh it's because
it's final tuesday
look how many blunders there were back
in december 2020 and now december 2021
1600 don't look at this number
look at look at this number best
let's go to
uh tactics
mates
probably need to work on these ones yep
every single rook fork that has
presented itself to me i have found no
one has a higher percentage of rook
forks than i do
that's correct
these are literally the night forks that
you i missed knight d6 it you saw it
just now what is wrong with me
i could have done here and then taken
this pawn and i'm winning because my
pawns get held together that's probably
the coolest part about this feature like
these positions against pets
rook there for rookie
he plugged his maiden one
oh my goodness i'm awful
the defending champion jan napomnishi is
back at the candidates affecting his
second straight bid to challenge for the
world chess championship
one of the more experienced players nepo
brings to madrid an aggressive style
that is both challenging to face and
entertaining to watch
two years ago nepo made the most of his
debut in the candidates with a round to
spare he won the event in convincing
fashion
that's all he needed yon mushi is the
2021 world chess championship challenger
that victory led nepo to a world
championship match with carlson and also
secured his return to the candidates in
madrid this year
despite being one of only two players in
the field to have won the candidates the
expectations for nepo are not
particularly high this time around
however his confidence from having won
here before in addition to his years of
competitive experience
may offer him a shot to turn some heads
if nepo should pull a major upset and
face magnus carlsen again the two know
each other well
nepo has competed against carlson for
decades ever since the two prodigies
were 12 years old
[Music]
we are back
round one of the 2022 feed a candidates
continues here on chess.com wherever you
may be
thank you for tuning in to the show
today boy has it been an epic day
and we still have a lot more chess to go
as ali reza perugia the rising star
who's turned more heads more heads than
uh than we can count one of them being
magnus carlsen's on his way to the
candidates now has to defend himself
i don't know if it's an easy rook ending
necessarily ibrahimov is going to come
up with tricks here i'll mirror your
thoughts on what what ferrugia needs to
do to really hold this thing to be
honest i feel that rook endings are
never easy you know you have to have so
much knowledge and
even though there is uh
an opinion that all of them
are drawn anyway so yeah you have to be
very precise here especially so um
he's trying uh to bring his king is it
possible
uh
yeah what what is the defensive setup
here let's just
again it's always easier for us than
them we have the engine we have
sometimes the table base
but
if we're just providing some instruction
like what does black want to do to hold
this in like a theoretical sense
maybe first of all you well uh
you should see what white is going to do
i was thinking about rook h5 or k5 then
king h4 king gene 5 something like this
yeah
okay no rajaba
quickly retreats by the way rook b3
threatened the move e4 of course because
the pawn was pinned to the king so rajab
takes care of that problem
hammer i think al mira highlighted a
good point i think there's an idea of
putting the rook on f5 to to add the
instructive point to that everyone from
f5 the rook not only guards f3 which
frees up the king to go on a journey
but it also keeps an eye on the e4 e5
pawn which might be might be tricky for
black to defend so
black will certainly have ideas but the
point is that's maybe a goal square for
white
oh no i was about to say and that's
precisely where rajab is going but he's
not but then he went to a different
square he's still holding i was gonna
say you don't see this that often at a
high level
he
he's still holding his rope so he was
gonna put it in the middle he decided to
put it out on the side of the board yeah
it doesn't make that much of a
difference i believe uh that rook is um
headed for
e3 regardless i'm gonna say i i think
what rajab of now uh what he's concerned
about uh is the fact that the black rook
has that pressure along the third rank
yeah
um and i think hijab feels it's it would
be nice if that pressure could be
um
stopped
so he's gonna try to move his rook down
and then
so he he's gonna go with the rook to to
b2 and then e2
and offer a trade um
and he's he's allowed to do that
uh but basically you were asking about
defensive setup
faruja just wants to keep the status quo
right he wants to
keep the situation where the white pawns
cannot advance
without being punished for it
he wants to trade uh his pawn for one of
the white pawns
um but he's not going to be allowed to
do that
and and that's why this is a difficult
rook ending because
because you can't force anything to
happen you just have to sit and wait and
kind of hope that they go wrong right
because in theory it should be a draw
you said a bunch of really instructive
things that were kind of i think maybe
it could be taken for granted just
already highlighting the idea that the
rook could come here and trade i think
is instructive for viewers because it
reminds us that while the rook ending
has great drawing chances you should
always be aware that the king and pawn
ending is just an easily losing position
so you can you can almost never trade
from a rook ending to a king upon ending
and improve your defensive chances it's
very very rare so so that was really
important and i think hammer you also
quickly pointed out black's goal which
is
if you give black the chance tactically
he would he would trade this pawn for
either of these pawns if he could
somehow magically take them off the
board because
one of the reasons this is hard to
defend and we keep saying
is because
if you had just one pawn
then all you have to do is defend it
there are many well-known philidor
lucina type of drawing positions but
with the threat that white has to not
just have one pawn but maybe somehow
some way trick you into winning a second
pawn that's the thing that makes this
hard to hold so i just wanted to point
out that hammer made really two very
subtle destructive points for black to
draw
never trade rooks if you're taking this
advice for your own games and black's
goal should be to not miss an
opportunity if there's ever a tactical
shot where you could somehow swindle or
trade this pawn don't miss your chance
to do so right elmira
well of course if your kingers is very
close to the pawn then then it's true
yes i saw you nodding your head over
there so i was like right now mira back
me up here
no no okay actually like uh well
what uh alive
is doing here is like uh keeping the
rook on the third file he simply does
not allow white kink to
well to advance well
we'll just show it again because ideas
like this are met with e4 that's that's
the whole point and now now we're
forcing the drawn ending
so i think uh timor played king e2 oh as
ali raza already moved yeah mm-hmm
okay
he's just sitting there yeah he's
waiting
um and that's the key to this end game
with the black pieces
you got to be aware of your opponent's
plans
and you got to have great patience you
got to be ready to just sit there and do
nothing
because doing nothing will end in a draw
eventually in a long
time but it will eventually end in a
draw
and we're actually at five and a half
hours played now so uh the players will
definitely be uh
be feeling some uh
some fatigue yeah at this stage as they
should be it's a long long game we'll
we'll note for
the fans watching who just observed that
the evaluation bar turned gray on our
main board
and that's actually because the table
base has had enough time to think to
confirm that this position is a draw
and so um that's just a
visual way we're bringing that theory to
life and we're not going to sit here and
try to pretend that
that i can just show you the
move force line that the table base says
it was a draw but the point is
um
as we work on on bringing that check to
life as we all know we're just doing
what we can work on the eval bars table
bases try to add some more context
not it hasn't always been perfect but we
had some recent advancements and it's
actually kind of cool that now now once
the table base knows for sure it's a
draw it will turn colors and it also
will tell us if someone makes a blunder
and it goes back
um that will also be an interesting
moment
yeah
not sure we're going to see a blender
here from aloe alareza despite his young
age
he is
more than capable
of defending tricky work endings like
this
and
yeah i don't know what to say about this
danny do you have any quips
to this uh camera angle maybe let's
let's try it i i love what we're
watching right here if
twitch content if we can clip it and
ship it fans i'd be super happy by the
way are those levi jeans
those look like some levi's
you can tell just from
the fibers
i
you know there's only two things i i
recognize better than hikara nakamura
facial expressions and one of them is
the threads on jeans i would bet my life
those are levi's
possibly wranglers if they were the
faded the faded navy blue wrangler brand
which was very popular at some point in
the 90s the faded faded blue
but
but okay there we go
rajab is thinking of course as he
as he kind of should be but we said
we've been applauding and saying from
the beginning that he's not going to
just give the youngest player in the
field to draw elmira he's going to push
it it's the right thing to do
psychologically and also
it's just important that you get
yourself in game shape but that said is
there ever a risk of tiring yourself out
if you try too hard in a situation like
this
well i think that um
this game is actually very important
like for
rajamov because uh
he didn't play a lot recently so playing
such a long game is very important so
you get into shape
yeah so uh even if you play like 120
moves i believe that uh it gives you
also a boost in confidence i agree and
even if it takes a long time and you
still draw the fact that you had a lot
of memories about playing a position you
could win is important so hammer i think
uh
i think we're going to get you on the
telestrator to give our fans some
instructive stuff here
in just a moment maybe maybe right now
if you want to just head on over
i don't know how you're feeling he's
pretty spry that guy as soon as i
as soon as i make a suggestion he tends
to
to jump up real quick and get excited we
all want to stretch our legs but okay we
saw the game between dingley ren and
yana pomnishi end with a victory for the
russian player but we didn't get to see
checkmate on the board so hammer's going
to show us how that game could have
played out
that is precisely what i'm going to be
doing uh this was the position
in that game uh and here
uh the brilliant move from jan
nepamyachi to take down the first
victory of this candidate's tournament
was putting this bishop on a square
where it could be captured by the white
king now why did ding instead resign the
game well because of this well not there
uh because the queen then
uh could make an entrance from the uh
one square
to the second square of the board
forcing the white king further up and
when the pawn also comes in the king is
forced uh basically so that it itself is
an attacking force uh and and here the
black queen would make one of these
quiet moves it's not a check
but it's still gonna be checkmate coming
up because there's no way uh for for
white to stop that queen from coming in
with the checkmate uh later on but i
guess we're gonna go back to you danny
because the game between farouza and raj
above just finished
indeed it did there is a
a quick draw offer from rajabov
he uh
he offers a draw and they
finish and uh
although i i don't see the result just
yet
hammer hammer called for it so i'm
assuming it was a draw but are you sure
it was a draw here no i'm not sure oh
thank you
i think hammer i think hammer assumed it
was a it was a draw but no actually the
game continues rook to e2 from rojava so
hammer
debated debated us big time buddy uh we
appreciate that
uh and uh we won't hold it against you
um
[Music]
what we are going to do now is uh
continue of course talking about a rook
ending that rajab is going to take here
until the cows come home
and
at some point we'll we'll swing back
over to the game with young christophe
duda as well but right now we're
actually joined by
a pretty special person in studio
and uh
i'm i'm gonna shake his hand as he
enters and even if the fans can't see it
you're sitting down in the nice comfy
chair first of all fabi
the main thing everyone wants to know is
how much more comfortable is this chair
compared to where we sat on the couch
for a month in november this is a lot
better this is a lot better right i was
trying to tell people that the lower
back support here is phenomenal right
yeah
i had i had back problems for like a
month after that dude i am so not
kidding i know people i i say ridiculous
things for a living so you saying that
just validated so much because i it was
it was a very it was a very tough set
i'll just say that we were the moment we
were off camera elmira we were standing
up all of us like stretching i had a
massage gun i was massaging bobby's back
with the massage it was it was
absolutely crazy but so from what i
understand i'm feeling fabulous shoes
you are you're filling bobby's shoes
here and and fabi is in the chair
killing robert's shoes robert's shoes
but okay fabiano uh
jokes aside and it was not a joke
huge win
here today congratulations first and
foremost
there's so much we could unpack about
this game and we're excited to have you
with us um
i just want to start with what does that
do for you in a tournament like this
where you know it's a marathon you are
the most experienced candidates player
in the field so there's no way you're
going to let that let your emotions get
the best of you right but you've got to
be feeling pretty excited to start off
with a w
yeah i feel great um
no i'm definitely not letting it you
know
let lay myself
get super excited about this because
it's still only the first game yeah um
but it's always nice to start well and
uh
yeah i you know before the tournament
there's a lot of nerves and you don't
really know how to feel
uh there's a lot of preparation but then
you have to go from that preparation
mindset into the
playing mindset and it's totally
different
um
so i was trying to
you know like be
relatively calm today and take my time
and not rush any decisions it was still
a very nerve-wracking game i'm sure with
many mistakes but overall it's great
yeah
i'll ask a question about preparation i
know elmira had a couple you mentioned
preparation and that transition that
goes from it's no longer time to prepare
it's time to play
what happened in this game you didn't
see it did this go according to plan did
you get what you wanted with white it
felt like at some point hikaru had
equalized and was feeling comfortable
until the decision to maybe castle short
we all were like kind of surprised about
putting the king over there but as much
as you can tell us about your
preparation and and what happened in the
first stage of things how are you
feeling with the white pieces in this
game
yeah well it went relatively according
to plan okay um i wanted to play this
line with knight b3 it's a slightly
unusual move but he's faced it before um
only in uh blitz games on chess.com but
it still counts for something so i'm
sure he knew the move but he decided to
improvise okay he played a bit weird
queen e7 followed by rookie usually if
you play queen e7 you want to castle
along yeah which leads to just an
absolutely crazy fight um so i was
surprised he played queen e7 because i
thought he really wants to cast along
and turn into a pawn race um
and and then he played rook b8 which is
a bit illogical because he if he wanted
that he could have first castled in and
played rook v8 right and queen e7 is is
a not as useful move as castling um
so i was very happy with the position i
got but then after f6 like i think
everything i did up to that point was
was good and then after f6 i'm sure i
misplaced it
queen d3 can't be the way
uh
but i don't know exactly how i i'm
supposed to prove an advantage
i'm pulling that up as we're all
watching the resin match we're spending
some time with bobby so
just because you you mentioned all those
lines that were very interesting again
i'm just going to quickly highlight so
no one feels left in the dark by the
variations our our 2800 player rattled
off went according to playing queen e7
rook beat a slightly unusual move order
especially to commit to it and then and
then still
i guess still eventually as you said
castle
short but the main thing you said is you
felt that the after f6 the position
slipped a little yeah i thought queen d3
like i was hesitating between c3 and
queen d3
and i i just couldn't really decide
like but yeah after i played queen d3
and he played h5 rather quickly i
realized i should have played c3 then i
prepare for h5 with with h4
and uh i'm i'm sure i have some some
advantage here but yeah in the game i
didn't really get anything
and um
and then he was like after i played um
b3
which was
actually it was i think a
psychologically kind of tricky move
because i understand i have nothing and
he's going to play king d7 so i kind of
wanted to dissuade him from king d7 by
by like hinting that i want to play
knight c4 and potentially opening up the
queen side and then like i see him
reaching first king i'm hoping that he's
going to castle uh and finally he did i
was very happy about that well elmira
you want to jump in on that because we
you saw us both nodding so we talked a
lot about that moment in king d7 so go
ahead i'm here no actually i wanted to
well i wanted to have an explanation
behind the b3 moves because it was such
a mysterious i wanted to find something
concrete like c4 b4 you know but b3 is
um
a very nice prophylactic move actually
in a way yeah it's sort of a
prophylactic move after kd7 i'm going to
probably play knight c4 and
uh
and yeah something like this um
but yeah i was just very happy he didn't
play king d7 but i love the
psychological point you made that
you know you kind of baited a little bit
right into into a weird decision right
because elmira and i we spent a lot of
time talking about king d7 and this
whole idea
and uh
a really interesting psychological point
so all right we have a bunch of
questions coming
in for you from shab by the way chat
loves you as if you need to be reminded
of that you uh you became a superstar
commentator um we're all just waiting
for you to just come back to this seat
and commentate with us i'm kidding you
know we're excited you're in the
candidates but um we'll get to some
questions here from chat as uh as they
come in but um
the
let's see so
where did you first feel like you might
have some winning chances yeah after
castle i thought oh already okay well i
mean winning chances in the sense that
i'm playing for an advantage
not
i mean not that you know i have to play
on the be on the defensive and and try
to equalize um but it's clear that i
have no risk here his king is very weak
my king is much safer
uh and
yeah i thought i played it pretty well i
wasn't sure if he would go for d5 but
it's kind of in his style to go for the
most concrete approach rather than wait
around and wait for me to improve i'm
going to take on a fake play knight f1
knight g3
etc so
um
i don't know when it got really bad for
him
but at some point it did i although i
felt like i was playing quite well after
d5 yeah um
yeah but it's of course a tough position
it's more tough for black because he's
the one who can lose while white
you know if you make a slight event a
slight mistake then you might lose your
advantage but uh
but you're never risking
so
and then yeah i i completely messed it
up we have just been joined by babiano
karana who who beats
hikaru nakamura fabi congratulations
some weird audio coming in here well
i'm sure that's supposed to be playing
but it's playing loud and clear so we'll
continue here
um
we're ready for chat's questions
whenever we get them on the screen but
you make a good point that you know
obviously black did have another option
which was to kind of sit tight rook of
seven or rook f6 or something right but
he went for the most concrete approach
and
and maybe maybe it it would have been
okay but you got to be super precise
right you have to play every move
accurately and
and as soon as you had the opportunity
here yeah this move also did surprise me
a bit yeah although i didn't see what he
would do
um i thought rookie is just
like he he's trying to hold on to the
pawn but he ends up with a miserable
position and he's probably going to lose
that pawn anyway
uh
yeah rook f1 was an option i was kind of
hesitating but i decided not to
not to think because in his time control
you don't get an increment and
i figured i would get more important
decisions later on so
i just kind of went with my gut and
my gut was i was wrong
okay well forget forget what the
computer says we we uh we brought you in
studio for the world championship
because we wanted your opinion over the
computer um
well this was a well
a phenomenal game actually i think that
even though there were maybe there were
a few imprecisions like uh
some some chat coming in they love you
fabi just letting you know let you know
i'm pretty sure that dean already asked
you a lot of uh embarrassing questions
you know so yeah
we should we should give shout outs to
the fans because they're they're
screaming go fabi go bobby with emotes
bobby with the hearts it's good to feel
the love right
we have a uh a feature here fabi is such
a sweetheart agreed and you don't even
know him in person he's even sweeter um
but uh or maybe you do captain here
maybe that maybe that's different um
but um
we have a fun feature that we're gonna
have throughout the event which uh
we'll have uh some different subscriber
emotes and whoever's leading the
tournament we're gonna have more emotes
of them on twitch so if you stay in the
lead we might have your face being shown
a lot in chat so we'll see how that
plays out
you play nepo tomorrow
so far you two were the only ones to get
victories today
yeah i was very surprised by that game
he just it looked like he just blew him
off the board yeah um
but i i couldn't really see in much
detail
but he played very well yeah yeah and
that was my feeling that it was a really
good game from his side and something
went wrong with
with either things opening preparation
because it looked like something went
wrong out of the opening
or um
or maybe it was okay but it was just a
complicated position and he misplayed it
but yeah that's that's quite a big game
winning with black
and and also for ding
not a good start but uh
but yeah i guess it's still in the the
first round
and february i just wanted to ask you
about your rituals if you can reveal
those you know for example what would
you do after such a game which was so
intense would you go for a walk
yeah i think first we'll get dinner um
i'm guessing it's rather late although i
don't know the time
and uh and then probably
probably rest a bit maybe focus more on
preparation tomorrow rather than tonight
um
because it is yeah it is quite a long
day it's a long time control so the
games end rather late and uh
um and yeah you don't want to over tire
yourself uh of course like i have
already given some consideration to
what is the balance of that you just
mentioned that
there's a balance between preparation
versus rest
right in a long event like this knowing
you did so much prep to get here
you just you gave a lot of insight with
that comment right how do you balance
your your practical sort of physical and
mental alertness
and health versus versus getting ahead
of the prep yeah well for let's say the
since i was lucky that i knew that i was
playing the candidates already from last
year um i started training
um
like at the start of this year
and
at the start it was more just about the
chess work
and before the tournament it was more
about getting shape and resting a bit
and more of the physical aspect and now
it's
it's just a normal tournament you just
you try to get into the tournament mode
makes sense not very often do we have
two tournament leaders facing in the
second round where they both got
victories in round one but it was the
case with you and napon rishi so thank
you for joining us man we wish you the
best of luck as you know and uh who
knows maybe we'll be talking to you
again tomorrow thanks so much all right
we're gonna go back to the alarism match
now everyone those of you who are
eagerly awaiting
more more news from that there's been
some changes here in rajabov's position
as white but ali reza still still seems
like he's holding
and uh we'll be jumping back into that
one now
all
right well we have
rajaba for ruja
as we said
the king has finally
kind of committed itself i guess up the
board it got it got away from the third
rake third rank breaking if you will
right elmira
and now
now you've got this potential for
shouldering right you've got the king in
a spot where if black makes one mistake
the game could actually get very very
dangerous very quickly like we were
talking about this idea before so that's
the only reasonable plan that you can
find in this position so
uh let's see um
if he plays
hammer your thoughts on this
um
well it's probably going to be a draw uh
but it it still requires caution uh from
olivereza we see he's moved already
putting pressure on that f3 pawn
and what olivereza wants to have happen
is that that pawn takes a step uh
forward
so that black can make the exchange
uh of pawns after which the draw would
be trivial
um
so
i'm not sure what else there is i i
think the king if you want to keep the
pawn on the board the king has to step
back and then it's a repetition of him
and that's why you're thinking it's a
draw here
so like for instance if you try to
protect the pawn by moving the brook
back
then there's once again this idea with
e4
uh and you managed to get the trade of
pawns uh since white's pawn cannot
escape without letting go of the rook
can i try g6
and why g6 here
so king g7 and
yeah
you cannot hide f4 you simply take it
and as hammer already pointed out if the
king goes back well now you're just
right back yeah they agreed to a draw
now check in here for once when i'm
announcing they agreed to draw it's
actually by the way what was that
earlier that you were saying i got i got
a bit of a
i got tricked danny
they reached move 60 and these score
sheets they're signing right now they
only go to move 60. so i saw them
fiddling with their score sheets so i
assumed that they had made a draw so
that okay i'm glad you explained them
because you you you threw me and elmira
off you're like it's a draw and we were
like no it's not so sorry about that but
i was just so stressed out when i saw in
the corner of my eye yeah that something
was happening
and uh yeah well now it did in fact now
they did in fact agree to a draw and we
can note that
rajava basically made a draw offer when
he played that move pawn f4 especially
based on the instructive stuff we were
offering earlier that as soon as a pawn
was traded it would be
very close to a draw but okay
we are very close maybe to round one
going in the books depending on what
duda manages against report but before
we dive into the last game we want to
remind everybody that the chess.com
global championship is ongoing and it is
your chance to play alongside the
world's best players be part of history
on chess.com playing in our largest
tournament ever it's open to everyone
non-titled open qualifiers run every
saturday and sunday through the end of
july this is your opportunity to compete
in events that will have the best
players in the world so what are you
waiting for let's go head over to
go.chess.com
cgc2022 for more information get
verified start playing and try to get
your part in cash prizes
and
we are back to the last game now don't
hold your breath everybody just because
there's only one game left doesn't mean
we don't have a lot more chess ahead and
a lot more instructive moments this is
going to be
this is probably going to become a very
sharp finish right meaning even if it's
a draw this is going to be one of those
draws that is like
very forcing down the stretch elmira i
see you nodding yeah this is a
completely crazy end game you know this
is a race definitely so um
a6
for once they fiddled with their score
sheets without me announcing it
we're gonna hold that against you for
the rest of the event so i'm glad you're
calling yourself on it so i don't have
to um but that being said right now
there's a move for black that makes this
game very easy to call yeah you want to
trade bishops yeah that move is bishop
to d6 okay that is a game ender right
there because the advantage duda has had
over the past couple of moves
have all been about the two bishops
working together supporting that pawn on
a6 which is only two squares away from
becoming a new queen
but black is in time to prevent it uh
from accomplishing just that because
um
the um
the pawn will not be able to safely go
to this a7 and the main reason
yeah because if you play this first
mm-hmm
but then uh i still think that a7
uh you none of the yeah
because a7 you take
king james king takes then bishop c6
because your king is so far away so if i
take an e4 i go knight e3 yeah 93 and
you take knight g2 yes unfortunately yes
and even if i don't take on g6 you take
on g2 and it's a draw for example
if king d4 black can sacrifice that
for the last pawn and for those
hi everyone i'm sorry but we're
experiencing some technical difficulties
here in the studio i hope you'll be
patient with us as we get things in
order before we return back to the
broadcast this video will now play on
loop
hi everyone we're experiencing some
technical difficulties here in the
studio uh well to maintain the pressure
a little bit yeah i'll i'll make the
trade and then i
my idea
uh was to go knight e7
it's funny this is this is super
important just to show because the
reason elmira's move order matters is if
you don't play knight e7 the bishop will
come to c6 first unlike a7 king b7 and
then we get a big trade of pawns in this
position just to make a move elmira is
threatening bishop c6 which prevents
king b7 actually
there was brilliant danny
what 93 yeah
oh because you can play this first
because now if king b6 i can go knight
c4 i accidentally play brilliant moves
all the time i'll have you know yeah i'm
i'm pretty good at it but if i
play bishop b4
we still don't know we actually do have
bishop b6 on the board although i think
our transmission is dead anyway so
so we shall wait no we're back
king c4
yeah no
king c4 is
it's an interesting test but i also did
notice that the the eval bar
made a bit of a a change so
to me i feel like it's logical to to put
the maximum pressure
and try to make this trade like you
you're suggesting
um but with danny's uh accidentally
brilliant move oh stop it
uh
i made that king c4 it feels pretty it
feels pretty effective for for black so
let's run over the moves again the point
is you can actually play something like
this because bishop c6
uh
oh z2 now i'm ahead of the game so i
can't play bishop c6 can you make
another accident well
as i said i've been known from time to
time to blunder myself into a bouncing
e-bell bar
um but uh yeah so this e3 move is
recommended by the computer but also
danny's knight e3
is a very clean way of
forcing into a draw
because the idea that we both kind of
assumed was there
with the the bishop coming in to take
control of the a8 square which is the
queening square that forces black to
step back with their king
to keep the a7 square
uh under tabs
and now the reason i dismissed this move
initially was because of king b6
but knight c4 check we looked at that
right with king b6 trying to get that
checkmate but then the knight returns
same but if bishop b4 there's a funny
you play king a7 first and it's easy
because then you simply overload the
bishop on b7 with knight takes g2
captures captures and we have a draw i
was just pointing out that if you got
sloppy and played this move first
now you actually lose because the bishop
can actually both guard b7 and the
diagonal and uh
and i think this king is actually in
time no maybe well if you go king b5
instead danny okay yeah that's the key
king to b5
and on a move like this you can simply
force your way through uh the king would
back up and white would go on to win so
okay very interesting duda has played
another move after bishop d6 he
responded with a7 yeah and this game is
going to be done in a minute now both
players have
like they only have one good move for
the next
five moves right and then they're not
gonna have enough uh pieces left to uh
to win the game so this game is going to
be a draw in
two minutes two minutes yes okay someone
put them on the clock i got it it's 8 59
p.m here local madrid time
if it is a second longer than two
minutes you are in timeout yeah no
actually two minutes was way too two
minutes is too long yeah way too long
team to be seven i just didn't dare say
one minute because rockport was
doing something with this uh score
okay he was writing something down i'm
not sure why
well that means unless we see something
catastrophic we will be calling day one
of the 2022 feed a candidates tournament
with a split down the middle two
decisive games
two drawn games uh
maybe
maybe two games you thought would be
decisive coming in maybe not you don't
even know right in the end
all of these games delivered as far as
i'm concerned in regards to excitement
and fighting chess
and i couldn't be more excited for what
we have in store there you go we got you
on the clock hammer
one i think you guys were a little
generous yeah
i should have said one minute i regret
it i feel like that was
they were a little generous to you
i feel like they started that clock a
little late but maybe i'm wrong you know
vic is pretty smooth he's pretty fast
with that stuff so we'll give him the
credit and indeed with hands are shaking
you are right hammer it ended in less
than two minutes
and uh
wow what a game what a game
today is clearly disappointed
he um
he had such a good position after
well coming after
out of the opening so
he did indeed uh he had a
honestly if you asked us 20 minutes into
the round which game we had to pick is
decisive it might have been this one
yeah right for those of you who missed
the beginning
due to
dude played a really interesting
approach had a fantastic position and um
and let it slip away he will he'll be
taking a look at it with a little bit of
regret for sure elmira
i i think even though it ended in a draw
this feels like a loss for duda yeah
yeah it's interesting i feel the same
way and i didn't even play the game i
also feel like i lost
they continue to analyze you know it's
like you while they're signing the score
sheets they still
share their ideas yeah
well for sure right and uh
it makes sense
with a light blue jacket i think that
was the second light blue jacket we saw
in the field today
so uh there's some
fashionistas the other the other one was
worn by yon napomnishi who got the w
yeah that's right that's right okay
well here we are day one is in the books
i don't know any other cue than to just
say hammer your major takeaway after
what we've seen here from round one in
madrid
i think for me there were two big
favorites in this field ding and karana
karana goes ahead and wins his game ding
loses with the white pieces
i i think by now fabiano is a big
favorite uh to take this home
there's still 13 more rounds to go
uh but you know
you build confidence yeah by by winning
uh and and fabiano just got off to a
great start yeah elmira
your your thoughts well i was actually
thinking about the 14 rounds you know if
there would be 12 then i would talk i
would be talking about tasks you know
like killing the lion you know
killing the
hydra yes like in english you say hydra
the one hydra hydra hydra yes hydra so
sorry so it's like killing the hydro
like every day one more so like the
you should realize the immensity of this
task what what do you need to do to
qualify for the match so
um
i'm really impressed by fabi's game
so um
[Music]
especially tomorrow like we have uh
nipple playing
with white against fabi so is he going
to
try to maintain the momentum so it would
be very interesting uh to see
well someone's going to have momentum
because nepal actually the other one and
and upon russia gets white i believe so
that'll be interesting not to say he
needs it apparently he gets wins with
black against dingley ren but okay well
let's let's bring up the scores for
today and show everybody what they were
uh as we've been talking about
highlighting the two decisive games we
should also point out the two of the
games were drawn as you just saw due to
report uh it feels like a bit of a loss
for duda although it is his first
candidate so you will give him some
credit some time to get comfortable for
ruja played aggressive enterprising
chess and exchange sacrifice that at one
point was the talk of the round it did
peter out at some point and rajava was
the one pushing before that one
ultimately ended in peace so there we
have it
as we said this this round for sure
delivered
every game was exciting um and uh
it already it already has me wanting
wanting more i you know i want to give a
little bit of a shout out to the to the
two losers too in terms of not like
not adding extra drama but there's
there's a lot going on there right as
far as riding your ship right so dingley
wren loses knowing the pressure knowing
that he's a pre-term favorite hikaru
also has a lot of pressure on he said so
himself in the article that he recently
did the interview he did for chess life
right so
take me into the the camp you were one
point a second for magnus carlsen what
what are you doing in the camp of
helping their heads be in the right
space to recover from a loss well the
advantage of being in magnus carlson's
team
is that he never really loses okay that
was a horrible answer okay
i i never had to deal with that i i was
um one the main helper for magnus during
the 2013 match against anand yeah and
that was a match magnus won with three
victories and zero defeats and not only
did one splash in the pool lose
uh he was never in trouble yeah
okay so you don't have good advice for
them thanks amber almira good advice for
the people who lost their first game it
is a marathon just like it is for the
winners to not get ahead of themselves
for the losers one loss is not going to
define the tournament if you can make
sure that the bleeding stops well first
of all you well you need to get a good
very good night's sleep you know this is
absolutely essential and then
uh it's a clean slate you have to start
all over again it's a new tournament
okay that's
how well the russian school the soviet
school
yeah you heard it from elmira you have
to start again it's a new tournament
those will be the pairings for the brand
new tournament uh we see that uh
report for ruja
again two players competing in their
first candidates nakamura going he's the
second oldest player in the field going
up against the oldest there but he gets
the white pieces uh with a chance to as
elmira said start a new tournament
nepo and caruana don't want it to be a
new tournament they're happy with their
victory but i mean yeah we can't wait we
already know which matchup we're
circling for tomorrow right mark it it's
in the books napomnishi versus caruana
just did our job for us and then of
course we have duda and ding as well
hammer so your thoughts on i guess i
stole some thunder i think it's napan
nashikarwana but any other matchups you
want to talk about for tomorrow um i i'm
interested in this rapport versus
farouza okay both players today proved
that they're willing to take enormous
risks to try and win games even with the
black pieces two such risk takers up
against each other that just has to be
fireworks okay elmira as we look at
those uh those three events sorry those
other three matchups your thoughts on
another one well those matchups
disappeared but actually and what i
wanted to add is just that i cannot even
imagine like uh the cows there these two
players are going to create tomorrow
right richard against early so uh like
some it's going to be uh
well probably a tactical squirmish like
on the board like all the way so let me
have a look um
so we are not allowed to talk about
nepocharwana
you can talk about whatever you want i
was just i stole the thunder and said
that's clearly the matchup we're all
going to be talking about but duda has a
a one loss record and one draw to
dingley ren so that's you know not too
much there no but i think this is also a
very important game because duda starts
with uh white you know he has two whites
so he didn't uh convert his game today
so it might add up to a disappointment
so he is going certainly
and try to play for a win tomorrow
but
if you are not well winning at least one
game with the white pieces in the
beginning of the tournament then you
know
you start doubting yourself so i think
this is a very important moment for
young sister i think that's a really
good point and of course
dingley wren
definitely does not want to lose a
second game in a row you do not want to
miss a moment of the action of course
the 2022 candidates
tournament starts off at 6 00 a.m on the
west coast 9 a.m in new york 3 p.m local
time here of course
in madrid 2 p.m in london i could read
every time you could just take a peek at
whatever time zone you are closest to
and of course uh circle your calendars
we have so much more ahead uh the
candidates will continue to roll on for
many many days many live audience
members don't want to believe that it's
over they're listening in to uh to an
interview with richard reports so uh
so good for them tuning in there
but there you have it that is round one
it is in the books the stage has been
set so much more ahead we have the two
early tournament leaders facing off
tomorrow you're not gonna want to miss
anything and that's gonna wrap our day
here so for my team working super hard
for my two co-hosts here young lovely
camera almeros kripchenko i'm danny
wrench this has been chess.com coverage
of the 2022 feed a candidates we will be
back for round two from madrid tomorrow
and we'll see you then
[Music]
do
you